Ihr hört CRE Technik Kultur Gesellschaft und das hier ist die 206.
Ausgabe davon. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlav und ja, it's been a while.
Manch einer mag geglaubt haben, da kommt ja nichts mehr. Weit gefehlt.
Eigentlich ist meine Liste der Themen unbegrenzt lang, nur die Liste der potenziellen
Gelegenheiten, die ist manchmal etwas schwierig. Nichtsdestotrotz, Trotz.
Heute wollen wir mal wieder in ein schönes Thema einsteigen,
was für meinen Geschmack auch mal wieder hier diese ganzen Kategorien wunderbar zusammenbringt.
Konkret soll es gehen um das Ohr und das ganze Hörsystem. Wie hören wir,
warum hören wir und all das.
Und da begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner den Stefan. Stefan Brill.
Hallo, guten Tag. Hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo Tim.
Äh, ja Stefan, du bist, ähm, was bist du denn genau? Wie nennt man das?
Ja, man könnte sagen, ich bin Audiologe. Ich bin aber auch Ingenieur.
Audiologe. Jemand, der sich mit der Hörforschung beschäftigt.
In dem Sinne bei Pathologie.
Also wenn jetzt Gehörstörungen vorliegen, was kann man da machen?
Von der Herkunft her bin ich eigentlich Ingenieur. Ich habe natürlich auch so
eine Nerdquelle, warum ich Ingenieur geworden bin und habe mich mal in meiner
späten Jugend für digitale Technik begeistert.
Das war also wirklich noch mit Ant- und Nandgattern und allem Möglichen.
In welchem Jahrhundert hätte ich was gesagt?
Anfang des 80er Jahre war das.
Also ich habe mich da begeistert für Digitaltechnik und da war das noch gar
nicht so selbstverständlich, dass man Dinge mit Mikroprozessoren gemacht hat.
Die gab es natürlich schon. Das war so die Zeit, wo es den 8080 gab und den
Z80 und diese Prozessoren.
Und dann ist auch die Homecomputer-Geschichte langsam losgegangen.
Ja, das war eigentlich noch so kurz davor. Kurz davor war das.
Die Homecomputer-Startgeschichte habe ich natürlich dann auch mitbekommen und mitgemacht.
Und das war so eine der Gründe, warum ich mich damals entschieden habe,
Elektrotechnik und Informationstechnik zu studieren. Ich hatte dann,
Natürlich die üblichen Bastelleien, die man da so macht, hab natürlich auch
so im Studium versucht, eine Band zu gründen. Und da haben wir natürlich mehr
an der Elektronik herum gebastelt, als dass wir Musik gemacht haben.
Da haben wir auch ganz völkerlich geworden alles.
Und dann hatte ich...
Audio war dann sozusagen schon Thema, wenn du Musik gemacht hast?
Audio war für mich privat schon ein Thema. Ja, und ich hatte dann aber auch
das Glück, das war eigentlich eher Zufall, dass ich in meinem Studium eine Spezialisierungsrichtung
einschlagen konnte. Das nannt sich damals Kybernetik.
Das hatten die in München, also an der TU München, hatten die so eine Spezialrichtung aufgemacht,
wo die mehrere Forscher sich zusammengetan hatten und gesagt haben,
wir wollen mal unsere ganzen mathematischen Methoden, die die Informationstechnik,
Informations- und Signalverarbeitung so bietet, was man eben in der E-Technik
lernt, anwendet auf biologische Systeme.
Und da gab es dann einige Forscher, die dann extra reinkamen an die TU und dann
da Lehre gemacht haben darüber.
Und es gab aber auch einen, der mir natürlich besonders in Erinnerung geblieben
ist. Das war ein Institut, was direkt an der TU war. Die haben sich mit Akustik
beschäftigt. Der Chef von denen hieß Zwicker.
Das ist so einer der Päpste der Psychoakustik.
Psychoakustik ist jetzt also die Erforschung der subjektiven Hörwahrnehmung
mit geradezu physikalischen Methoden.
Und das hat mich dann völlig begeistert. Das war also ganz toll,
dass die dort Methoden entwickelt hatten mit den, also nicht nur die,
das war natürlich woanders entwickelt worden, aber die haben dort geforscht.
Eberhard Zwicka.
Eberhard Zwicka, genau.
Und der sogar eigene Units aufgemacht hat, hier Zwicka-Parameter und so.
Ja, genau. Und der hatte dort ein Institut, das stand damals noch in voller
Blüte und hatte noch andere Professoren, ein Teerhardt und ein Fastel und natürlich
jede Menge Assistenten.
Und das hat mich wirklich begeistert. Und ich habe bei denen unter anderem eine
Studienarbeit gemacht, also so eine Projektarbeit neben dem Studium her,
da ging es dann schon um digitale Signalprozessoren.
Das kamen dann auch schon wieder der eine Zweig mit dem anderen zusammen.
Und habe dann aber meine Abschlussarbeit nicht bei denen gemacht,
sondern bin dann in der Medizintechnikfirma, habe ich das gemacht.
War auch Signalverarbeitung drin, da ging es aber um so kardiologische Sachen,
also Herzparameter, Herzschlag, Druckkurven und so weiter. Und dann...
War ich fertig mit dem Studium und dann waren inzwischen die
Anfang der 90er und dann bin ich natürlich wie alle nach Berlin und
Berlin war ja damals großartig so 1990 bis 92
und dann ging mir aber so nach
und nach das Geld aus und dann habe ich wieder geguckt überregional und ich
saß dann gerade hier in Berlin und hatte in ich weiß nicht in einer von den
großen Tageszeitungen hatte ich eine Anzeige gesehen von einer Firma die was
machen wollten oder die was geplant hatten,
was eigentlich alle Dinge, die ich, die ich machte und die mich interessierten
sozusagen auf einen Punkt brachten.
Und da habe ich mich dann halt gemeldet und zufällig war dann die Firmenchefin
war auch gerade zufällig in Berlin, mit der habe ich mich dann hier getroffen.
Habe ich mich im Foyer der Charité habe ich mich getroffen und die erzählte
mir dann von Cochlea Implantaten.
Erstaunlicherweise hatte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt, obwohl ich so verschiedene Verbindungen dazu hatte,
noch nie was davon gehört, aber das Konzept war mir sofort eingängig,
nämlich dass man den Hörnerv, wenn jetzt das Innenohr nicht mehr akustisch hören
kann, dass man den ja eigentlich elektrisch reizen können müsste.
Und so habe ich dann bei denen angefangen und wahrscheinlich,
weil ich irgendwie diese ganze Vorgeschichte so...
Also es war quasi eine Firma, die konkret auf solche Implantate spezialisieren
wollte. Korrekt, ja. Also war das damals nur eine Idee oder gab es das im Prinzip?
Das gab es schon.
Die Kochler-Implantate, ach da gibt es eine ganz lange Vorgeschichte.
Also das ging eigentlich schon los mit Alessandro Volta. Der hat sich nämlich
schon eine Elektrode in den Gehörgang gesteckt.
Der von dem Volt?
Ja, nachdem das Volt genannt ist.
Und der hatte... Der totale Freak.
Ja, da gab es einen, der war noch ein härterer Freak. Ein gewisser Herr Ritter.
Aber der Volta... Herr Amper.
Der Ritter war sehr interessant, den kennt nur kein Schwein.
Das ist also wirklich eine fast schon sträfliche Vernachlässigung,
dass man den nicht kennt. Johann Wilhelm Ritter.
Der Volta, das muss so ungefähr 1798 gewesen sein,
der hat sich also von seiner elektrischen Säule, das waren noch diese elektroschemischen
Säulen, hat er sich eine Elektrode ins Ohr gesteckt und hat ein brutzelndes
Geräusch gehört, ist, glaube ich, in Ohnmacht gefallen.
Und als er dann wieder aufgewacht ist, hat er dann so ein Paper geschrieben,
auf Lateinisch, glaube ich noch, wo er diese Erfahrung beschreibt.
Und dann gab es aber einen Herrn Ritter, der lebte in Jena damals und das war
einer der Leute, die wirklich die Elektrochemie mitbegründet haben.
Der hat unter anderem den Vorläufer des wiederaufladbaren galvanischen Element
des Akkumulators entwickelt. der hat.
Den ultravioletten Spektralanteil im Sonnenlicht entdeckt.
Der wäre also nach heutigen Maßstäben wäre der lockerer Nobelpreisträger,
aber den kennt keine Sau.
Und er hat mit sich selber alle möglichen Dinge ausprobiert.
Der hat also den elektrischen Strom auf sich wirken lassen, bis er kann schon
sagen, bis er Invalide war.
Der hat sich die und das geht endlos. Dicht die Zinkelektrode ins linke Auge
und die Kupfer ins Recht und hat dann detailliert beschrieben,
was er für ein rotes Flackern gesehen hat und dann die eine Elektrode in die
Nase und die andere ins Auge und was er dann empfunden und wahrgenommen hat.
Und der hat das eben auch mit dem Ohr gemacht.
Der hat das alles, also das ist ja jetzt echt ein blödes Klischee,
aber der Volta als Italiener, der macht eine Sache,
fällt in Ohnmacht und schreibt drüber und der andere,
der geht bis zur Grenze seiner physischen körperlichen Fähigkeit,
das auszuhalten und beschreibt das alles im Detail.
Und dieser Ritter, der hat publiziert in den Analen der Physik,
das ist ja jetzt nun eine renommierte Zeitschrift, da ist ja einsteins e gleich
mc quadrat dann veröffentlicht worden,
die war zu dem Zeitpunkt damals gerade, ich glaube zwei Jahre gegründet worden und der hat dann,
ich denke das muss so 1800 bis 1802 muss das gewesen sein,
da hat der Ritter all diese Dinge beschrieben und da gibt es dann unter anderem eine Publikation,
ich glaube die geht über 60 Seiten, wo er in blumigen Worten all das beschreibt,
was er damit sich ausprobiert hat und so einer seiner Schlusssätze ist,
also das mit dem Gehör, das war so ungefähr das Schlimmste, das ist jetzt nur
so inhaltlich wiedergegeben, wortwörtlich kriege ich das nicht und das geht
jetzt alles nicht mehr, das möchten doch bitte andere nach ihm,
möchten das doch weiterführen, diese Experten.
Und dann hat es die das ganze 19. Jahrhundert hat jede Menge so Charlatane gegeben,
die dachten, na ja, wenn wir da Elektronen ins Ohr halten, dann können wir das
heilen und das hat logischerweise alles nicht funktioniert.
Und der erste wirkliche Zeitpunkt, wo man sagen kann, hier ist das mal ernsthaft
versucht worden. Das war 1957 in Frankreich.
Da hat es zwei Franzosen gegeben, ein Ingenieur und ein Chirurg.
Und die haben wirklich den Ansatz gemacht, eine Elektrode ins Innenohr einzusetzen
oder unmittelbar vor das Innenohr.
Hatten das mit zwei Patienten gemacht und bei einem hat das Erfolg gehabt. Der hörte was?
Natürlich auf einem ganz anderen Niveau, hat er also Höherwahrnehmungen und
irgendwelche Töne, muss man dazu sagen.
Der vorher gar nicht hören konnte?
Der war vollständig taub, war offensichtlich sehr verzweifelt,
dass er überhaupt keine Höherwahrnehmung mehr hatte.
Hatte allerdings auch eine schwere andere Krankheit, die ihn...
Also jemand, der schon mal vorher gehört hat sozusagen?
Jemand, der normal hören kann, vorher mal. Und dann hatte der aus Gründen,
die ich jetzt nicht mehr weiß, findet man natürlich irgendwo in Publikationen
drin, hatte der sein Gehör verloren und diese beiden, der Chirurg und der Ingenieur,
die haben dann gesagt, na vielleicht kann man da was machen.
Und der Ingenieur hat dann ein Implantat sozusagen am Küchentisch,
könnte man heute sagen, gebastelt und der Chirurg hat das eingesetzt.
Und der Patient hörte tatsächlich was, hat aber natürlich keine komplexen Hörwahrnehmungen
damit gehabt, also konnte keine Sprache.
Man hat überhaupt erst mal rausgefunden, dass es überhaupt geht.
Bevor uns hier die Pferde durchgehen mit zu viel Details,
weil sicherlich diese Implantatarbeit, an der du ja viel arbeitest,
das ist eine der Dinge, auf die wir hier noch zu sprechen kommen wollen.
Aber ich denke, um überhaupt erst mal verstehen zu können, was sich hier eigentlich
abspielt in unserem Kopf, müsste man da einfach auch noch mal ein bisschen ein bisschen reinschauen.
Ich denke, was für jeden so ein
bisschen klar ist, ist, dass diese ganze Hörgeschichte extrem komplex ist.
Wie auch unser Sehvermögen ist, ist das einfach so eins dieser Wunder,
wo man sich immer denkt, wie schaffen wir das insbesondere.
Das Problem ist, der ja
genauso auch bewusst und ich denke jeder der sich auch
so im Computerbereich mal so ein bisschen
mit Audio auseinandergesetzt hat also um aus solchen digitalisierten Audiodaten
überhaupt relevantes heraus zu holen und
da irgendwas drin zu entdecken bis hin zu solchen Konzepten wie Spracherkennung
und so weiter war ja ein ein sehr langer Weg und auch heute ist ist ja auch
immer noch verbaut an manchen Stellen also vieles geht auf eine beeindruckende
Art und Weise sofern man die Messergebnisse gut isoliert bekommt oder von vorne
rein in eine definierte,
isolierte Umgebung aufgenommen hat.
Aber so diese gesamte Komplexität des Gehörs ist natürlich eine ganz andere Sache.
Jetzt hat man wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal ein bisschen rumgeschnippelt am Menschen,
das wahrscheinlich schon eher früh und festgestellt, Da ist ja so allerlei mechanisch
anmutende Geschichte zu finden. Wenn man jetzt versucht.
Zu verstehen, was führt dazu, dass wir hören?
Also was führt dazu, dass wir aus letztlich, es ist ja nur Schalldruck in der
Luft, dass wir da so komplexe Informationen heraus hören können?
Wo, wo fängt das an? Wo, wo, wo?
Wie entwickelt sich das? Wie kommt das in den Kopf?
Ja, es geht natürlich los mit der Schallwelle, die von irgendwo her auf uns eintrifft.
Und wenn man jetzt das mal von außen anschaut, dann haben wir natürlich erstmal das Außenohr.
Außenohr ist so mehrfach gefalteter Knorpel und das ist so ein bisschen trichterförmig
und was natürlich besonders wichtig ist,
wir haben zwei davon und wir können mit jedem gewissermaßen unabhängig hören
und können dadurch zum Beispiel Richtungsinformationen extra...
Das ist eigentlich bei allen Tieren so. Also zumindest bei allen Säugetieren
eigentlich so zwei Ohren ist schon der Goldstandard ein bisschen.
Das ist der Goldstandard.
Jetzt muss man natürlich dazu sagen, das ist teilweise extrem abhängig davon, was die hören müssen.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt mal ein Extrembeispiel,
es gibt zum Beispiel Nachtfalter.
Die haben ein Hörorgan, das darauf spezialisiert ist, die von Fledermäusen ausgesendeten
Schallwellen, die ja zur Echolotortung in der Nacht dienen.
Ultraschall.
Das ist ziemlich hoch im Ultraschallbereich. Die haben also spezielle Hörorgane
für den Zweck, diese Jagdrufe der Fledermäuse zu hören.
Und sobald dieses Hörorgan das bemerkt, lassen die sich fallen wie ein Stein und sind dann
hoffentlich aus deren sicht aus der flugbahn der fledermaus
raus das ist schon mal so ein ganz extremes beispiel ganz
anderes extrem beispiele ist sind
die organe der zeta-10 also der meereszeuger die haben ja auch einerseits ein
echolot zeta-10 glaube ich heißen die also wale delfine ich glaube die Ich bin
kein Biologe, ich bin mir da mal was schief geht.
Den Begriff kannte ich jetzt auch gerade noch nicht, aber schauen wir mal, ich sprühe weiter.
Mit C.
Cetardiodactyla, sozusagen.
Ja, aber die haben natürlich auch ihre speziellen Notwendigkeiten.
Die haben natürlich auch einerseits
diese Echolotortung, haben dafür sogar speziell geformte Schallinsen.
Das ist dann vorne so im Vorderkopf diese große… Ach so, Cetacea ist der wissenschaftliche Name für Wahl.
Ja.
Okay, alles klar. Und die haben dann auch Frequenzbereiche, die sie hören,
die sind komplett am anderen Ende des Spektrums.
Die gehen sehr tief ins Niederfrequente hinein und die haben dann teilweise
richtig schwere, knöchernde, massive Strukturen, die in Höhlungen aufgehängt
sind und die dann diese tieffrequenten Schwingungen wahrnehmen können.
Und da gibt es dann auch natürlich wieder sensorische Organe,
also Nervenzellen, die dann diese Schwingungen aufnehmen können.
Wie tief geht das bei Wahlen?
Das kann ich nicht sagen, das weiß ich nicht. Also das geht sicher weit,
weit unterhalb von dem, was wir so hören. Aber bei uns ist wo Schluss? 20, 20 Hertz.
Das heißt, die könnten vielleicht auch noch so zwei Hertz hören.
Also ganz sicher bin ich mir nicht, das müssen wir nahe, da will ich mich nicht
allzu sehr aus dem Fenster legen.
Aber tief halt.
Ja und bei dem, was uns für uns so wichtig ist oder was unsere humane Hörfähigkeit
angeht, gucken wir uns natürlich am ehesten die Landseugetiere an.
Die Landseugetiere, die hören natürlich Luftschwingungen und haben bewegliche
Außenohren, Wenn es zu Tieren geht, die jetzt...
Zum Beispiel gejagt werden, dann können die ihren Kopf in eine bestimmte Richtung
halten, aber die Außenohren können sich drehen. Bei uns ist das fast vollständig weg.
Wir haben noch so ganz wenige Ansätze davon. Wir haben noch so ein paar kleine Muskeln am Außenohr.
Gibt ja so Leute, die können so mit den Ohren wackeln.
Ja, genau. Also wir haben da tatsächlich noch Muskeln, also sogar außen auf
der Rückseite am Knorpel und innen drin ganz winzige, die auch noch innoviert sind.
Aber das reicht bei uns nicht mehr aus, dass wir unsere Ohren noch irgendwo
gezielt hin drehen können. Aber so eine Antilope zum Beispiel,
die kann das machen. Die kann also gezielt ihr Ohr in eine bestimmte Richtung
drehen und dann gucken, ob da was ist.
Und bei uns ist es dann so, das Ohr ist aber etwas seltsam gefaltet.
Da kann man sich ja fragen, warum ist das nicht einfach nur so ein Trichter?
Aber diese Faltungen des Ohres, zumindest ist das eine gängige,
weitgehend akzeptierte Theorie, warum das so ist,
die haben aus verschiedenen Einfallswinkeln,
sind die natürlich unterschiedlich groß, und da kommt es zu Schallauslöschungen,
so nach dem Motto stehende und reflektierte Wälder, gibt es halt so Schallauslöschungen
bei bestimmten Frequenzen.
Und wir können dadurch, dass wir jetzt diese gefalteten Außenohren haben,
haben wir in unterschiedliche Richtungen nach oben,
nach unten, haben wir unterschiedliche Frequenzen,
bei denen diese Auslöschungen stattfinden und haben so also,
was mit zwei Ohren ja eigentlich nicht zu erklären ist, wieso können wir eigentlich
die Höhe hören oder wie hoch das Signal über uns ist, haben dadurch zumindest
in Ansätzen eine Möglichkeit, die Richtung in der Höhe.
Also sprich Elevationswinkel, heraus hören zu können.
Aber das Wesentliche, wofür unsere zwei Ohren taugen, ist, dass wir Differenzen
in den Schallsignalen, die die beiden Ohren erreichen, wahrnehmen können.
Da gibt es im Wesentlichen drei Unterschiede. Wenn wir mal vorstellen,
ganz rechts von mir habe ich eine Schallquelle sitzen, dann kommt natürlich
das Signal von dem rechts von mir stehenden Lautsprecher am rechten Ohr früher an.
Zweitens kommt es natürlich lauter an, weil das Schaltsignal muss um den Kopf
rumlaufen und auf der anderen Seite kommt es nicht in derselben Intensität an.
Und es kommt auch spektral anders an. Also das Direkt Einfallende,
das ist spektral in erster Linie ungefiltert und das, was um den Kopf rumlaufen
muss, da schaffen es die tiefen Frequenzen besser rum als die hohen Frequenzen.
Das ist also spektral auch nochmal etwas geändert.
Diese Differenzen ist unter… Man hört weniger Hochantrag.
Ja, genau. Man hört weniger Hochfrequenzen.
Und die Schallpegeldifferenzen zwischen den beiden Ohren, die Schalllaufzeitdifferenzen
zwischen den beiden Ohren und in drittem,
nicht ganz so ausgeprägten Maß, die spektralen Unterschiede zwischen den beiden
Signalen, die wir bekommen, die dienen unserem Gehirn dazu, die Richtung heraus hören zu können.
Und das geht außerordentlich gut. Das ist natürlich etwas, was in der horizontalen
Ebene um uns herum möglich ist, weil nur nur in der horizontalen Ebene kriegen
wir Unterschiede zwischen beiden Ohren.
Wenn ein Signal genau frontal vor uns ist und einfach nur hoch oder runter bewegt
wird, kriegen beide Ohren dasselbe Signal.
Und dafür brauchen wir diese Faltungen. Da gibt es dann Reflektionen,
je nachdem, dass eher von oben und so reflektiert oder eher von da und ein bisschen
anders mit einem etwas anderen Weg reflektiert.
Sind diese Auslöschungsfrequenzen oder sagen wir mal lieber die Frequenzen,
bei denen dann Auslöschung stattfindet, sind je nach Einfallswinkel ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Da ist unser Gehirn offensichtlich in der Lage, das zu nutzen, um eine...
Höheninformationen über das eintreffende Schallsignal heraus zu extrahieren.
Was würde denn jetzt passieren, wenn ich mir irgendwie eine Rolle Gaff annehme
und mir einfach mal meine Ohrwasche irgendwie zu tape?
Und nur ein Loch offen lassen?
Ja, also sagen wir mal überhaupt so diese ganze typische Knorpelkonstellation
da mit diesen ganzen Gängen, also wenn man, wenn man oder einfach das Ohr einfach
nur so glatt an den Kopf Und außerdem, also das Loch bleibt offen.
Und man würde aber alle... Aber der Rest wäre quasi so glatt abgeklebt, wie es nur denkbar wäre.
Wie es nur irgendwie geht. Dann würde man viele Dinge noch immer ganz gut können.
Also man würde noch wissen, woher was kommt in der Ebene, aber in der Höhe würde
man relativ orientierungslos werden.
Es hat sogar schon Experimente gegeben, wo man Aufnahmen, Kunstkopfaufnahmen
gemacht hat, wo man dann...
Also eine Aufnahme, wo man so eine Kopfform nimmt, der...
Mit, mitsamt dran geformten Ohren. Genau.
Wo man dann Ohren und Kopfform von jemandem anderes nimmt, zum Beispiel von
einem großgewachsenen Menschen, und das einem klein gewachsenen Menschen vorspielt und umgekehrt.
Und die haben dann tatsächlich auch in der Höhenlage, haben die bestimmte Fehlannahmen,
wenn man ihnen das dann über geeignete Kopfhörer vorspielt, haben dann Fehlannahmen
darüber, aus welcher Höhe das jetzt kommt.
Das ist ja interessant, bei Kopfhörern geht ja dann quasi dieser Effekt verloren.
Ja, Kopfhörer ist natürlich so, diese klassischen Kopfhörer,
die wir so kennen, so wie wir sie jetzt aufhaben, die sitzen ja über dem Außen
oder drüber, das ist damit weitestgehend, aber nicht vollständig eliminiert
in seinen Eigenschaften.
Was man eigentlich machen muss, man muss dann wirklich direkt mit dem Stöpsel
in den Gehörgang reingehen und muss das natürlich alles ganz im Ohrhörer nehmen
und muss das alles so sauber präparieren,
dass man alle Fehlerquellen eliminiert. Das ist also schon so.
Kannst du das irgendwie so in Ihr Kopfhörer ertragen?
Ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich habe so ein Babel in meinem Ohr.
Ich finde die ganz schlimm.
Es gibt ja die, die auch so speziell an den Gehörgang, also an den eigenen Gehörgang
angepasst sind. Da mag das dann vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so störend sein.
Ich habe es auch nicht, aber von mir selber extrapoliere ich,
dass das fürchterlich ist.
Dauer mag ich das. Okay, das macht man sich glaube ich schon mal gar nicht so
klar, dass jetzt so dieser Ohrwaschel da so eine große Rolle spielt.
Und bei Leuten, die was weiß ich, irgendwelche Verletzungen haben,
denen mal vielleicht ein Teil des Ohres abhanden gekommen ist,
passt sich dann das Ohr dann daran an?
Ja, also die haben ja meistens dann, wenn es eine Verletzung ist,
auf der anderen Seite noch eins und dann kann unser Gehirn ist da offensichtlich
so flexibel, dass es da durchaus sich wieder einiges rausholen kann.
Es dauert sich ja eine Weile, bis man da wieder rankommt.
Dinge, die man nicht mehr kann, würde man im Experiment nachweisen können. Ja, aber...
Hat denn das Ohrläppchen eigentlich auch irgendeine akustische Funktion?
Nö, ich weiß nicht. Das wirkt irgendwie so wie so ein Anhängsel.
So ein bisschen so der akustische Blinddarm.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wofür das gut ist. Also es ist ganz günstig,
dass es so labberig ist, weil wenn man da einen Ohrstecker durchschießt,
dann hört man das nicht so gut.
Aber sonst keine Ahnung. Da geht jedenfalls kein Knorpel runter.
Der Rest vom Außenohr, das ist ja alles Knorpelgespät.
Aber was man jetzt auf jeden Fall schon mal festhalten kann,
ist schon für das Ankommen des Schalls ist am Menschen und auch bei anderen
Tieren schon eine Menge an Vorrichtungen vorhanden,
um überhaupt erstmal die Zuführung der Frequenzen und Zuführung dieses Schalldrucks
zu leiten, zu lenken, zu optimieren und in gewisser Hinsicht halt auch ortbar zu machen.
Zu machen. Auf der einen Seite hat man halt dieses horizontale Hören durch Zeitverlauf.
Diese Zeitverläufe sind ja nicht nicht unerheblich. Also wenn man das mal so
ausrechnet, so wir sind jetzt irgendwie so zwei Meter entfernt,
das sind dann schon so ein paar Millisekunden, die da eine Rolle spielen.
Ja gut, das sind, das ist jetzt der Laufzeitabstand hier zwischen uns,
aber nicht der zwischen den beiden Ohren.
Ja, der ist geringer, aber der ist halt auch vorhanden.
Ja, aber der ist erstaunlich klein. Also wenn ich eine Schallquelle,
sagen wir mal, ich gehe genau nach rechts raus, vom Ohr weg und denke mir,
dass das Schallsignal als Ebenefront ankommt, dann erreicht das natürlich das
eine Ohr zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, läuft dann sozusagen bis zum halben
Kopf noch weiter und muss dann so einen Viertelkreis machen.
Und der Laufzeitunterschied, den man dadurch kriegt, das ist so in der Gegend von 500 Mikrosekunden.
Man kann es noch ein bisschen steigern
dadurch, dass man die Schallquelle unmittelbar vor das eine Ohr setzt.
Dann muss nämlich zum anderen Ohr wirklich ein Halbkreis gelaufen werden.
Also einmal rum um den Kopf, dann sind wir so ungefähr bei 680-700 Mikrosekunden.
Und das ist unheimlich kurz und das ist auch wirklich erstaunlich,
dass unser Nervensystem das transportieren kann.
Weil wenn man sich die Nervenfeuergeschwindigkeit eines einzelnen Nervs anguckt,
dann kann der normalerweise höchstens so ungefähr 300 mal in der Sekunde einen
Impuls abgeben und dann sind wir bei 3 Millisekunden Abstand zwischen einem
und dem frühestmöglichen nächsten Feuern eines Nerfs.
Und wie soll dann dieses Nervenskellett Zeitdifferenzen von 700 Mikrosekunden
überhaupt kodieren und auflösen? Und es geht ja noch weiter.
Das sind ja jetzt nur die extremsten Zeitunterschiede, die es gibt.
Wenn das Schallsignal kommt komplett aus einer Achse.
Aber wenn wir ein Experiment machen, was wirklich sauber konstruiert ist,
wo wir Leute in so ein Schallfeld setzen, dann haben wir in Blickrichtung genau
vor uns, haben wir eine Winkelauflösungsgenauigkeit von einem Grad, von einem Winkelgrad.
Das ist so der gerade ebenmärkliche Unterschied an Winkeleinfallsrichtung.
Und da geht es dann um Laufzeitdifferenzen, die ungefähr bei zehn Mikrosekunden liegen.
Das ist unglaublich schnell und auf eine wundersame Art und Weise ist unser
Gehörsystem in der Lage,
diese Zeitunterschiede zu messen und in unserem Bewusstsein oben dann als eine
Richtung, wo der Schall herkommt, sozusagen sich manifestieren zu lassen.
Aber das Nervenkostüm an den entsprechenden Schaltstellen kann diese Zeitunterschiede
auflösen. Das ist überhaupt so ein Merkmal von unserem Gehörsystem.
Unser Gehör ist eigentlich das, was unheimlich gut mit Zeit umgehen kann.
Unser Gehör ist eigentlich auch so eine Art Zeitwahrnehmungs- und Zeitmessorgan
könnte man vielleicht sagen. Diese Dinge kann unser,
akustisches Neurokostüm außerordentlich gut?
Offensichtlich. Man merkt das ja auch selber, wenn man mal so bewusst hört.
Ich fand auch schon mal diese Kunstkopfaufnahmen, wenn man sich so was mal anhört.
Allein diese Demonstration, dass sich diese Plastizität der Umgebung so gut,
perfekt will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber doch teilweise wirklich sehr beeindruckend,
bei manchen Aufnahmen, man hat wirklich das Gefühl, da ist jetzt was hinter mir und so.
Also auch so dieses dreidimensionale, also wie ist das eigentlich so mit vorne
hinten, das ergibt sich quasi auch aus der Ohrform. Das Ohr ist ja quasi auch
vorne hinten asymmetrisch, nicht nur oben unten.
Ja, das gibt sich ausschließlich auch aus der Ohrform und natürlich aus der,
sagen wir mal, spektralen Zusammensetzung des Signals.
Andere Möglichkeiten an diese vorne-hinten Informationen ranzukommen,
haben wir nicht. Aber da gibt es auch vergleichsweise viel Verwechslung.
Wenn man also jetzt ein naives Experiment in einem schalltoten Raum macht und
sich denkt, das muss doch ganz einfach sein vorne und hinten,
da kommt man manchmal drauf, dass es eben doch nicht so leicht ist.
Wir benutzen also, in dem wie wir im Alltag herumlaufen, benutzen wir natürlich
noch eine Menge andere Informationen, die zum Beispiel auf Reflektionen in Räumen beruhen.
Dass wir also jetzt solche Dinge auch noch können.
Das ist ja auch noch etwas, was wiederum eine ganz besondere Leistung unseres Gehörs ist,
dass wir Sprache verstehen können, obwohl jetzt die Schallquelle,
sprich der andere Sprecher, dem wir zuhören wollen, nicht nur auf direktem Schallwege zu hören ist.
Da kommt es zwar mit höchster Intensität und am schnellsten an.
Aber so eine Sprache wird ja auch noch zigmal überall wieder an den Wänden reflektiert
und das kann man auch sogar sehr schön grafisch darstellen,
wenn man sich das mal aufzeichnet oder anzeigen lässt in einem technischen System,
wie denn so ein schneller Klick in einem relativ halligen Raum dann ausschaut.
Da sieht man also also tausend nachklingende Nachklicks.
Und das überlagert sich natürlich dem ersten Signal. Und wenn es dann zum Beispiel
um Sprache geht und wir diese ganzen reflektierten Anteile,
etwas geschwächten Anteile, die alle noch zeitverzögert hinterherkommen,
auch noch mit drauf rechnet, muss man sich eigentlich wundern,
dass das überhaupt geht, dass wir das überhaupt können.
Ich meine, irgendwann ist dann auch Schluss. Also wenn man jetzt auch einen
Podcast aufnimmt und man sitzt in so einer nackten Küche,
Dann ist es natürlich auch irgendwann nicht mehr zu verstehen,
oder beziehungsweise wird es dann für Einzelne immer schwerer,
da noch die Sprecher auseinanderzuhalten oder gleichzeitig Gesprochenes noch
auseinandernehmen zu können.
Aber es geht halt relativ relativ weit.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es ja auch so, wenn die Informationen des Echoes nicht
vorhanden sind, kommt man ja auch nicht mehr klar. Zum Beispiel in so dedizierten Turnstudios.
Also wo so insbesondere Aufnahmen gemacht werden für so Special Effects,
also wo man so wirklich einfach so die nackte Soundinformation braucht,
weil gemixt und beechoet und beraumt wird es dann quasi danach in dem Bearbeitungsprozess.
Also muss man da alles möglichst trocken aufnehmen und dann ist das Ding einfach
voll mit schallschluckendem Material.
Und das ist dann so extrem, dass wenn man da reingeht, dass man sich sofort unwohl fühlt.
Was, was löst das denn, also wodurch wird das denn eigentlich ausgelöst?
Also es ist quasi dieses, das Echo, also so würde ich das jetzt mal interpretieren,
verdeutlicht einem, wo man ist und die Abwesenheit von Schall nimmt einem auch Orientierung.
Ja, also ich kann das, warum man da so ein Unwohlsein hat, kann ich nicht beantworten.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass es mir inzwischen nicht mehr so geht.
Also wir haben bei uns einen sehr guten schalltoten Raum unten im Keller,
den wir halt auch für so Lokalisationsexperimente zum Beispiel mit unseren Patienten,
um rauszufinden, ob die Schallrichtungen erhöhen können, benutzen.
Und der Raum ist für das, was man so im Durchschnitt an Kliniken zur Verfügung
hat, ist er außerordentlich gut.
Also ich bin sehr glücklich über diese Möglichkeit. Und in der Anfangszeit,
als ich da reinkomme, da hatte ich auch noch dieses seltsame bedrückende Gefühl.
Und ich beobachte das auch immer wieder bei jetzt insbesondere bei Normalhörern,
also Studenten oder irgendwie Leute, die man mal so reinführt.
Die haben auch dieses Unwohlsein. Bei mir ist das vollkommen weg.
Gewöhnungsfaktor.
Wahrscheinlich ein Gewöhnungsfaktor. Ich hab da auch nicht ansatzweise mehr
Probleme. Das hört sich halt einfach so ein bisschen anders an,
aber dieses Unwohlsein ist bei mir vollständig verschwunden.
Ich weiß nicht so richtig, woran das liegt. Also weder wo das Unwohlsein herkommt, noch...
Ich meine, man berührt sich jetzt an alles. Ich meine, auch so die natürlichen
Lebensumgebungen sind da ja auch sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich meine, wenn man jetzt so im Amazonus lebt, wo die ganze Zeit ein höllen,
ein akustisches Höllengewitter über einen einbricht von tausend Tieren und haste
nicht gesehen und Bäumen und Büschen versus Leben in der Wüste,
Ja, wo, weiß nicht, wie gut der Sand mag noch ganz gute Reflektionsfläche darstellen,
aber das ist jetzt in der Regel ja nicht so viel da, was jetzt groß wiederheilen könnte.
Wahrscheinlich alles nur eine Frage der Gewöhnung. Trotz alledem,
also das, was ich damit nur sagen wollte, ist ganz offensichtlich ist diese
permanente Wahrnehmung von Echo auch Teil unserer Selbstwahrnehmung und wird
auch die ganze Zeit dekodiert.
Ja, das ist so. Was man natürlich jetzt auch nochmal auf diesen schalltoten Raum zurückzukommen.
Im Idealfall ist ein schalltoter Raum natürlich identisch mit völligen akustischen Vakuumen.
Natürlich befinden wir uns in Luft, aber das Beispiel, was du gerade gesagt
hast mit der Wüste ist ja eigentlich schon, wenn wir jetzt keine Windgeräusche
oder solche Dinge haben, dann ist das ja, akustisch gesehen,
fast identisch mit einem schalltoten Raum.
Alles, was wir an Geräuschen selber abgeben, das läuft einfach weg,
kommt nie wieder zurück.
Und das ist ja eigentlich das, was ein schalltoter Raum machen soll.
Es gibt auch aus den Frühzeiten noch so alte Bilder von Experimenten,
ich glaube, das war so in 20er, vielleicht 30er Jahren, wo man noch nicht einen
schalltoten Raum gebaut hat, sondern für Hörexperimente haben sich die Leute
irgendwie so auf so eine Dachspitze gesetzt.
Die haben dann so einen ganz wackeligen
Stuhl irgendwie auf so einer Drahtkonstruktion auf dem Dach gehabt.
Und dann saß da oben der Proband wirklich frei in der Luft und wurde irgendwo
von einem einzelnen Lautsprecher, den man da so mit so einem Arm rumbewegen konnte, beschallt.
Ja, das war also damals der schalltote Raum.
In der Mangelung der entsprechenden Materialien. Ist ja auch der totale Hightech.
Also hier auch so im Studio, so dieses Basotec da, ist ja eine totale Revolution, was das schluckt.
So, jetzt sind wir viel um den Kopf herumgekrochen und haben zur Kenntnis genommen,
wie der Schall jetzt ankommt. Jetzt muss er aber doch irgendwie rein in den Kopf.
Also er findet halt irgendwie seinen Weg in das Loch. Das Loch heißt wie? Das ist der...
Das ist erstmal der Gehörgang.
Das ist der Gehörgang. Da geht es ja auch tief rein. 2 cm, 2,5 cm.
Man schickt ab und zu mal so einen kleinen Wattestab hinterher,
merkt aber auch schon, dass ist da alles sehr fragil und mehr zustechen sollte man jetzt nicht.
Ja, das mit dem Wattestab ist sowieso keine so gute Idee,
weil das Ohrenschmalz, was man da üblicherweise entfernen will,
das bringt man manchmal gerade dadurch noch tiefer rein und stampft das sozusagen
fest. Also das ist nicht unbedingt das Beste.
Eigentlich hat das Ohr ganz ganz gute Selbstreinigungseigenschaften.
Das hat also in der in der Hautauskleidung des Gehörgangs ist das so,
dass zumindest über langfristige Zeiträume hinaus die obersten Hotsche Schichten
sich so raus bewegen und alles raustransportieren unter anderem auch wenn man
da eine Narbe hat die wächst sozusagen nach außen raus und Und...
Mit welcher Geschwindigkeit?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht. Langsam. Naja, klar, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich kann das nicht sagen.
Keine Ahnung. Pi mal Daumen, also... In einem Jahr ist alles so rausgewachsen,
was drin war? Oder schneller?
Ich will mich nicht so richtig aus dem Fenster legen. Also wenn ich schätzen
dürfte, dann würde ich sagen, das ist höchstens so Nagelwachstumsgeschwindigkeit.
Ja, das ist ja schon recht schnell eigentlich. Aber da will ich nicht sagen,
was mir man nennt. sagen was mir meine Ärztekollege dann später immer vorhalten.
Aber trotzdem interessant, also es gibt also quasi so auch so einen automatischen Reinigungsprozess.
Ja und eigentlich ist das auch so gedacht, dass das Ohrenschmalz so trocknen
soll und dann rauskrümelt.
Warum ist denn das da überhaupt drin?
Ja also das hat...
Bitterstoffe die drin sind die sind für
Insekten nicht so schön deswegen finden
sich da relativ selten mal Viecher drin
wäre ja sonst eigentlich schön schön warm 37 grad und
reinkriechen und so und unter anderem sind in diesem oren schmalz dinge drin
die nicht so Angenehm sind für Insekten vier heißt nicht dass das nicht doch
hin und wieder mal passiert Das ist aber eine von vermutlich unendlich vielen
Funktionen, die das hat.
Es gibt auch noch die Theorie, dass das sogar Bakterizid sei,
aber auch da, das ist vielleicht doch ein bisschen zu nah an der Medizin wieder
dran. Da möchte ich mich auch nicht allzu sehr aus dem Fenster legen.
Okay, aber es hat sozusagen seinen Sinn und es geht schon im Wesentlichen darum,
diesen Gehörgang als solchen zu schützen, dass er nicht von irgendetwas anderem
als Behausung genutzt wird oder als Einfallstor für andere Gefahren.
Infektionen. Und das funktioniert ja an sich auch ganz gut. Wobei es gibt ja
auch schon so Entzündungssachen, was nicht so Mitteleuroentzündung,
ich will es hier auch nicht so sehr medizinisch abgleiten.
Ja, Mitteleuroentzündung, das ist nochmal was anderes. Aber das findet woanders
statt. Das findet woanders statt und zwar hinter dem Trommelfell.
Und das Trommelfell wäre dann eigentlich das nächste, was auf Okay,
also dieser Gehörgang, da der schmalz ausgekleidete Anti-Ameisentunnel sozusagen,
der endet am Trommelfell. Was wahrscheinlich...
Ganz praktisch so benannt ist, weil es eben genau an ein solches auch erinnert.
Ja, es ist nicht ganz so. Man findet das in Darstellungen öfter mal so,
als wäre das so eine gespannte, glatte Membran, wie wirklich das von einer Trommel.
Das stimmt aber nicht. In Wirklichkeit ist das trichterförmig.
Nach innen geht es also rein. Also man muss sich das eher so vorstellen,
wie vielleicht eine Lautsprechermembran, die so nach innen gewölbt ist.
Und das hat einerseits eine mechanische Eigenschaft, das ist in sich etwas stabiler.
Und es ist so, dass das Trommelfell so ein bisschen durchsichtig ist,
wenn man von außen rein guckt, als Mediziner mit einem entsprechenden Instrument.
Dann kann man auch so ein bisschen da durchgucken und sieht so ein bisschen
so durchscheinend, sieht man die Strukturen, die hinter dem Trommelfell liegen.
Hinter dem Trommelfeld haben wir dann das Mittelohr.
Und das auffälligste, was man jetzt von außen auf dem Trommelfeld sieht,
ist der Griff des Hammers. Der Hammer ist das erste von den drei Gehörknöcheln,
die dann dahinter kommen.
Und der Hammergriff, der klebt sozusagen etwas mehr als über den Radius des
Trommelfelds klebt der innen dran.
Wenn man das von außen sieht, wenn man auf ein rechtes Ohr,
ein rechtes Trommelfell von außen drauf guckt, dann sieht man innen drin den Hammergriff,
dran kleben und der steht so etwa auf einem 11-Uhr-Winkel, ist also sozusagen
nach vorne geneigt bei einem rechten Ohr. Beim linken Ohr ist es natürlich symmetrisch anders.
Und das schwingende Trommelfell, was jetzt ja mit den Schallwellen,
die von außen einfangen, mit schwingt,
das setzt dann auch den Hammer in Bewegung, der wiederum mit einem Gelenk verbunden
ist mit dem Amboss und der wiederum mit einem kleinen Gelenk verbunden ist mit dem Steigbügel.
Und hinter dem Steigbügel geht es dann ins Innenohr rein.
Das heißt, das Prinzip der Schallwandlung wird im Prinzip genau durch diese
Knöchelchen umgesetzt.
Also das Trommelfell nimmt den Schall auf,
schwingt also mit der Luft, wird durch die Luft angeregt und bewegt dadurch
den Hammer, der dann wiederum den Ambus bewegt und den Stapel oder den Steigbügel bewegt.
Also das Mittelohr, vielleicht sollten wir erstmal kurz plausibel machen,
wie das ungefähr aussieht, das Mittelohr.
Also das Mittelohr ist eine Höhlung im Knochen, die hinter dem Trommelfell sitzt.
Und die nicht allzu sehr in die Tiefe geht.
Wenn man also auf die gegenüberliegende Seite hinter dem Trommelfell drauf schaut,
die ist ziemlich nah. Das ist gerade mal so zweieinhalb Millimeter ungefähr weg.
Da kommt so eine Knochenwölbung hervor. Dahinter sitzt nämlich schon das Innenohr.
Diese Knochenwölbung sitzt also relativ nah am Trommelfell dran und es geht
dann aber Aber nach hinten oben wird es größer und weiter und nach vorne unten
geht es in die eustachische Röhre, in die Ohrtrompete.
Diese Ohrtrompete steht in Verbindung mit unserem Nasen-Rachen-Raum,
da ist also eine Öffnung dahin. Die ist aber normalerweise geschlossen.
Das dient zum Druckausgleich.
Und wir können uns ja jetzt vorstellen, dass so ein Trommelfell nicht nur Schallwellen
aufnimmt und schwingt, sondern es gibt ja auch einen statischen Druck.
Wenn das Trommelfell sozusagen in seiner Ruheposition sein soll,
dann muss der statische Druck zwischen Außenwelt und Innenwelt gleich sein,
sonst ist es erstmal grundsätzlich vorgewölbt, ein oder auswärtsgewölbt.
Das heißt also, das System muss in der Lage sein, zwischen dem Außen- und dem
Innendruck einen Ausgleich herzustellen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich auch wieder Quatsch, einfach eine permanente
Dauerverbindung dort zu machen, weil dann hätte der Schall ja sozusagen,
jetzt mal ganz salopp gesprochen, einen einfacheren Weg, als das Trommelfell
in Schwingung zu setzen, dann würde es einfach den Umweg nehmen und einfach da durchlaufen.
Das heißt, deswegen gibt es diese Ohrtrumpete, die aber zu ist,
aber bei Bedarf sich öffnen kann.
Und das ist so dieser Flugzeugtrick, wenn man im Flugzeug sitzt und man startet
und der Luftdruck ändert sich.
Gut, es gibt halt so diesen scheinbaren Luftdruck innerhalb des Flugzeugs,
also auch ein Flugzeug steht ja unter Überdruck, sonst hätte man dann noch ganz
andere Probleme, trotz alledem nimmt der gesamte Luftdruck ab und dadurch entsteht
dieser Druck auf dem Ohr, den man dann wiederum korrigieren kann mit Nasensohr.
Genau.
Das heißt, wenn ich so diese Luft in mich selber reindrücke,
dann drücke ich quasi die Ohrtrompete auf?
Ja, eigentlich ist es so, die Ohrtrompete geht noch ein Stückchen durch den
Knochen durch und wird dann Richtung Nasenrachenraum.
Wird sie knorpelig und wir haben da so einen gefalteten Knorpel,
der so ein kleines Kanälechen enthält und da sind so mehrere Muskeln dran und
beim Schlucken oder beim Gehen werden die aufgezogen.
Dann entfaltet sich das so ein bisschen, dann geht so ein kurzer kleiner Kanal
auf und dann kann es dort zum Luftausgleich kommen.
Also wenn man nicht diesen Luft-Reinblasentrick nimmt, hilft auch einfach mal Gehen, Schlucken.
Gähnen oder schlucken. Also wenn man so schreiende Babys im Flugzeug hat,
die müssten wir eigentlich dazu bringen, dass sie ständig schlucken.
Also denen irgendwie Bonbons zum Lutschen geben, dass sie ständig ordentlich weich sind.
Also bei mir ist Gähnen das Mittel der Wahl.
Aber ist jetzt auch nicht Schlimmes dran, wenn man jetzt diesen Luftreindrück-Trick macht?
Nein, ist nicht Schlimmes dran. Das geht auch mal.
Man sollte das nur nicht mit so viel Druck machen, dass man jetzt einen Überdruck
gegenüber der Außenwelt erzeugt. Dann holt man das Trommelfell gleich mit draußen.
Ja und wenn man so richtig ordentlich Druck aufbaut, kann man auch schon mal
das Trommelfell zum Reißen bringen. Das ist dann gar nicht so schön.
Ja das geplatzte Trommelfell, das ist ja schon so ein bisschen,
benutzt man immer gerne diesen Ausdruck, wie viel hält das aus?
Also wie sehr in Gefahr ist so? Also ich meine, sind so geplatzte Trommelfälle,
ist das sowieso ein gängiges Ding?
Ja, das ist schon ein gängiges Ding. Also ein typischer Fall für ein geplatztes
Trommelfell ist zum Beispiel eine Ohrfeige.
Also wenn Eltern mal ordentlich ausholen und ihren Kindern eine Ohrfeige geben,
dann kann es sein, dass die im Gehörgang kurzfristig so viel Luftdruck aufbauen
durch die auftreffende Hand, dass das Trommelfell nach innen einreißt.
Oder natürlich auch ein harter mechanischer Ruck sozusagen.
Wenn ich also sehr stark ziehe, dann ziehe ich sozusagen auch die ganze Wand so ein bisschen mit.
Aber soweit ich das weiß,
ist es im Wesentlichen ein schlagartig-plötzlicher Schalldruck,
den man von außen auf das Trommelfeld draufbringt.
Und das kann dann sein, dass man das zu einer Rupatur bringt.
Repariert sich das?
Ja, je nachdem, ja das repariert sich. Je nachdem wie groß das ist,
muss man unter Umständen mal ein bisschen nachhelfen.
Das kann, kann man zum Beispiel dadurch, also das ist so richtig der,
der Alltagsbetrieb an den HNO-Kliniken.
Also da kommen täglich mehr, möchte ich mal fast sagen, Patienten rein,
denen aus irgendwelchen Gründen sowas passiert ist.
Und was die Ärzte dann machen, die schienen das und nennen die das, so wie ein Knochen.
In Wirklichkeit ist das so, dass man ein dünnes Plättchen aus zum Beispiel ganz
feinem dünnen Folienmaterial auf das Trommelfell auflegt, das Trommelfell soweit
es noch besteht sozusagen daran anlegt und dann wächst das schon wieder zusammen.
Das ist also ganz normal, dass das Trommelfell wieder zusammenwächst,
wenn die Verletzung nicht zu groß ist. Man muss ja auch manchmal,
Gerade bei Kindern ist das relativ häufig, dass die sich so eine Mittelohrentzündung zuziehen.
Das ist so in Fällen, wenn das Wachstum mal so Phasen hat, wo die eine Sache
schon ein bisschen größer als die andere.
Ja, Schmerzen und so. Da kann das also mal sein, dass die Ohrtrompete,
dass die österreichische Röhre nicht so ohne Weiteres aufgeht oder auch zum
Beispiel permanent aufbleibt.
Und dann ist es so, dass wenn man jetzt eine Infektion hat, die sich da ins
Trommelfell hoch bewegt, dass dann das nicht mehr sauber rausgeräumt wird durch
den Ausgang in die Ohrtrompete.
Und wenn man da eine Entzündung drin sitzen hat, dann muss man manchmal so einen
kleinen Schnitt ins Trommelfell machen, damit der ganze Eiter und Entzündung rausläuft.
Und manchmal setze mal so einen kleinen Stöpsel ein,
der das sogar noch aufhält, so ein Röhrchen, damit da
also Belüftung da ist und irgendwann halt
das Trommelfell wieder zu und das Röhrchen dieses mini Also
jetzt so ein Millimeter großes Ding das fällt dann raus und
dann ist das Trommelfell wieder in Ordnung was wirklich ernst ist ist sozusagen
nach hinten oben im Mittelohr dieses diese Dachwölbung könnte man das sagen
da wo das Gelenk zwischen Hammer und Amboss drin sitzen da ist nicht Schluss
Also es wird immer so dargestellt, als wäre da jetzt Ende.
In Wirklichkeit kommen da aber noch eine ganze Reihe von Schleimhaut ausgekleideten
Zellen in dem Knochen dahinter,
kommen da noch und wenn da mal eine Entzündung da drauf überspringt und sich
da in diese Höhlungen pneumatisiert,
es sind pneumatisierte Knochen, so nennt man das, hat also so Lufthöhlungen drin.
Wenn da mal eine Entzündung reinkommt, dann kann es wirklich ernst werden,
dann kann es lebensbedrohlich werden und dann muss man da auch operativ ran
und muss das aufmachen und da diese ganze Entzündung ausräumen.
Das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig häufig, aber das kann schon auch mal ernst sein.
Also auf jeden Fall ein kritischer Bereich, der sich gut schützen muss,
aber das eben so bei Design auch schon ganz gut macht.
Also mit dieser Trommelfel ist ja an sich schon mal ein Abschluss und dann diese
Ohrtrompete, die eben ja mit diesen sich normalerweise gut zusammendrückenden
Knorpeln da eigentlich dicht macht, aber eben bei Bedarf auch mal aufmachen
kann, um eben diesen Überdruck abzuleiten.
Oder Unterdruck.
Kompliziert, kompliziert. Aber schon interessant, dass das letztlich aber auch
nur so ein mechanischer Vorgang ist.
Also das da Luft kommt an, drückt Knöchelchen gegen Knöchelchen,
das gegen Knüchelchen druckt und das ist ja dann also Hammer,
Ambus, Steig, Bügel, was...
Dann? Ja, wir sollten vielleicht die Aufgabe, die das hat, mal kurz anreißen.
Das Trommelfell wird ja durch Luft bewegt.
Und der Schall muss in Flüssigkeit rein, ins Innenohr. Das Innenohr ist flüssigkeitsgefüllt.
Wir müssen jetzt also aus einem akustisch weichen Medium, Luft,
in ein akustisch viel härteres Medium, Wasser, müssen wir die Schallwelle reinbringen.
Normalerweise bei solchen Grenzübergängen wird es reflektiert.
Diese Reflektion hat man ja an all möglichen Übergängen.
Also wenn ich an einem See stehe und ich spreche auf die Wasseroberfläche drauf,
der Taucher da drin hört das nicht. Und zwar weil einfach die Schallenergie
an dieser harten Grenzfläche reflektiert wird.
Diese Art von Reflektion gibt es ja auch bei optischen Grenzübergängen.
Unterschiedlich dichte optische Medien, auch wieder Luft, Glas, Luft, Wasser.
Da gibt es also diese Reflexionseffekte. Gibt es natürlich elektrisch auch,
wenn man also eine elektrische Leitung hat, sagen wir mal, ein Koaxialkabel
oder so und man schickt da ein Hochfrequenzsignal drüber und man hat an einer
Stelle, weckelt man auf einmal auf ein anderes Kabel mit anderen Eigenschaften.
Da wird ein Teil der da rein laufenden elektrischen Energie wird reflektiert,
geht gar nicht in das andere rein.
Technisch gesehen ist das ein Unterschied in der Impedanz, also sozusagen ein Unterschied im,
ganz elektrotechnisch komplexen Widerstand, komplex im Sinne von mathematisch komplexer Zahl.
Aber das wird ja jetzt als komplexe Widerstände mathematisch beschrieben.
Und das Problem haben wir hier auch. Wir haben also das Problem,
dass wir aus Luftschall, Flüssigkeitsschall machen müssen und dass eigentlich
das alles ganz gerne reflektiert würde.
Wie kriegen wir aber jetzt, wir wollen ja möglichst viel höher an,
es ist ja evolutionär notwendig gewesen, möglichst schallempfindlich zu sein.
Alle die, die was gehört haben, haben überlebt. Alle die nichts gehört haben,
wurden gefressen oder haben die Warnrufe nicht gehört oder so was.
Und jetzt muss man also dafür sorgen, dass dieser akustisch weiche Schall,
das ist jetzt sehr naiv beschrieben, in ein hartes Medium übertragen wird.
Und das ist die Aufgabe vom Mittelohr.
Wir haben jetzt eine große Empfangsfläche, das Trommelfell, im Vergleich zu
einer kleinen Fläche, die in die Flüssigkeit reingeht.
Wir haben also die Gehörknöchelchen, die die Schallschwingungen des Trommelfells
aufnehmen und weiterleiten.
Und das letzte Gehörknöchelchen, der Steigbügel, der hat so eine ovale Platte,
mit der er sozusagen in die Flüssigkeit hineinpumpt.
Aber die Fläche dieser ovalen Platte ist viel, viel kleiner,
als die Fläche des Trommelfels. Das ist im Prinzip sowas wie Hydraulik.
Ich will mit wenig Kraft,
aber großer Fläche und großer Auslenkung, kann ich viel Kraft,
aber kleine Auslenkung auf eine kleine Fläche bringen.
Also das Getriebe-Prinzip oder das Transformator-Prinzip ist das immer.
Ich habe hohe Spannung, wenig Strom, übersetze ich in viel Strom,
aber wenig Spannung der Transformator.
Oder ich habe eine hohe Rotationsgeschwindigkeit mit wenig Kraft,
schnell laufender Motor, wird durch
ein Getriebe transformiert auf langsam drehend aber viel Kraft das Rad.
Das Getriebe im Auto beispielsweise. Oder ein klassisches Beispiel auch Hydraulik.
Ich habe irgendwie so ein geschlossenes Ölvolumen und ich pumpe an einer Stelle
rein mit einem kleinen Durchmesser mit einem Kolben, den ich aber dann viel bewegen muss.
Ich schiebe also ein bestimmtes Volumen rein und an der anderen Stelle habe
ich einen großen Kolben, der wird durch dasselbe Volumen rausgedrückt.
Aber weil er groß ist, kriege ich mit dem selben Druck viel mehr Kraft drauf.
Das ist das selbe Prinzip hier. Ich habe also hier eine große Fläche,
die relativ groß schwingt, übersetzt durch das Mittelohr auf eine kleine Fläche,
die wenig schwingt und das ist die Impedanzwandlung.
Ich kriege also aus einem akustisch weichen Medium viel Energie in das akustisch
harte Medium Flüssigkeit.
Also kurz gesagt durch eine verhältnismäßig große Auftreffläche der Luft wird
das Ganze mechanisch so umgesetzt,
dass man mit einem relativ kleinen
Stoß in die Flüssigkeit diese Frequenz übersetzt bekommt und dadurch,
dass man diese Aufschlagsfläche am Steigbügel so klein vorfindet,
bleibt die Gesamtenergie erhalten?
Gehen sehr große Teile, das meiste der akustischen Energie wird eben nicht wieder
rausreflektiert, sondern geht dann tatsächlich ins Innenohr rein,
so wie wir das haben wollen, wenn wir möglichst gut hören wollen.
Wer hat das jetzt ausgedacht?
Ja, da gibt es zwei Stufen. Die erste Stufe, das haben sich schon die Reptilien
ausgedacht. Die haben nur den Steigbügel.
Das habe ich mal in Chicago gesehen. In Chicago gibt es ein großes naturwissenschaftliches
Museum, Fields Museum und die haben da ein Tyrannosaurus Rex.
Ein komplettes, vollständiges Skelett von einem Tyrannosaurus Rex rumstehen.
Das ist also wirklich toll. Sollte man sich wirklich mal angucken,
ist auf so Stahlträgern so aufgebaut. Man sieht eigentlich gar nicht, dass das getragen wird.
Wirklich, ich meine, es ist ein versteinertes Skelett, also wirklich Stein,
was die da aufgestellt haben. Und der Kopf war aber so schwer,
dass das nicht geklappt hat. Den haben sie separat rausgelagert und haben den
Kopf aber nachgegossen in, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie Kunststoff oder so.
Und dann haben die beim Präparieren, ist wohl irgendjemand dabei gewesen,
als der rauspräpariert wurde aus dem Stein und hat so eine kleine Struktur gefunden.
Und das ist die Kolumella.
Das ist das, was bei den Reptilien, also sprich Dinosauriern und Vögeln, der Steigbügel war.
Das ist nur ein einziger Knochen. Bei denen, also bei unseren großen Vettern,
der andere große Zweig der Landseu der Nabeltiere sozusagen.
Die haben wir eine gemeinsame Erfindung mit denen und zwar die,
dass wir nicht mehr im Wasser leichen müssen.
Also die Amphibien, die haben ja ihre, die Bravani immer noch auf Wasser angewiesen,
wenn sie sich fortpflanzen wollten.
Und unsere gemeinsamen Vorfahren haben die grandiose Erfindung gemacht,
dass wir unser Fruchtwasser mitnehmen können.
Und dass wir deswegen auch wirklich aufs trockene konnten.
Also wirklich weit weg.
Und die einen haben das gemacht, indem sie das Fruchtwasser in ein Ei gepackt haben.
Und da drin fand die Geburt statt. Und wir haben das gemacht,
indem wir es einfach in unseren Körper reingemacht haben.
Und das war aber eine sehr, sehr wesentliche Erfindung im Werdegang der Landtiere gewesen,
dass wir so ein Stückchen Wasser mitgenommen haben, beide auf eine unterschiedliche Art und Weise.
Und die ganze Zweig Reptilien, die haben eben nur den Steigbügel.
Und da ist eine direkte Stegverbindung zwischen dem Trommelfell und der Fußplatte
von dem Steigbügel. Aber da ist dieses große Fläche auf kleine Fläche Prinzip
schon drin verwirklicht.
Und erst der andere Zweig, die Säugetiere, die haben diese beiden zusätzlichen
Knöchelchen noch. Und da kommt jetzt noch ein zusätzlicher Effekt, nämlich ein Hebel dazu.
Der Hebel vom Hammer, das hatte ich ja vorher gesagt, der Hammer hat ja seinen
Hammergriff, der klebt sozusagen innen am Trommelfeld dran.
Der Hebel ist länger als der Hebel vom Steigbügel, äh, Entschuldigung,
vom Amboss, der auf den Steigbügel drückt.
Das kommt also auch noch mal noch ein zusätzlicher Effekt hinzu,
dass wir auch noch so eine Hebelübersetzungsgeschichte haben.
Also quasi so ein Verstärker.
Könnte man sagen, aber das ist im Prinzip auch noch mal dieses Getriebe-Prinzip.
Kleines Zahnrad, großes Zahnrad. Genau, langer Hebel, viel Auslenkung,
geht auf kurzen Hebel, wenig Auslenkung, aber dann mehr Kraft.
Und was entwicklungsgeschichtlich wirklich eine faszinierende Sache ist,
dass dieses Gelenk zwischen Hammer und Ambos, das war bei unseren gemeinsamen Vorfahren,
also unseren Säugetier- und Dinosauriervögel-Reptilien-Vorfahren,
die gemeinsame Vorfahren, bei denen war das, und bei denen davor natürlich erst
recht, also bis zu den Fischen zurück, war das eigentlich das Kiefergelenk.
Und das Kiefergelenk ist sozusagen nach und nach nach hinten gewandert.
Ursprünglich bestand der Kiefer aus zwei Knochen vorne und der vorderen Zahnteil und dem Os.
Quadratum oben und Os, ich glaube Articulum unten. Und die beiden waren sozusagen
verwachsen mit dem Oberkiefer und dem Unterkiefer und hatten dieses Gelenk.
Und die haben sich nach und nach nach hinten verlagert, sind kleiner und kleiner
geworden, haben sich dann sozusagen, den Stapes hat es gewissermaßen schon immer
gegeben, ist jetzt sehr salopp, aber.
Und die haben sich sozusagen nach hinten verlagert und sind in der ganzen Säugetierwelt,
sind die zu Hammer und Ambos geworden.
Ambos ist früher der obere Teil, Hammer ist der untere Teil gewesen.
Und der vordere Teil der beiden Knochen oben und unten, was ursprünglich nur
der Zahnteil ist, der ist nach hinten immer größer und größer geworden und hat
dann irgendwann die Gelenkfunktion mit übernommen.
Also wenn man diese ganzen Änderungen, also wir reden jetzt noch von der Zeit,
wo das auseinandergelaufen ist, Vor Dinozaue, also Erzeitalter Perm, vor Mesozoicum.
Da ist das sozusagen auseinandergelaufen und wir haben...
Konnten denn die Fische damit auch schon... Also war da auch schon eine Hörfähigkeit mit verbunden?
Ich kann nicht beantworten, ob die Fische eine Kolumela hatten.
Nee, hatten die nicht. Hatten sie nicht.
Das heißt, sie konnten gar nicht hören?
Doch, die konnten schon. Also die hatten Vibrations... Die haben vor allen Dingen
ein Gleichgewichtssystem gehabt. Die haben vor allen Dingen ein Gleichgewichtssystem,
aber die haben auch schon Vibrationswahrnehmungsfähigkeit.
Gehabt.
Hören im strengen Sinn würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen, weil ein Teil des Gleichgewichtsorgans
der Fische ist dann erst zum Hörteil geworden.
Also das Gleichgewichtsorgan war eigentlich früher da, nämlich bei den Fischen schon.
Da kommen wir gleich drauf.
Eigentlich sind wir schon mitten drin. Also wenn ich mal so ein dreidimensional
lebendes Tier habe, wie so ein Fisch. Also der kann vor, zurück, weg, hin.
Okay. Also...
Der Tyrannosaurus hatte im Prinzip schon so eine ähnliche Hörgeschichte,
war bloß nicht so fein ausgeformt wie bei den Säugetieren, bei denen immer jetzt
dieser Hammerambus zu finden ist.
Also das ist quasi, was alle Säugetiere vereint, so hören, funktioniert so.
Dann aber in unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen.
Was sind denn so die besten Hörer in der Tierwelt, in der Säugetierwelt?
Wer hört denn am besten? kann man das sagen?
Im Prinzip muss man das frequenzspezifisch angehen.
Ja gut, aber ich weiß nicht, da fällt dir jetzt gerade mal ein Beispiel ein
für irgendwas. Meine Hunde hören ja zum Beispiel deutlich besser als wir.
Ja, die hören vor allen Dingen zu höheren Frequenzen hin. Die haben also einen
Frequenzbereich, den wir nicht hören können.
Aber bei denen ist jetzt konzeptionell nichts grundsätzlich anders.
Ist da irgendwie jetzt in diesem mechanischen Bereich irgendwas besser ausgeprägt,
wird da, noch mehr Hebel erzeugt, dass das quasi,
also dass dieses feinere Hören durch das noch effizientere Transformieren von
Luftschall zu Wasserschall schonmal eingeleitet wird oder ist das eher eine
Frage der späteren Verarbeitung?
Das ist eigentlich eher eine Frage der Konstruktion der Hörschnecke.
Wie groß und mit wie viel Nervenzellen die angelegt ist und wie die mechanisch ausgeprägt ist.
Also es gibt bei uns, da sind wir jetzt noch nicht, was die Hörschnecke angeht.
Vielleicht sollten wir die anderen Sachen erst mal abhaken.
Aber zum Beispiel die Anzahl der Windungen der Schnecke, die ist unterschiedlich je nach Säugetierart.
Ich wollte jetzt nur mal festhalten, ob es sozusagen dann noch mal grundsätzliche
mechanische Unterschiede gibt, aber das ist dem scheint nicht so zu sein.
Nein, das ist prinzipiell nicht so.
Wo kommt denn jetzt dieses Gleichgewicht ins Spiel? Also dass unser Gleichgewichtsinn
dort angesiedelt ist, das ist mir wohl auch bewusst, aber ich wüsste jetzt ehrlich
gesagt noch nicht so genau wo eigentlich.
Ja, also gehen wir erstmal von der Notwendigkeit aus, was man braucht.
Gehen wir mal vom Fisch aus. Fisch kann sich dreidimensional bewegen oder befindet
sich in einem dreidimensionalen Raum, in dem er sich prinzipiell bewegen kann.
Der kann vor zurück, seitwärts und hoch und runter.
Viele Säugetiere sind im Wesentlichen zweidimensional
hoch und runter gibt es nicht für eine antilope die bewegt sie eigentlich in
der Ebene Wir sind sozusagen zweieinhalb dimensional könnte man vielleicht mal
sagen wir können bäume rauf und runter klettern wir haben einen sinn für hoch
hoch und runter Aber so richtig frei in der dritten dimension sind wir eigentlich
nicht das sind die vögel wieder die können rauf und runter fliegen die haben Okay,
wenn man also jetzt mal von der dreidimensionalen Welt ausgeht,
in der man sich orientieren und bewegen will, dann ist es sinnvoll,
ein sensorisches System zu haben, was
die 6 Freiheitsgrade der Bewegung im dreidimensionalen Raum messen kann.
Und zwar gibt es 3 translatorische Vor-Zurück, Rechts-Links, Rauf-Runter.
Das sind aber reine Verschiebebewegungen.
Dann gibt es drei rotatorische Bewegungen.
So um die Achse, um die Vorwärtsachse drehen, dann vorwärts kippen oder zurück,
also Schaukelstuhl und rechts-links drehen.
Und die Fische, die haben für diese sechs Bewegungsmodi,
Mechaniker reden eben von sechs Freiheitsgraden der Bewegung,
also ich habe irgendeinen Körper hier, ich bewege den irgendwie woanders hin
und dann kann ich jede Positionsänderung eines Körpers im dreidimensionalen
Raum kann ich aus diesen sechs Komponenten zusammensetzen.
Ein bisschen vorwärts, ein bisschen seitwärts, ein bisschen rauf,
aber dann um so viel Winkel darüber, darüber, darüber gedreht.
Dafür ein Sinnesorgan zu haben, wäre eine schlaue Sache und die Fische haben
das entwickelt. Die Fische haben deswegen diese drei Bogengänge.
Das sind drei Höhlungen mit flüssigkeitsgefüllte Windungen drin.
Die stehen genau senkrecht zueinander.
Und wenn ich jetzt einen solchen Bogengang so orientiert habe und ich drehe
genau um die Mittelachse dieses Bogengangs, dann kann dieser Bogengang diese
Rotationsbewegung messen, während die anderen beiden nichts messen.
Ach so, verstehe. Das heißt, man dreht sich um die eine Achse und man hat so
ein kreisförmiges, mit Flüssigkeit gefüllten Bogengang.
Gang in dem Moment, wo dann diese der der Richtung dieses Kreises entsprechende
Bewegung tatsächlich stattfindet bleibt ja quasi die Flüssigkeit stehen und
bewegt sich quasi nicht relativ so ein natürliches Gyroskop wo man Ja,
okay das basiert natürlich auf dem Fundamentale anderen Prinzip aber also wenn
ich so eine Kaffeetasse gefüllt mit Kaffee auf dem Tisch stehen habe und ich
drehe die dann bleibt der Kaffee erstmal stehen Und dann gibt es eine Sensorik,
die quasi merkt, dass die Flüssigkeit sich auf einmal relativ zu dem festen Teil bewegt.
So, und jetzt habe ich in der Kaffeetassenwand, habe ich irgendwie einen Sensor,
der diese vorbeiströmende Flüssigkeit bemerkt.
Und wenn ich die Kaffeetasse drehe, dann merkt der Sensor hier,
die Flüssigkeit hier bewegt sich relativ zu mir.
Was sind das dann so Härchen, die dann so hin und her gedrückt werden?
Ganz genau. Also es gibt dann in den Borgengängen, da wo die zusammen laufen,
die sind also an einer Stelle gemeinsam miteinander flüssigkeitsverbunden.
Da gibt es in der Nähe davon, gibt es so Verdickungen.
Also wie gesagt, das muss man sich jetzt vorstellen als Hohlräume,
also ringförmige Hohlräume in einem sehr festen Knochen eingebettet.
Diese Hohlräume sind flüssigkeitsgefüllt und ich habe an bestimmten Stellen Verdickungen,
das sind die Ampullee und da drin sitzt ein Sensorium, was diese Flüssigkeitsbewegung
aufzunehmen in der Lage ist.
Und wenn ich jetzt eine entsprechende rotatorische Bewegung des Kopfes ausführe,
dann kommen halt partiell einige von diesen Bogengängen, kommen dann halt in
Bewegung und je nachdem genau wie die Drehbewegung stattfindet,
halt auch mal einer, wenn es genau um dessen Achse geht, in voller Ausprägung
und anderer vielleicht gar nicht.
Und natürlich ist es auch so, so ähnlich wie bei der Kaffeetasse,
wenn ich die drehe und drehe und drehe und einfach gleichmäßig weiter.
Irgendwann geht der Kaffee schon mit, weil da ist ja Reibung zur Wand.
Irgendwann ist die Flüssigkeit in Synchronisation, also dreht sich mit dem ganzen
System durch. Wenn ich dann auf einmal die Kaffeetasse wieder festhalte,
dann dreht sich die Flüssigkeit weiter. Das ist dieser Drehwurm.
Wozu Drogen, wenn ich Drehstühle habe? Setze ich also auf den Drehstuhl und drehe mich so lange, bis
alle Flüssigkeit sauber mitgehe und dann halte ich das Kind fest und das Kind
findet das ganz priver, das jetzt dadurch dagegen torkelt, weil es Fehlinformation bekommt.
Die Flüssigkeit rotiert innen drin weiter, ein bisschen langsam nach und nach
wieder zum Stillstand kommt, ist ja auch klar.
Und solange die Flüssigkeit weiter rotiert, kriege ich die falsche Information,
dass ich mich noch im Raum drehe.
Das heißt, die Fischer hatten einfach dieses Gleichgewichtsorgan schon früh
ausgebildet, weil der Bedarf war absolut gegeben.
Aber es war eben auch nur das. Ein Hören war in dem Sinne so nicht mit dabei.
Aber dann im Schritte der Evolution hat sich dann dieser überflüssige Knochen
da so in die Gegend bewegt und da noch was anderes draus gemacht.
Kann man so sagen? Es gibt einen wesentlichen Punkt, müssen wir noch dazu sagen.
Diese Bogengänge sind ja, die decken ja nur drei von diesen freiheitsgradende
Bewegungen ab, nämlich die drei rotatorischen.
Wir haben ja auch noch die drei translatorischen vor, zurück,
rechts, links, hoch, runter, ohne dass wir uns drehen. Ja.
Dafür gibt es nochmal eigene, ein eigenes Sensorium.
Aber beim Fisch nicht, oder wie?
Doch, beim Fisch schon auch. Beim Fisch gibt es zumindestens bei einigen Formen,
aber da gehen jetzt meine biologischen Kenntnisse, Gehen wir aus.
Da gab es auch für diese translatorische Bewegung gab es drei Sensoren.
Ja.
Bei uns gibt es nur noch zwei. Und ohne dass ich jetzt irgendwelchen Entwicklungsbiologen
da vorgreifen möchte, muss man also jemanden fragen, der sich damit richtig ausfindet.
Ist es, glaube ich, so, dass aus einem dieser drei translatorischen Messsysteme
unser Hörsystem geworden ist.
Also wir haben sozusagen eines von den drei translatorischen aufgegeben und
haben das ins Hörorgan langsam umentwickelt.
Jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal die translatorischen nochmal an.
Angenommen wir haben eine Fläche.
Mit einem Sensorium, was Bewegung erfassen kann.
Und ich klebe auf die Fläche, klebe ich eine träge Masse drauf.
Bei uns ist das so eine galertartige Masse, die mit so Calcium-Kristall,
Knochen-Kristall, könnte man sagen, Steinchen gefüllt ist, sogenannte Otolithen.
Und wenn ich jetzt schlagartig das hochbewege, dann geht die träge Masse verzögert mit.
Also wir reden jetzt von so einer vertikal stehenden Fläche.
Genau, wir hätten eine vertikal stehende Fläche,
auf der seitlich angeordnet eine Anzahl von Sinneszellen,
das sind jetzt spezialisierte Nervenzellen, drauf sitzen, die eine Verbiegung
wahrnehmen können sensorisch.
Also es ist ungefähr so, als ob ich jetzt so ein Marmeladenbrot schmiere und
das senkrecht halte und dann nach oben ziehe, dann bleibt die Marmelade etwas zurück sozusagen.
Also ich habe jetzt Marmelade, die mir melden kann, dass sie verschoben wird in sich.
Weil da auch wieder so Herrchen sind.
Genau. Und jetzt klebe ich auf die, sagen wir mal so, ich nehme mein Marmeladenbrot.
Die Marmelade, die ist jetzt verschiebeempfindlich in sich.
Und ich setze auf die Marmelade obendrauf von mir aus noch ein Stück Leberkäs.
Und der ist jetzt schwerer als die Marmelade. Und jetzt bewege ich das Marmeladenbrot
hin und her, dann geht der Leberkäs zeitverzögert mit.
Weil er träger ist, weil er eine Trägermasse hat. Und das Marmeladenbrot haben
wir ja jetzt so konstruiert,
dass die Marmelade diese Scherbewegung wahrnehmen kann und dann kann das Marmeladenbrot
die Stärke der Beschleunigung messen, weil mit einer konstanten Beschleunigung
geht ja mein Lebercase immer zeitverzögert mit.
Das ist ja Beschleunigung mit Kraft.
Und damit habe ich einen Beschleunigungssensor konstruiert, der genau in der
Ebene funktioniert, wie das Marmeladenbrot liegt.
Und das kann ich jetzt senkrecht stellen oder leicht verkippt in den Raum stellen
oder waagerecht stellen. Ich kann das in verschiedene Positionen sozusagen konstruieren.
Im Fisch gibt es dann halt zwei solche Marmeladenbrote und die bestehen.
Warum nicht drei?
Entschuldigung, drei gibt es bei uns gibt es zwei und die haben auch entsprechende Namen.
Bei uns ist es der Utriculus und der Sacculus. Das sind also Flächen,
die mit so sensorischen Neuronen gefüllt sind und das, was wir immer als Lebercase
jetzt hatten, das ist eben so eine galertartige Masse, die draufklebt,
die eine Trägermesse das da so...
Knöchern kristalline steinchen drin sind jetzt also die träge masse
Und die sensorischen zellen die
da drin sitzen die können das ist jetzt das schöne beim Bei diesen
bei diesen flächigen sensoren das funktioniert ja sogar für zweifache jetzt
gerade ich kann das ja hoch und runter Bewegen ich kann das vor und zurück bewegen
solange ich in der ebene des Wie wir es vorhin hatten marmeladenbrot bewegt
muss ich nur die sensorischen Bewegung sensoren Die müssen zwei mit dem Fy-dimensional
da drin angeordnet sein.
Und dann brauche ich eigentlich nur zwei Flächen und kann trotzdem dreidimensionale,
translatorische Bewegungen, also eigentlich nicht Bewegungen,
sondern Beschleunigungen.
Weil aus 2x2D kann man 3D machen.
Ah ja, das erinnert mich an eine schöne Installation, die wir früher mal in
unserer Firma hatten, wo ich gearbeitet habe, wo es darum ging,
so ein Prinzip ein Globus zu steuern, also eine dreidimensionale Globus-Bewegung zu machen.
Das kann man wunderbar dadurch machen, dass man einen Ball macht,
an dem man an zwei verschiedenen Stellen einfach eine Maus dran klebt.
Wenn man nämlich dann eine Kugel bewegt, hat man quasi zwei Stellen,
an denen eine zweidimensionale Information abgegriffen wird.
Und daraus kann man die gesamte dreidimensionale Bewegung errechnen.
Das ist dann hier im Prinzip genau die selbe Logik.
Das ist die selbe Logik.
Ah ja.
So, aber jetzt ist es so, dass pfiffig. Soweit ich das weiß,
und ich sage das jetzt aber nur mit dem Vorbehalt, gab es bei den Fischen tatsächlich ein drittes.
Das war der Limulus. Also Sarkulus, Utriculus haben die Fische, haben wir.
Den Limulus, den gab es bei den Fischen noch, oder vielleicht waren es nur bestimmte
Arten, aus denen wir entstanden sind. Vielleicht nicht bei allen,
also überlasse ich Biologen das zu beantworten.
Und dieser dritte, der hat sich nach und nach verformt und ist nach und nach
spezialisiert, hat sich nach und nach spezialisiert zu einem Hörorgan.
Das heißt also unsere Kochlehrer, das Innenohr ist sozusagen,
wenn das denn so stimmt, wie ich das im Kopf habe, aus einem Teil des translatorischen
Sensoriums der Fische entstanden, hat sich umgebildet nach und nach in einen Vibrations...
Ja, im Prinzip auch diese galärtartige
Bewegungssensorik letztlich ja eine Flüssigkeitsbewegungssensorik ist.
Also genau das, was der Steigbügel durch die Umsetzung des Luftdrucks auf diese Hörschnecke gibt,
wird ja dann quasi eine Bewegung, eine reale Bewegung erzeugt,
die zwar sehr hoch aufgelöst ist und etwas was
sich aus diesem eigentlichen wohin bewegt sich mein ganzer körpersensorik heraus
entwickelt hat übernimmt dann quasi hören weil es sehr viel feiner ausgebildet
ist also was sie was jetzt dann bei der hörschnecke dazu kommt damit kommen
jetzt zum eigentlichen Hörorgan. Aber diese Gleichgewichtsgeschichte...
Also wie muss man sich das jetzt konkret beim Menschen vorstellen?
Also wir haben zwei Sensoren quasi, die fürs Gleichgewicht zuständig sind.
Und Gleichgewicht heißt ja im Prinzip Gravitationsmessung.
Bei uns nicht, nee. Wir messen nicht die Gravitation damit.
Aber die Gravitation zieht doch im Prinzip die ganze Zeit auch an diesen Härchen.
Also das ist ja quasi eine immer fort...
Wir fallen ja eigentlich die ganze Zeit.
Zeit. Ja, aber dann, ja das ist aber dann, weil wir ja natürlich so eine Gegenkraft
haben, die das irgendwann in Ruhe lässt.
Also die Gravitation ist eine ständig nach unten wirkende Kraft,
stimmt natürlich, aber diese galertartigen Pakete von Trägermasse,
die folgen dem halt um, was weiß ich, so und so viel Mikrometer,
Verbiegung und dann ist aber Ruhe, dann ist da der Stillstand.
Okay, die werden dann sozusagen festgehalten relativ zu diesem 1G,
darauf sind sie halt geeicht quasi.
Genau. Und wenn ich jetzt dann aus diesem Ruhezustand beschleunige,
indem ich zum Beispiel springe, runterfalle oder hochspringe,
mich hochwärts bewege, dann tritt natürlich eine Beschleunigung auf.
Also die träge Masse relativ zu ihrem eigentlichen Ruheort verschoben.
Und die Nervenzellen, die diese Verschiebung messen können und ans Sensorium
weiter oben weiter leiten, die melden dann natürlich diese Verschiebung.
Aber es ist nicht sozusagen per se die Schwerkraft, die wir messen,
sondern es ist immer ein Beschleunigungssensor, den wir da haben.
Ja, aber die sind immer relativ zu diesem einen G ist. Das ist richtig, ja.
Wie rum sind denn jetzt diese beiden Platten eigentlich ausgerichtet?
Sind die in der vertikalen und horizontalen oder sind die irgendwie?
Die sind schräg verkippt. Also die sind auch die Bogengänge.
Die liegen jetzt nicht waagerecht senkrecht und 90 Grad zueinander schon.
Zueinander schon.
Aber die liegen trotzdem so schräg verkippt.
Weil es eigentlich egal ist, was das Letzte ist.
Weil es eigentlich egal ist. Also es gibt in die eine Richtung sind es glaube
ich 30 Grad so hoch rückwärts gekippt und die andere Richtung 45 Grad so einwärts.
Das ist das, was ich jetzt mal so aus dem Bauch heraus ungefähr weiß.
Aber...
Wie es so passt halt. Da müsste man halt die Anatomen fragen.
Ich war ja mal eben in einem Parabellflug.
Kurz gesagt, die viel zu schnell vorübergehende Herstellung von nicht kompletter
Abwesenheit von Gravitation,
aber der Einfluss der Schwerkraft wird halt so weit reduziert,
dass man sich halt schwerelos fühlt.
Es gibt dann auch so diverse Restkräfte, die aber an der Stelle keine Rolle
machen, weil man schwebt bereits durch die Luft und ist so sehr damit beschäftigt,
dass man sich um diese paar Zahlen hinter dem Komma nicht noch groß kümmern würde.
Und diese Schwerelosigkeit im Parabelflug wird ja dadurch hergestellt,
dass man eben das Flugzeug mit einem enormen Schub für eine Weile so 45 Grad
nach oben schießen lässt.
Und da merkt man überhaupt erstmal, was für eine Power in so Flugzeugtriebwerken
drin stecken kann oder generell halt auch drin steckt.
Um das halt überhaupt erstmal zu leisten, ist in dem Zeitpunkt dieses Einknickens
in diesem Flug nach oben, nimmt die Beschleunigung auf den Körper erstmal enorm zu.
Also man landet dann so bei 1,5 bis 1,8 g.
Also bevor man quasi 0G erreicht, muss man zwischenzeitlich auf 1,5 bis 1,8G beschleunigt werden.
Das ergibt sich halt einfach durch diese Flugbahn und in dem Moment,
wo man dann so bei wirklich bei 45 Grad ist und die Piloten,
da wird ja von drei Piloten gleichzeitig geflogen, auch eine total abgefahrene Sache.
Da kümmert sich sozusagen auch jeder um, also ein Pilot kümmert sich um den
Winkel, der Also kümmert sich um die Geschwindigkeit und der andere um das links-rechts
Ding, also voll abgefahrene Nummer.
So, und dann wird halt einfach der Schub rausgelassen, man hört das auch so
richtig, die Triebwerke gehen aus, also nicht komplett aus, aber kein Schub
mehr, so und man fällt einfach nur noch.
Und das sind dann halt diese magischen 22 Sekunden,
die man dann einfach fällt und in dem Moment gleicht quasi der Fall des Flugzeugs,
der am Anfang natürlich noch nach oben geht, weil man eben so eine unglaubliche
Geschwindigkeit hat, die Anziehung der Gravitation außer, dass man eben bei 0 g ist.
Und dann am Schluss gibt es halt nochmal etwas mehr Beschleunigung.
Und das Problem ist, dass wenn man diese Phase gut überstehen will,
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Verhindern musst, dass es einem schlecht wird. Und im Wesentlichen ist es wohl
so, dadurch dass unser Gleichgewichtsystem ja nicht für 1G gemacht ist,
sondern so eine Überlast auf einmal stattfindet, die man normalerweise ja so nicht hat.
Also wenn man sich auf dem Planeten bewegt, dann ist irgendwie immer alles 1G.
Also es sei denn, man springt halt irgendwo vom Berg oder so,
ganz klar, aber dann hat man eh andere Probleme.
Durch diese Überbeschleunigung wird da irgendwie alles zusammen gedrückt,
sodass man das, dass der Körper eigentlich eine falsche Information bekommt.
Weil quasi die Basis, dieses 1G bricht auf einmal weg und auf einmal werden
so die relativen Geschwindigkeiten falsch berechnet.
Also vielen wird dann halt deshalb schlecht, so wo das mehr erläutert, weil man in dem Moment,
wo halt das Auge irgendeine Bewegung sieht, also wenn man so hin und her guckt,
dann meldet halt das Auge so, Dinge bewegen sich,
während das Gleichgewichtssignal halt sagt so,
hier bewegt sich einfach mal gar nichts, weil hier liegt irgendwie alles nur
platt zusammengepresst rum und aus diesem Differenzsignal macht dann das Hirn
diese Notstandsmeldung mit unterschiedliche Wahrnehmungen deiner Sinnesorgane.
Wahrscheinlich bist du vergiftet, fang mal besser an zu kotzen,
weil sonst wird es alles noch viel schlimmer. Das ist so diese kritische Phase.
Man wird da mit allerlei Medikamenten vollgepumpt, um diese Reaktion zu entschleunigen.
Jetzt habe ich viel erzählt.
Wie geht das hier, du warst wahrscheinlich noch nicht in einem Parabelflug,
wie würdest du das sozusagen hier auf die Funktionsweise des Gleichgewichtsorgans übertragen?
Also wie geht es dem Gleichgewichtsorgan, wenn man auf einmal Also eins muss
man natürlich dazu sagen,
wenn man jetzt frei fällt, dann wird man ja permanent beschleunigt.
Man ist ja eigentlich dann eben tatsächlich in der Beschleunigung von 1G ausgesetzt im Parabelflug.
Der Trick besteht ja darin, dass man sich eine Kapsel um sich selber gebaut
hat, nämlich das Flugzeug, das genau dieselbe Sache vollzieht und nur relativ
zu dieser Kapsel ist man ja schwerelos.
In Wirklichkeit fliegt man ja eine Parabel und die Kapsel um einen rum fliegt dieselbe Parabel.
Und wenn man das Ganze jetzt ohne Kapsel erleben würde, dann würde man sehen,
dass man da irgendwie in höheren Atmosphären so ein Parabel fliegt und sich
jetzt dem Erdboden nähert.
Also man hat, man befindet sich in der Situation natürlich sehr wohl in einem
beschleunigten Zustand, aber,
Was die Sache so irritierend macht, ist, wie du schon gesagt hast,
das Gehirn schlägt Alarm, weil da so eine Widerspruchsinformation auf einmal entsteht,
dass das visuelle System, was völlig anderes meldet, nämlich totale Ruhe und
Frieden und hier ist alles in Ordnung,
und das andere System meldet irgendwie, ich falle, ich falle,
ich falle, das ist irgendwie in sich im Widerspruch. Und eine der Schwierigkeiten, die...
Aber an der Stelle ist ja eigentlich das Auge eher das Problem.
Man löst es dadurch, dass man wie ein Blöder auf einen Punkt startet und keinerlei
Bewegungsinformationen visuell einspeist.
Das Problem entsteht eigentlich erst in dem Moment, wo ich jetzt aus Interesse,
wie es den anderen alles so geht, herumschauen, meinen Kopf drehen.
Das erzeugt dann überhaupt erst die Übelkeit, weil eigentlich der Gleichgewichtssinn
so zusammengepresst ist und sagt, nichts tut sich.
Keine Bewegung statt. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich meinen Kopf bewege,
müsste ja diese Bewegung des Kopfes auch vom Gleichgewichtsorgan gemessen werden.
Dadurch, dass ich in dem Moment gerade 1,8G ausgesetzt bin,
ist die Funktion dieses Gleichgewichtsorgans offensichtlich ausgenullt,
weil es einfach zusammengepresst wird und nicht mehr die Reibungen und Herrchenbewegungen
so wahrnehmen kann, wie das normalerweise der Fall ist.
Ne, das sehe ich genau anders. Also gut, ich habe jetzt selber die Erfahrung
noch nicht gemacht. Ich habe noch keinen Parabellflug gemacht.
Aber das Gleichgewichtsorgan misst die Beschleunigung, die es tatsächlich erfährt.
Du fällst ja. Also wenn du, wenn du von, was sage ich, wenn du falsche Umsprungen
machst und du springst raus aus dem Flugzeug.
Ja, es misst die 1,8G, aber es ist dafür halt nicht gebaut.
Doch, doch, doch, sicher. Und deswegen ist es über seine Grenzen.
Nee, das ist nicht über seine Grenzen. Das ist nicht jetzt irgendwie am Anschlag
und kann das nicht messen. Also die Fähigkeit, das zu messen,
hat das Gleichgewichtorgan sehr wohl.
Klar kommt das irgendwann mal an Anschlag und kriegt extreme Beschleunigungen
nicht mehr richtig einsortiert und aufgelöst.
Aber so eine normale Fallbeschleunigung von 1G, gut vielleicht lehne ich mich
da jetzt so sehr aus dem Fenster.
Aber das ist ja 1,8 g. Also genau dieser Übergangsmoment ist das Problem.
Wenn du wieder eintauchst und wenn die Sache wieder losgeht vor allem.
Ach so, wenn es nach oben schießt, dann entsteht unglaublicher Druck.
Man wird da irgendwie mit den Beinen auf den Boden gepresst,
als hätte man so Metallstiefel an oder magnetisch schon fast.
Das ist ein völlig abgefahrenes Gefühl.
Na gut, ich will das jetzt auch nicht zu sehr vertiefen.
Auf jeden Fall merkt man auch, wie die Sinne zusammenarbeiten und gemeinsame
Erwartungshaltung permanent miteinander vergleichen und wenn die halt nicht
stattfinden, dann ist irgendwie bekloppt. Na gut.
Kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen Wahrnehmung. Weil bisher,
um es vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen zusammenzufalten, also wir haben das
Außenohr leitet die Frequenzen in den Gehörgang.
Das trifft aufs Trommelfell an. Dahinter gibt es dieses mechanische System,
was geschickt diese große Angriffsfläche,
Trommelfell, dann auf einen sehr kleinen Punkt konzentriert.
Am Ende des Steigbügels durch diese mechanische Übersetzung zwischen Hammer
und Ambus wird die auch noch so verstärkt, dass man quasi so einen ganz kleinen Piks erzeugt.
Also von so einer großen Fläche wird es immer weiter verdichtet bis es wirklich
nur noch so eine ganz kleine, ich weiß nicht wie groß ist diese Kontaktfläche
des Steigbügels real mit der Hörschnecke?
Das ist, ich weiß nicht, in Größenordnung ein Quadratmillimeter,
vielleicht zwei Quadratmillimeter, also wirklich ziemlich klein.
Und das Trommelfell selber?
Das hat schon etwas größeren Durchmesser. So in Größenordnung,
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger als ein Quadratzentimeter.
Das heißt, da wird dann schon so ein Faktor 100, das reduziert.
Also in der einen Achse zumindest gerechnet.
Worauf trifft das jetzt aus? Also jetzt haben wir diese Hörschnecke und wir
wissen, okay, das hat sich wahrscheinlich aus unserem Gleichgewichtsorgan,
was über war, weil die anderen beiden sich so spezialisiert haben,
dass es schon gereicht hat für die dreidimensionale Messung.
Was geschieht jetzt da in dieser Schnecke? Was ist da überhaupt verschneckt.
Also als erstes muss man sich die Fußplatte vom Steigbügel jetzt vorstellen,
als wenn die so wie ein Kolben in die Flüssigkeit eine Schallwelle hineinpumpt.
Es gibt der Vollständigkeit halber, es gibt also nicht nur diesen einen Eingang
in die Schnecke, sondern es gibt sozusagen auch noch einen Ausgang.
Also dieser Steigbügel, der sitzt mit seiner Fußplatte in so einer ovalen Öffnung,
wo dahinter die Flüssigkeit von der Hörschnecke anfängt.
Es gibt weiter unten gibt es noch ein zweites Fenster, das ist aber jetzt nicht
mechanisch irgendwie mit Knochen abgedeckt, sondern das ist mit einer gespannten Haut.
Das ist das sogenannte Runde Fenster.
Und der Flüssigkeitsraum der Schnecke sitzt jetzt in einem sehr festen,
sehr dichten Knochen drin.
Das ist das sogenannte Felsenbein, hat also seinen Namen auch davon,
dass es so dichter Knochen ist. Der ist vermutlich aus akustischen Gründen so
dicht und fest gebaut. Das ist der dichteste Knochen, den wir im ganzen Körper haben.
Damit keine Schallwellen sozusagen einfach rauslaufen ins Nachbarknochengewebe raus.
Also die Flüssigkeitsraum der Schnecke ist mehr oder weniger fest abgeschlossen
in einem sehr genau definierten Volumen.
Das ist Felsenbein umschließt die komplette Hörschnecke.
Richtig, ja. Also man muss sich die Hörschnecke vorstellen, auch die Bogengänge
vom Gleichgewichtorgan muss man sich vorstellen als flüssigkeitsgefüllte Hohlräume
in einem sehr festen Knochenmaterial.
Und die Schnecke ist eben auch ein schneckenförmig gewundener,
flüssig, wie genau das ausschaut, können wir gleich nochmal vielleicht ein bisschen
drauf eingehen, ein geschlossenes Volumen.
Und wenn ich jetzt diesen Steigbügel dann nehme und ich will da was reinpumpen,
dann stoße ich natürlich auf dem Widerstand, wenn ich ein komplett abgeschlossenes
Volumen hätte. Ich brauche irgendwo anders einen Ausgleich, wo das Volumen wieder
ausgeglichen werden kann.
Also wenn ich da reinpumpe, muss es irgendwo anders raus und diesen Zweck hat das runde Fenster.
Nur vor dem runden Fenster ist jetzt eine feste Haut gespannt,
also so ein eigener Membran ist dort und wenn die Steigbügel,
bleibe ich das ganz langsam machen, wenn ich mit dem Steigbügel,
also die Chirurgen bei einer OP, können das wirklich sehen.
Die können da mit ihrer OP, mit dem OP-Instrumentsrand können das berühren und
können dann sehen, wenn Sie den Steigbügel ein bisschen reindrücken,
dann kommt unten die Membran vom runden Fenster so ein kleines bisschen raus.
Das heißt also, wenn der Steigbügel jetzt seine Schallwelle Richtung in die Flüssigkeit hinein.
Dann passiert am anderen Ende genau das Gegendruckphänomen mit dem ovalen Fenster.
So habe ich also einen Volumenausgleich.
So wie so ein Lautsprecher auch immer noch mal ein Loch irgendwo hat.
Ja, könnte man so diese, wie hießen die noch? Diese Basse-Reflexionsboxen,
wie es da gab. Gab es ja so ganz tolle Prinzipien oder noch immer.
Also das Volumen wird also, Es ist also überhaupt nur möglich,
eine Flüssigkeit dort ordentlich mit einem hohen Wirkungsgrad,
eine Schallwelle reinzuschicken, wenn ich diese Ausgleichsmöglichkeit habe.
Aber sonst würde ja der Steigbügel quasi festes Material stoßen und keinerlei
Frequenzen übertragen können.
Genau. Also es ist nicht ganz so, weiß man inzwischen, waren auch alle überrascht,
dass es auch trotzdem geht. Aber jetzt so für die erste Annahme,
für die erste Näherung dessen, wie man sich das vorstellen muss,
muss man sagen, okay, da gibt es also ein konstantes Volumen, das ausgeglichen.
Damit wir jetzt mal anschauen, was da eigentlich vor sich geht,
stellen wir uns die Schnecke mal vor, wie so eine kleine Gartenschnecke,
die man hat, so eine richtig winzige.
Die ist insgesamt ziemlich klein, die passt also in so einen Kubikzentimeter rein.
Also eigentlich könnte man sagen, wenn ich hier so eine Fingerkuppe nehme,
so vielleicht vom kleinen Finger oder von einem durchschnittlichen Finger,
die Fingerkuppe oben, die gesamte Kochlehr passt da rein.
Kochlea ist die Hörschnecke. Also Kochlea ist jetzt, ich glaube,
der griechische Begriff für Schnecke wirklich.
Und wir haben also jetzt da einen Knochen und in diesen Knochen hinein haben
wir einen schneckenförmig gewundenen Tunnelgang im Knochen drin.
Zweieinhalb Windungen bei uns Menschen. Bei anderen Tieren sind das ein bisschen mehr oder weniger.
Also bei Meerschwanchien sind es zum Beispiel schon vier, ein Viertel oder so Windungen.
Bei uns sind es eben, Meerschwanchien hört auch zum Beispiel auch höhere Frequenzen,
bei uns sind es zweieinhalb Windungen. Und wenn wir uns diese...
Die Anzahl der Windungen gibt es auch schon Aufschluss darauf, wie viel Frequenz?
Ja, da kommen auch viele andere Sachen noch, Gesamtvolumen kommt noch hinzu,
es kommt noch hinzu, wie der Durchmesser ist, wie sich der Durchmesser des gewundenen Gangs...
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Variable, das ist jetzt nicht so konstant.
Ja, sogar beim Mensch ist es sehr variabel. Also da gibt es Anatomen, die das über viele...
Leute, die verstorben sind, die sich das dann untersucht haben,
die Variationsbreite ist unglaublich groß.
Aber wenn wir jetzt mal ran wollen, wie sich die Sache...
Heißt das, dass es sich aus solchen Sachen ergibt, ob man gut hört oder nicht gut hört?
Soweit möchte ich mich nicht aus dem Fernsehen verlehnen.
Ich glaube nicht so richtig. Und wie das dann in der Wahrnehmung ist,
wie das dann oben bei uns im Bewusstsein kommt, das ist ja immer noch mal eine ganz andere Sache.
Aber wenn wir uns diese schneckenförmige Windung im Knochen anschauen und wir
würden das jetzt mal so im Querschnitt sehen,
das heißt, wir würden die Schnecke von der Spitze her spalten und würden uns
den Querschnitt angucken,
dann würden wir von einer Windung der Schnecke, würden wir erst mal in gröbster
Näherung sagen, das ist ein kreisförmiger Querschnitt, der an einer Seite so
scharf eingezogen ist nach innen.
Man könnte jetzt sagen, das ist so nierenförmig, stimmt aber nicht ganz.
Für die Nerds unter den Hörern eine Kardioide, diese mathematische Kurve,
die so eine Einschnürung an einer Seite hat, also so ein Kreis mit einer scharfen
Einschnürung in die Mitte hin.
Das trifft meines Erachtens am am ehesten, wie man den Querschnitt einer Windung
des schneckenförmigen Tunnelgangs sich vorstellen muss.
Und das bedeutet, diese Einschnürung, die ist aber auf der Innenseite,
also da, wo die Schnecke ihre zentrale Achse hat, von dort in die Windung hinein
geht diese Einschnürung.
Und diese Einschnürung, die kann man sich als einen kleinen Knochensteg vorstellen,
in diesen flüssigkeitsgefüllten Hohlraum der Schneckenwindung hinein ragt.
Von diesem Knochensteg, der auf halber Höhe in die Schneckenwindung innen rein
ragt, spannt sich ein Membran auf die gegenüberliegende Seite.
Das heißt, die Schnecke ist nochmal in so zwei Teile zerteilt?
Genau, die Schnecke ist in eine obere und eine untere Hälfte zerteilt.
Die Zerteilung geht einerseits durch diesen hineinragenden Knochensteg und in
Fortsetzung dessen durch eine Membran, die zur gegenüberliegenden Wand gespannt ist.
Das teilt die Schnecke in zwei Hälften. Die obere Hälfte ist aber auch nochmal geteilt.
Das bleiben wir aber erstmal bei diesem Steg. Also der Steg ragt in die Schnecke
hinein und von dort geht eine Membran zur gegenüberliegenden Seite.
Das ist die sogenannte Basilarmembran und die ist im Anfangsbereich der Schnecke,
ist die Basilarmembran kurz.
Also der Weg vom Knochensteg zur gegenüberliegenden Seite, der ist relativ kurz.
Also wir sprechen davon so einem Millimeter oder eineinhalb Millimetern.
Und wenn wir jetzt tiefer reingehen, also dieser Schneckenwindung weiter und
weiter nach innen einwärts folgen,
dann zieht sich dieser hineinragende Knochensteg immer mehr zurück und der Teil,
der durch eine Membran gespannt ist, der wird immer breiter.
Und bevor wir ganz oben im äußersten oberen Ende ankommen, hört die Membran auf.
Und da ist dann die obere Hälfte von der Schneckenwindung und des Hohlraums
einer einzelnen Schneckenwindung.
Und die untere Hälfte sind miteinander verbunden.
Das heißt, wenn man da im Prinzip jetzt reingehen würde in diese Hörschnicke,
hätte man die Wahl zwischen oben und unten, weil die einfach über die komplette
Fläche von so einer Membran geteilt sind.
Bis ich ganz nach oben gehe, diese Membran dehnt sich immer weiter aus.
Ganz oben ist hier dann aber zu Ende. Ich kann im Prinzip auf die andere Seite
wechseln und auf der anderen Seite diese Hörschnecke wieder runter marschieren.
Wieder runter marschieren. Und das ist genau das, was der Schallweg nimmt.
Und das ist alles mit dieser Flüssigkeit gefüllt?
Das alles ist mit Flüssigkeit gefüllt.
Und jetzt dieser Steigbügel da drauf hämmert, dann jagt er quasi diese Schockwelle
durch die Flüssigkeit einmal hoch und wieder runter.
Der Steigbügel sitzt jetzt so, dass er seine Schallwelle in den oberen Teil hineinjagt.
Jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor, dass der Steigbügel sich ganz langsam pumpend rein und raus bewegt.
Der pumpt also rein, das heißt, der schiebt seine Flüssigkeit vor sich her und
zwar in der oberen Hälfte von diesem Querschnitt.
Und das, was der an Flüssigkeit vor sich her schiebt, geht also jetzt zweieinhalb Windungen hoch.
Oben ist dann die Trennmembran zwischen den beiden Hälften zu Ende.
Diese Stelle nennt man Helikotremer.
Dort wird das Volumen in die untere Hälfte runter gedrückt und wandert sozusagen
in der unteren Hälfte wieder zurück und drückt unten die Membran des runden Fensters raus.
Und wenn der Knochen, also der Steigbügel, die Gegenbewegung macht,
also sozusagen wieder zurück zieht beim Rein- oder Rauspumpen,
dann passiert genau das Umgekehrte.
Dann zieht er das Flüssigkeitsvolumen zweieinhalb Windungen wieder zurück,
oben wird ein bisschen wieder zurückgezogen, unten, am zweieinhalb Windungen
im unteren Teil runtergehend, wird die Membran eingezogen und so bleibt die
Flüssigkeit konstant. Das heißt dadurch, dass der Steigbügel,
hinein pumpt mit einer schwingenden Bewegung wird die gesamte Flüssigkeitssäule
durch die Kochlehr aber eben in gewundener Form hin und her bewegt.
Im Prinzip so, als ob ich so einen dicken Gummischlauch nehmen würde.
In der Mitte knick ich den, legt ihn sozusagen so zu zwei Strängen zusammen.
An der einen macht er Wasser rein und drücke da jetzt Blase da zum Beispiel
rein, aber ans andere Ende mach ich so einen kleinen Luftballon.
Wenn ich das so reindrücke, würde das Wasser den Luftballon entsprechend aufblasen
und wenn ich es wieder zurücknehme, geht es wieder zurück.
Das ist quasi so diese Aktivität, die jetzt in dieser Hörschnecke die ganze
Zeit erzeugt wird durch diese...
Ja, der Trick... Das ist richtig. Das habe ich aber jetzt absichtlich erstmal
ganz langsam in der Vorstellung gemacht, dass der Steigbügel nur langsam da
hoch und runter pumpt. Macht er natürlich.
Macht er natürlich nicht. Das macht er natürlich je nachdem,
welche Frequenzen von außen kommen. Wenn also so ein tiefer Bass kommt,
dann so richtig tiefer, so 20 Hertz, dann passiert ungefähr das.
Oder machen wir es noch noch langsam mal. Ein Herz.
Einmal pro Sekunde.
Das, was der Chirurg, wenn er operiert, tatsächlich mechanisch machen kann,
indem er da mit seinem Instrument an dem Steigbügel macht. Der kann natürlich
nicht beliebig schnell, der kann das so ein bisschen hin und her bewegen und
dann sieht er diese Flüssigkeit hin und her laufen.
Wenn ich das aber jetzt schneller und schneller und schneller mache,
mit anderen Worten, wenn ich zu höheren und höheren und höheren Frequenzen gehe,
dann wird das natürlich physikalisch,
energetisch gesehen immer mühsamer, diese gesamte Flüssigkeit,
dass wir haben, wir reden ja hier mehr oder weniger von dem ganzen Flüssigkeitsraum,
der in der Kochlehr drin ist, vom ganzen Volumen, es wird immer mühsamer,
die ganze Flüssigkeit hin und her zu schieben.
Das wird energetisch immer aufwendiger, immer schwieriger.
Das hat ja auch seine eigene Trägheit.
Richtig, das hat eben, weil es eine trägemasse darstellt, eine trägeschwingende Masse.
Weil wir aber von Schall reden, wir haben ja einen Steigbügel,
der jetzt ein Schall Signal in die Schnecke reinschickt, müssen wir auch erstmal
von der Schallgeschwindigkeit reden, mit der das da reinläuft.
Wir haben ja, In der Außenwelt haben wir ja Luftschall. Das Schalllaufgeschwindigkeit
sind so ungefähr 335 Meter pro Sekunde Schallgeschwindigkeit und in Flüssigkeit,
in Wasser ist das viel höher.
Das sind ungefähr so 1700, 1800 Meter pro Sekunde, je nachdem noch wie die Flüssigkeit
zusammengesetzt ist. Und das geht natürlich rasend schnell.
Das hat jetzt mit diesem Impedanzausgleichsphänomen des Mittelohrs erstmal gar
nichts zu tun, wie schnell die Laufzeiten da drin sind. Aber Wenn der Stapel….
Hinein pumpt in die Flüssigkeit, dann sendet er ja,
auch wenn das langsam ist, sendet er gewissermaßen eine Schallwelle rein in die Flüssigkeit,
wie man in so ein Rohr eine Schallwelle rein senden kann,
wenn das Luft- oder Flüssigkeitsgefüllt ist, dann läuft die einfach da lang
und so sendet auch der pumpende Stapes in diese Flüssigkeit hinein,
in die Flüssigkeit hinein, eine longitudinal längs
laufende Schallwelle und die
ist es die sozusagen wenn man das das in
diesem statischen langsamen hin- und herpumpzustand uns
überlegen wenn ich also jetzt Den stapes
reindrücke dann kommt um diese laufzeit verzögert kommt unten die membran raus
das ist ja Die laufzeit des schalt das natürlich auch dann so wenn ich es ganz
langsam mache Schall läuft ja nicht deswegen schneller weil man eine niedrige
frequenz hat also auch dann so wenn man es ganz langsam macht nur für so den Beobachter,
der das sich so mental vorstellt, wirkt das instantan.
Ich schiebe einfach hier so eine Flüssigkeit hin und her. Aber in Wirklichkeit
geht das natürlich mit der Laufgeschwindigkeit von der Schallwelle.
Weil aber das ganze System so irrwitzig klein ist und die Schallwelle in Flüssigkeit
unheimlich schnell läuft, kann man in erster Näherung mal so tun, als wäre das instantan.
Das ist jetzt mal nur am Rande gesprochen. Wenn man jetzt aber zu höheren und
höheren Einprägefrequenzen wechselt,
also langsam die Schwingfrequenz des Stapes hochdrehen, dann wird es physikalisch
vom Energieaufwand immer unangenehmer,
wenn das System die ganze Flüssigkeit hin und her pumpen muss.
Und jetzt fängt das System irgendwann an und da wird es
wirklich unglaublich schlau und da steht man immer wieder davor
und staunt Bauklötze was die Evolution
dazu stande gebracht hat jetzt fängt irgendwann an die Flüssigkeitssäule nicht
mehr den Umweg übers Helikodrehm zu gehen sondern das ist der höchsten Punkt
über diesen höchsten Punkt wo die beiden Flüssigkeitshälften miteinander in
Verbindung stehen sondern sagt sich menschlich gesprochen,
da verbiege ich doch lieber die Membran.
Das heißt also, anstatt dass die Flüssigkeit oben rum läuft,
bollt sich die Membran nach unten aus bzw. schwingt wieder zurück.
Das heißt also, das Hin- und Herpumpen der beiden Flüssigkeitshälften...
Nimmt jetzt salopp gesprochene Abkürzung, indem die Membran hoch und runter ausgelenkt wird.
Und das Ganze passiert je nach Frequenz an unterschiedlichen Stellen.
Das heißt, je nachdem, wo die
Membran eingedrückt wird, misst man dadurch quasi eine andere Frequenz.
Ganz genau.
Und das geht alles gleichzeitig.
Jetzt gehen mehrere Sachen Hand in Hand. Ich hatte ja ursprünglich gesagt,
die Membran unten im Eingangsbereich ist zur gegenüberliegenden Seite relativ
kurz und nach oben wird sie immer länger.
Sieht die gespannte Weite der Basilarmembran.
Und das hat schon der alte Helmholtz gewusst. Also hier ist doch hier in Berlin
das Helmholtz-Institute, Helmholtz kennt man.
Und der hatte damals schon gesagt, Moment mal, das ist ja so,
als hätte ich sozusagen aneinander liegende,
gespannte Seiten, wie von einem Seiteninstrument, die immer von diesem Knochensteg
zur gegenüberliegenden Wand gespannt sind, kann ich diese Membranien interpretieren
als infinitisimal dicht aneinander liegende schwingende Seiten.
Und jetzt sind die da unten kürzer, so wie bei einem Seiteninstrument.
Kurze Seite, hohe Frequenz. Die weiter drin sind länger, also eher für eine
tiefe Frequenz zuständig. Deren Schwingungsvorzug ist bei einer tieferen Frequenz.
Und da hatte der damals schon gesagt, das ist schon ein spektraler Analysator.
Der macht jetzt schon eine Umsetzung der Frequenzanteile im Schallsignal auf
verschiedene Stellen im Ohr.
Das Ganze ist aber doch noch ein ganzes Stückchen komplexer.
Aber diese Dinge gehen zumindest Hand in Hand. Wir haben also einerseits die
energetische Anstrengung mehr oder weniger Flüssigkeitssäule hin und her pumpen zu müssen.
Je höher die Frequenz, desto energetisch günstiger ist es, wenn ich gar nicht
die ganze Flüssigkeit solle pumpe, sondern wenn ich früher und früher und früher
stattdessen die Membran sich verbiegen lasse.
Das hat natürlich auch seinen Preis. Die Membranverbiegung will ja als energetisch-physikalisch
gesprochen, will ja auch bezahlt sein.
Braucht man ja auch Energie dafür, die zu verbiegen. Deswegen geht es bei ganz
langsamen niedrigen Frequenzen trotzdem obenrum, weil das wiederum günstiger
ist, als die Membran zu verbiegen. Ja.
So und wenn ich also jetzt zu höheren und höheren Frequenzen gehe,
gehen diese drei Dinge Hand in Hand. Erstens,
dass die Breite der Membran nach unten hin immer kürzer wird.
Zweitens, dass die Flüssigkeitssäule, die ich hin und her pumpen muss,
immer weniger Masse ist, die ich bewegen muss.
Und drittens habe ich noch ein gewundenes System. Das heißt also tiefe Schallwellen
gehen, jetzt mal ganz salopp gesprochen, gehen leichter um die Ecke als hohe Schallwellen.
Hatten wir ja schon bei den Höhen von außen und so.
Hatten wir schon von außen. Das ist eine relativ neue Idee.
Das ist erst in Simulationen vor ein paar Jahren erst so rausgekommen,
weil man sich immer gedacht hat, warum eigentlich Schnecke? Warum müssen wir
eine Schnecke haben? Die Vögel haben nämlich keine Schnecke und die Dinosaurier,
die haben nur einen hohlen Stift sozusagen.
Die haben nur eine gerade oder so leicht gebogenen liegenden,
so eine Art Banane, könnte man vielleicht sagen, haben die.
Aber bei denen ist das nicht wirklich zu einer Schnecke geworden.
Und eine der neueren Theorien, warum das eine Schnecke ist, ist diese Geschichte,
dass wenn ich das nochmal um die Ecke gehen lassen muss, dass ich dann nochmal
eine bessere Frequenzseparierung bekomme.
Grundsätzlich kann man sagen, die tiefen Frequenzen werden eher am Ende dieser
Schnecke dekodiert und die höheren Frequenzen am Anfang.
Die tiefen Frequenzen sind tief drin.
Hm, da kann man sich gut merken.
Ja, und dann kommt noch was anderes hinzu.
Betrachten wir uns mal diese Membran, die sozusagen hoch und runter verbogen
wird, je nachdem welche Frequenz ich einpräge.
Das kann man sich natürlich wie so eine rauf und runter schlackernde Teppichblase
vielleicht vorstellen, aber in Wirklichkeit ist das auch noch mal komplizierter.
Das ist erst so Mitte dieses Jahrhunderts dann entdeckt worden,
als man sich das mal so richtig ganz genau angeguckt hat.
Jetzt hat man festgestellt, Und in dem Bereich, wo diese Membran auf und ab
schwingt, schwingt das ja gar nicht so naiv wie eine Teppichblase rauf und runter,
sondern in dem Bereich schwingt das sowieso wie kleine Wellen.
Das heißt also der Bereich, der überhaupt schwingt, schwingt nicht wie eine
Teppichblase flap flap flap rauf und runter, sondern schwingt sozusagen mit
einer Welligkeit rauf und runter. Und diese Welligkeit, die läuft so ein bisschen durch.
Die bewegt sich sozusagen von einem zum anderen Ort durch. Das ist die berühmte Wanderwelle.
Und das ist erst so berühmt. Ja, Wanderwelle ist schon...
Also alle, die sich mit dem Ohr beschäftigen, die haben dann sofort mit dieser Wanderwelle zu tun.
Und das ist was, wofür es sogar einen Nobelpreis gegeben hat.
Und zwar hat von Bekeshi, ich glaube 1956, einen Nobelpreis dafür gekriegt.
Genau diese mechanische Spezialität der Kochlehrer überhaupt in dieser Klarheit
zu entdecken und zu finden.
Und diese Wanderwelle, die kann man jetzt natürlich,
mikroskopisch beobachten. Heutzutage wird das mit allen möglichen schlauen Gerätschaften
wie Laserdoppler, Vibrometer etc. wird das gemacht. Der Becci selber hat sich
selber mechanische Modelle gebaut und hat das daran nachverzogen.
Und diese Wanderwelle hat jetzt die Eigenschaft, dass die zu den tiefen Frequenzen
hin irgendwann ganz plötzlich aufhört.
Also diese Teppichblase, das ist nicht so ein weiter Bereich,
der so locker rauf und rum flappert, sondern zu tiefen Bereichen,
ist ganz schnell Schluss und zu den höheren Bereichen hin ist es lautstärkeabhängig.
Wenn man ganz leise ist hat man ganz scharf beschränkt den Bereich wo das aktiv
ist und wenn man höhere lautstärken macht dann dehnt sich das immer weiter Richtung hohen Frequenzen aus.
Das heißt also das ist auch das warum Bässe so hörschädigend sein können,
weil wenn ich einen richtig massiven Bass auf das Ohr draufschicke dann ist
ja der Ort wo der Bass sich am stärksten auswirkt ist ja tief drin oben in der
Spitze von der Schnecke.
Ich habe mir gesagt, die tiefen Frequenzen sitzen tief drin.
Aber wenn das dann noch zusätzlich entsprechend laut ist, dann schwingt am Ende
sozusagen die gesamte Kochlehrer bei dieser tiefen Frequenz.
Ich kann also auch mit tiefen Frequenzen Hörschädigungen im mittleren und Hochtonbereich erzeugen.
Weil es da dran vorbeikommen muss zwangsläufig.
So könnte man das interpretieren. Man darf das aber nicht falsch verstehen.
Viele Leute, auch in meinem Fachgebiet bin ich immer wieder mal überrascht.
Viele Leute denken diese Wanderwelle wäre jetzt eine Schwingung,
die unten am Eingang der Kochlea losläuft, noch ganz klein und sich irgendwie
weiter oben dann ausprägt und manifestiert.
So als wie von Zauberhand, das fängt mit Null an und hinten drin ist es auf
einmal ausgeprägt da. Das ist aber eigentlich ein lokales Phänomen von dem Ort,
wo die Schwingungen überhaupt stattfindet. Und dort habe ich in dem Bereich
habe ich dann diese Wanderwelle.
Was ermöglicht denn jetzt diese, also ich meine was ist jetzt das Besondere da dran,
dass da diese Membranen nochmal in so einem Wanderwelligen-Dings,
ich würde mir jetzt erstmal denken, in dem Moment wo sich irgendeine übertragende Frequenz,
die dann durch die Schnecke durchläuft an einer bestimmten Stelle in der Membran
manifestiert, wäre es ja jetzt einfach nur wichtig, dass die Membran da auch
die entsprechende Sensorik hat, das quasi festzustellen.
Ist dadurch, dass er sich so wanderwellig niederschlägt, nochmal irgendwas anderes
möglich, was man so von ihm möglich gehalten hat?
Eines der Schwierigkeiten, die man gerne erschlagen möchte, wenn ich jetzt mal
so als Ingenieur denke, Ingenieur denke, genau.
Wir bauen uns ein Ohr.
Genau. Eine der Schwierigkeiten, die ich gerne lösen möchte,
wäre natürlich, dass ich Spektral sehr scharf auflösen kann.
Dass ich also sehr genau bestimmte Frequenzen heraus hören kann und unterscheiden kann von anderen.
Und wenn ich jetzt mal von diesem anfänglichen, naiven Modell,
dass ich da so eine flabrig schwingende Teppichblase nur habe,
die rauf und runter geht, die ist natürlich überhaupt nicht frequenzspezifisch.
Und da treten jetzt eine ganze Reihe von Mechanismen zusätzlich auf.
Also einerseits, diese Wanderwelle hat auch etwas damit zu tun,
dass ich entlang der Basilarmembran, worauf das stattfindet,
dass ich auch nochmal so eine Oberflächenwellenphänomen habe.
Also ich kann ja auch eine schwingende Welle sozusagen
die die die Membran ist ja mit sich selber und
ihren elementar Elementen der Membran sozusagen mit sich
selber verbunden das heißt also das wird sozusagen weitergeleitet
wieso an der Wasseroberfläche Das ist schon mal ein Mechanismus der da auftaucht
und dann gibt es Jetzt in dem eigentlichen sensorischen Organ da man jetzt noch
gar nicht darüber gesprochen was ja auf der Basilar wenn man drauf sitzt und
diese Schwingungen überhaupt erst mal als Nervenzellen wahrnimmt und aufnimmt und weiterleitet.
Dieses sensorische Organ hat jetzt auch wieder spezielle Eigenschaften,
um eine spektral sehr scharfe Hörwahrnehmung zu ermöglichen.
Und da kommen jetzt eine ganze Reihe von Effekten ins Spiel,
die teilweise auch noch gar nicht wirklich geklärt sind.
Dass also da so Mechanismen stattfinden, dass sich benachbarte Zellen gegenseitig
verstärken oder behindern in ihrer Aktivität.
Das war das, was wir, ich glaube, bevor wir angefangen haben,
gesprochen haben, diese Geschichten mit lateraler Inhibition.
Wenn ich also bestimmte Elemente in...
In einem sensorischen System wahrnehmen will, wie zum Beispiel eine Helligkeitskante,
ein Helligkeitssprung, dass ich mich eigentlich nur für den Sprung und die Kante
interessiere, dann sind in diesem Bereich Nervenzellen miteinander verschaltet,
behindern oder verstärken sich gegenseitig in der Nachbarschaft und können auf
die Art und Weise zum Beispiel eine Helligkeitskante besonders herausarbeiten.
In dem Fall halt eine Frequenzkante. Ganz genau. Die Zellen messen nicht nur
für sich, sondern auch so mit ihren Nachbarn. mal nach, empfängst du noch das
gleiche wie ich? Ne, sehe ich nicht.
Alles klar, dann ist jetzt hier wohl irgendwie genau der Punkt erreicht.
Okay, also um es nochmal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, das Höhen an sich funktioniert,
nachdem eben dieser ganze Luftumwandlung in mechanischer Energie dann wiederum
in Flüssigkeit übertragen wird,
so dass eben die Schockwellen quasi des Steigbügels durch diese doppelte Schnecke gejagt werden,
doppelt weil es halt eine Windung hin und eine Windung zurück gibt,
getrennt durch diese Membran und unterschiedliche Frequenzen übertragen sich
an unterschiedlichen Stellen,
die hohen Frequenzen am Anfang der Schnecke,
die tiefen Frequenzen am Ende der Schnecke und es herrscht jetzt in dieser Membran eine Sensorik,
die in der Lage ist jetzt sehr fein zu trennen, welche Frequenzen in welchem
Maße hier jetzt aufgeschlagen sind, um dann eben quasi über die gesamte Membranstrecke
so eine kombinierte Information ans Gehirn weiterzuleiten.
Das ist im Wesentlichen eigentlich das Hören.
Einfach von mir zusammen gedampft
aber ich treffe das an der
Stelle Jetzt haben wir natürlich
noch keine nerven impulse das war jetzt bisher alles erstmal nur mechanik Ja
genau es ist mich mechanisch genau Aber das ist ja jetzt auch schon mal was
also jeder der jetzt hier zu hört Weiß jetzt zumindest schon mal wie Das ist echt unglaublich.
Wie groß dieser ganze Apparat ist auch wirklich an sich sehr überschaubar.
Also wie groß ist dieses komplette von Trommelfell bis ohne jetzt die Nervenverbindung dahinter.
Also nur so Schnecke, Mittelohr, all das zusammen Innenohr. Das ist ja ganz
komplex. Wie groß muss ich das vorstellen? So groß wie eine Kastanie oder etwas größer?
Ja, also wenn wir den Gehörgang noch mit dazu nehmen, dann haben wir da vielleicht
eine Tiefe insgesamt von da wo es reingeht bis da wo dann die Schnecke ist.
4,5, 5 cm vielleicht. Also das größte davon ist der Gehörgang.
Ja, wenn man den jetzt mal wegnimmt. Ich meine jetzt nur sozusagen dieses reine
Schallumwandlungssystem.
Die Hörschnecke selber, das passt in Kubikzentimeter. Das ist,
also dann kommt noch natürlich das Mittelorder hinzu. Wenn man nochmal ein Kubikzentimeter,
eher ein bisschen weniger.
Ist also alles schon ganz schön klein.
So, was muss man jetzt noch zur Kenntnis nehmen?
Das, worüber wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, auch beim Gleichgewichtsorgan
noch nicht, ist eigentlich welche Nervenzellen machen das denn überhaupt?
Wir haben ja immer so ein bisschen um den heißen Brei bisher rum geredet.
Wir haben ein Sensorium, wir haben Nervenzellen, die dann Schwingungen oder
Bewegungen in Flüssigkeit aufnehmen. Aber wie die das genau machen,
haben wir bisher noch gar kein Wort darüber verloren.
Und das sind halt Nervenzellen, die mechanische Rezeptoren sind.
Nervenzellen, die in der Lage sind, Nervenimpulse abzugeben auf mechanischen äußeren Reiz hin.
Und das ging schon unheimlich früh los in in der Evolution.
Das geht, glaube ich, sogar noch vor das Cambrium zurück,
also bevor überhaupt Skelette da waren,
dass man Lagesensoren brauchte,
zum Beispiel in Qualen ist das noch so, braucht Lagesensoren,
Gleichgewichtorgan könnte man dann sagen, bei den Fischen war das vergleichsweise
schon unheimlich ausgeprägt und die Natur hat dann so Blasen konstruiert,
in die hinein Nervenzellen reinragten und in diesen Blasen war zum Beispiel
ein Steinchen drin und das Steinchen das hat immer diese diese mechanischen
Rezeptorzellen berührt und dann wusste das Tier immer was immer das war.
Wo unten ist. Wo unten ist.
Es gibt teilweise gibt es ganz ganz lustige solche Konstruktionen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel Krebse bei denen ist das eine offene Blase nach außen offen
und Wenn diese Krebse sich häuten, dann ist das Steinchen, das da drin ist, verloren.
Und die müssen sich selber mit ihren Scheren wieder ein Steinchen reintun.
Und wenn die das nicht finden, dann sind sie orientierungslos.
Ja, was wirklich lustig ist, man kann die Viecher jetzt einfangen und man gibt
denen halt keinen Sand, sondern man gibt denen ausschließlich Eisenspäne.
Dann tun sie sich so einen Eisenspahn da rein und dann kann man die auf einmal
mit Magneten fernsteuern.
Also die tun sich da wirklich Sandkörner rein?
Ja, richtig. In ihr Lager.
Danach wächst das dann zu oder was?
Nö, das ist immer offen. Das ist immer offen. Also so offen,
dass das nicht ohne weiteres wieder rausgespült wird.
Aber das sind sozusagen von außen zugängliche Blase, die innen ausgekleidet
ist mit Mechanorezeptoren.
Und da wird halt ein Steinchen rein praktiziert.
Weißt du, wie diese Krebsart heißt?
Nee, vielleicht kriegen wir das nachrecherchieren. Kriegen wir schon irgendwie raus.
Und zu diesen frühen Zeitpunkten, also wie gesagt, das gibt es bei Qualen, gibt es das auch immer.
Die müssen jetzt kein Steinchen da rein praktizieren, das ist irgendwas,
was der Körper dann selber bildet.
Aber die haben auch so Bläschen, die nach innen gerichtete mechanische Rezeptorzellen
haben. Da ist dann irgendein Gewicht drin und das berührt dann sozusagen immer
an der Unterseite. Und dann wissen die, wie die orientiert sind.
Es gibt sogar das Umgekehrte. Es gibt sogar, bei irgendeinem Wasserskorpion
ist das glaube ich, da ist das kein Steinchen, sondern ein Luftbläschen.
Also genau umgekehrt. Die Luftblase drückt immer nach oben und dann haben die
mit Hilfe dieser Luftblase einen Lagesensor konstruiert.
Pfliffig.
Also das ist schon toll, was da alles passiert. So, jetzt müssen wir aber mal
zu dem eigentlichen mechanischen Rezeptor kommen.
Das ist eine spezialisierte Nervenzelle und eine Nervenzelle ist ja jetzt etwas,
was ein erregbare Zelle, die da also durch z.B.
Temperatur, mechanische Einwirkung, olfaktorische Einwirkung,
durch Einwirkung von Nachbarzellen, die irgendwelche Brotenstoffe heranschicken
über synaptische Verbindungen, die dazu gebracht werden kann.
Einen elektrischen Puls abzugeben, ein Aktionspotenzial.
Und diese Nervenzellen, die müssen natürlich gegenüber der Außenwelt selber
innen drin erstmal ein Potenzial aufbauen.
Also diese Nervenzellen haben dann Proteine in den Zellwänden sitzen,
die schaffen es, Kalium reinzupumpen und im Innenraum der Zelle eine höhere
Kaliumkonzentration als in der Außenwelt zu haben.
Und die sind sozusagen vorgespannt elektrisch, könnte man sagen.
Kostet natürlich ein bisschen chemische Energie, das aufzubauen. Ist ja nicht kostenlos.
Und wenn dann irgendein Reiz, für den die Zelle spezialisiert ist,
des Weges kommt, dann schicken die einen elektrischen Impuls ab.
Bei moderneren Nervenzellen läuft dann dieser Puls entlang des Axons und läuft
irgendwo hin und stimuliert dort wiederum eine andere Nervenzelle.
Und diese mechanischen Rezeptorzellen, diese jetzt Bewegungssensoren,
das sind Nervenzellen, die es auch schon in diesen frühesten Formen gegeben hat.
Also wie gesagt, diese statuolitischen Bläschen da, wo die innen drin saßen
oder das gibt es bei den Fischen zum Beispiel um Wasserbewegungen an der Außenhaut wahrzunehmen.
Die haben also unter den Schuppen, mit so kleinen Kanälen noch nach außen offen,
haben die auch solche Rezeptorzellen, mit denen die ganz feine Wasserbewegungen wahrnehmen können.
Wasserströmungen wahrnehmen können. Und bei den Fischen ist das eben im Gleichgewichtsorgan
dann auch aufgetaucht, dass sie solche mechanischen Rezeptorzellen benutzt haben,
um diese Gleichgewichtswahrnehmung zu machen. Und das sieht jetzt so aus,
dass eine solche spezialisierte Nervenzelle...
So konstruiert ist, dass es sich intern ein elektrisches Potential aufbaut und
aufrecht erhält. Und wenn jetzt ein entsprechender Reiz kommt,
wird ein Aktionspotential abgegeben.
Und bei diesen sogenannten H-Zellen, das sind die,
die eben diese mechanischen Rezeptoren haben, die haben oben auf dem Dach der Nervenzelle,
muss man sich sowieso ein zylinderartiges Ding vorstellen, wo oben die Nervenzelle
mit so einem Deckelchen abgeschlossen ist und oben aus diesem Deckelchen raus
wachsen kleine Röhrchen.
Das sind die sogenannten Stereozilien oder auch Kinozilien, je nachdem wofür die spezialisiert ist.
Und diese kleinen Röhrchen sind normalerweise geschlossen, haben aber kleine Deckelchen.
Das ist jetzt wirklich absolut im mikroskopischen Zustand. Also wir sind da
schon auf der Größenordnung von großen Eiweißmolekülen. So klein ist das alles schon.
Und diese aus der Zelle herausragenden Stereozylien oder Kinozylien, Die-
machen dadurch, dass die jetzt verbogen werden,
wenn durch einen mechanischen Reiz, durch eine Flüssigkeitsströmung oder durch
eine direkte Berührung diese herausragenden,
aus der Zelle herausragenden Röhrchen verbogen werden, dann gehen so kleine
Deckelchen auf, die einen kurzfristigen Flüssigkeitsaustausch mit der Außenwelt ermöglichen.
Dadurch ändert sich die Ionenkonzentration zwischen Innen- und Außenwelt und das führt dann dazu,
wenn das ausreichend lange offen
ist und wir reden hier also wirklich im Mikrosekundenbereich natürlich,
wenn das ausreichend lange offen ist und genügend Austausch stattfinden kann,
dann depolarisiert die Zelle, dann klappt die sozusagen kurzfristig in einen
völlig anderen Zustand, sendet ein Aktionspotential aus, einen Puls entlang
des Axons und hat somit weiter gemeldet hier ich wurde bewegt.
Feuert los.
Ich wurde berührt. Feuert los. Und solche Zellen, die nennen wir,
wenn sie bei uns im Innenohr sitzen, nennen wir Haarzellen.
Und das hat jetzt überhaupt nichts mit Haaren zu tun und und Follikeln und was
weiß ich, sondern die heißen deswegen so, weil die eben diese dünnen kleinen
Röhrchen, diese Härchen oben drauf sitzen haben, die auf mechanische Verbiegung reagieren.
Und solche Zellen sitzen jetzt in einem Verbund mit anderen Zellen auf der Basilarmembran drauf.
Das waren diese Trennmembran in der Schnecke, die diese obere und untere Hälfte
des Schneckengang- Durchmessers einer Windung voneinander getrennt haben.
Und da sitzen jetzt eine ganze Reihe von solchen Haarzellen drauf.
Und zwar im Querschnitt gesehen, wenn man also von der Mittelachse der Schnecke
nach außen durchschneidet und sich das im Querschnitt anguckt.
Sehen wir vier solche Zellen.
Eine Zelle die innerste, das ist eine ist die innere Haarzelle.
Natürlich gibt es davon tausende entlang der Schneckenwindung,
aber im Querschnitt sehen wir jetzt erstmal nur eine. Und wir sehen drei äußere Haarzellen.
Und die pflanzen sich in die Tiefe der Schnecke entlang der Windung entsprechend
fort. Das heißt, wir haben sozusagen wie so ein ganzes Band von solchen Haarzellen.
Wenn man das elektronenmikroskopisch anguckt und obendrauf guckt,
dann sieht das aus wie so Grasbüschel, die aus einer Fläche herausschauen.
Und diese Fläche ist die Oberfläche des kortischen Organs.
Kortisch Organ heißt dieses Ganze, was auf der Baselameinbran drauf sitzt,
weil das ein Herr Korty im 19. Jahrhundert mal mit damals den besten Mikroskopen sich angeschaut hat.
Und diese Härchen, die dann aus dieser Fläche herausragen, die sehen wie gesagt
so ein bisschen grasbüschelmäßig aus und die von den Inneren,
die sehen aus wie so eine kleine Zeile, vielleicht so ein bisschen verbogen
und die von den Äußeren, die sehen aus wie sie sind so v-förmig angeordnet.
In der Spitze unten vom Pfarr vielleicht eingeknickt, dass das eigentlich eher
so ein kleines W ist, aber die sind auf diese Art und Weise dann auf der Basilarmembran angeordnet.
Ja.
So, die Basilarmembran hatten wir ja vorhin gesagt.
Eine Frage habe ich. Ja. Ich hatte mit sowas schon gerechnet,
du hast gesagt, da sind jetzt so Tausende.
Wie viele Tausende? Also Zehntausende, Hunderttausende? Also wie viele?
Zwischen drei und viertausend ungefähr.
Dreitausend, viertausend. Im Prinzip mein einfaches Gehirn sagt jetzt viertausend
Härchen entlang dieser Membran bedeutet man kann so viertausend verschiedene
Frequenzen unterscheiden.
Nee, ist natürlich wie immer viel, viel komplizierter. Also erstens mal besteht der Hörnerv selber.
Der Hörnerv sind jetzt alles Axone, gebündelte Axone von Nervenzellen,
aber nicht von diesen H-Zellen.
Axone war jetzt nochmal was?
Axon ist dieser lange Ausläufer einer Nervenzelle entlang dem,
das Aktionspotenzial läuft.
Wenn man den Hörnerv anschaut, dann haben wir da ungefähr 30.000 Axone drin.
Das heißt also da ist schon sozusagen mehr Informationsmöglichkeit zu drin zu
kodieren, als wir Anzahl an H-Zellen auf der Basilarmembran haben.
Und dann gibt es auch was, was man auch noch nicht so wahnsinnig lange weiß.
Wenn man sich anschaut, in welche Richtung diese Wirkung der Verschaltungen
ist, dann gibt es Axone, die Informationen vom Innenohr Richtung Hirn stammen, leiten.
Und es gibt aber auch die umgekehrte Richtung. Es gibt aber auch Axone,
die sozusagen in andere Richtungen laufen im Bereich der Kochlehr.
Eine Rückmeldung.
Es gibt eine Rückmeldung.
Das Hirn kann dem Hörnerven sagen, Informationen geben.
Ganz so weit rauf würde ich nicht gehen. Das findet also eher lokal statt.
Aber man hat das eben mal genauer untersucht und man hat mal festgestellt,
dass die äußeren Haarzellen,
viel mehr Information bekommen, als sie wegschicken.
Das ist mehr so eine Parametrisierung.
Die inneren Haarzellen, da ist das etwas zugunsten der Afferenten.
Also Afferenten sind die, die hinaufgehen.
Afferenten sind die, die herunterkommen. Vom Gehirn heißt das immer.
Afferent ist immer was, was von der Peripherie zum Gehirn läuft.
Und Afferent, was in die umgekehrte Richtung läuft.
Jetzt kann man klassifizieren, wie viel Afferente gibt es, wie viel Afferente
gibt es. Dann stellt man fest, dass man bei den inneren Haarzellen in der Mehrzahl
afferente, das heißt, die liefern eher Informationen, als dass sie bekommen.
Die äußeren Haarzellen, die wären weit, weit überwiegend afferent in der Welt.
Die kriegen viel mehr Informationen, als sie selber liefern,
können aber auch ein bisschen was liefern.
Und dann hat man irgendwann festgestellt, als man diese Haarzellen mal rauspräpariert
hat, äußere Haarzellen hat man mal eben im Labor präpariert,
dann hat man festgestellt, die sich minimal in der Größe ändern können,
wenn sie Information kriegen.
Also die äußeren Hartzellen, die können sich so ein bisschen kontrahieren.
Das heißt also, die dienen nicht nur als mechanische Rezeptoren und empfangen
irgendwas, sondern die können offensichtlich auch sich kalibrieren,
ein bisschen Information, mechanische Information abgeben.
Die können also ein bisschen was tun sozusagen.
Und das wird offensichtlich von dem System in der Basilarmembran genutzt,
um einerseits noch mal zu verstärken und andererseits um noch Spektralen noch
mal besonders scharf auflösen zu können.
Das hat man dann natürlich vor langer Zeit hat man das mal versucht,
natürlich im Tierversuch gemacht worden, hat man gesagt, ja was passiert denn eigentlich,
wenn wir die einen ausschalten, was passiert denn eigentlich,
wenn wir jetzt die äußeren Haarzellen mal kaputt machen,
deaktivieren durch irgendeine vergiftende Droge, einen orthotoxischen,
also ohrgiftigen Stoff, kann man gezielt die äußeren Haarzellen oder auch die
inneren Haarzellen deaktivieren.
Also man testet sozusagen, was verändert sich am Gesamts funktion,
wenn man mal ein Ding rauslässt.
Man hat vorher schon gewusst, dass
die Frequenzauflösungsfähigkeit des Ors unglaublich gut ist, indem man...
Ganz ultra feine Elektroden in den Hörnerv gestochen hat, sodass man ein einzelnes
Axon kontaktiert hat im lebenden Exemplar natürlich.
Jetzt hat man also die Aktivität einer einzelnen Nervenzelle beobachtet.
Im lebenden Exemplar eines...
Eines Tieres, eines Tieres natürlich. Ich weiß nicht womit das da ist.
Es ist schon ewig her als das gemacht wurde, keine Ahnung. Vor 30 Jahren.
Und ich glaube es ist an Katzen gemacht worden, aber beschweren möchte ich das
nicht. Also man hat jedenfalls eine feine Nadel in ein Axon des Hörnervs eingestochen,
kann also jetzt die Aktivität einer einzelnen Nervenzelle beobachten.
Wohlgemerkt, das sind nicht die Haarzellen auf der Basilarmembran,
sondern in der Mitte der Schnecke, so im Stamm der Schnecke drin,
sitzen auch nochmal sehr sehr viele, das sind die Ganglehenzellen,
das sind die eigentlichen, die den Hörnerv dann bilden durch ihre Axone.
Und wenn man jetzt also ein Schallsignal von außen drauf gegeben hat und beobachtet hat,
wann wird dieses Neuron aktiv, dann hat man festgestellt, dass ein einzelnes
Neuron unglaublich scharf auf eine Frequenz gestimmt ist.
Man kann also jetzt mit einem Signalgenerator, kann man jetzt verschiedene Frequenzen
durchfahren und man kann jetzt bei tiefen Frequenzen, zu hohen Frequenzen so
einen Sweep durchfahren und man beobachtet immer, wann ist denn der Nerv aktiv
und kann gucken und dann gibt es...
Wie ist denn da die Auflösung? Also wenn so ein Axon so auf eine bestimmte Frequenz
reagiert, wie ist ja die Bandbreite?
Ja, so genau kann man das insofern nicht sagen, als dass dieser Nerv natürlich
auch auf alle anderen Frequenzen ein bisschen reagiert, aber in extrem steil abnehmendem Maß. Ja.
Ich sehe also, wenn ich… Aber genau dadurch kann man ja die Bandbreite gut messen.
Also wenn man da jetzt so durchswiebt durch die Frequenzen, dann wird es ja
irgendeine erste Frequenz geben, wo das Ding überhaupt reagiert.
Das geht unter Umständen schon ganz tief los, dass man so ganz wenig so spontane Aktivität,
tröpfelsweise Aktivität des Nervs beobachtet und wenn ich mich dann immer mehr ran bewege,
wird es immer fetter, dann wird das eigentlich muss man es umgekehrt machen,
man muss gucken, man muss auch noch den Pegel so ändern,
wie viel Pegel brauche ich, um das dann zu erreichen und dann stellt man fest,
dass man für das Axon, was jetzt für eine bestimmte oder für die Frequenz,
die man jetzt gerade erwischt hat, sage ich, dass man ein bestimmtes Axon erwischt
hat, braucht man bei dieser Frequenz unheimlich wenig Pegel um trotzdem.
Eine Aktivität zu sehen. Und sobald ich dann nur um wenige Hertz seitlich davon
wegfahre, brauche ich wesentlich mehr Pegel, um überhaupt wieder Aktivität zu sehen.
Das ist also, wenn ich in die Höhe aufzeichne,
wie viel Pegel brauche ich, um Aktivität zu sehen und auf der X-Achse aufzeichne,
bei welcher Frequenz mache ich das, dann habe ich so eine ganz scharfe,
scharfe spitze das sind die sogenannten tuning oder
abstimm abstimmungs kurven also wenn
man das gucken würde tuning curves würde man das finden und das ist weil das
so unglaublich scharf auf eine bestimmte frequenz anspringt ein bestimmtes neuron
ist das eben auch interessant gewesen ja wie kann das überhaupt sein wir waren
ja vorhin bei dieser schwingenden teppichblase das wäre damit wäre das gar nicht erklärbar.
Und wenn man aber jetzt diese Situation hat und in dieser total scharf abgestimmten
Situation auf eine bestimmte Frequenz die äußeren Haarzellen kaputt macht,
indem man die durch Einbringen von irgendwelchen orthotoxischen Substanzen in
die Kochlea gezielt ausschaltet, dann geht auf einmal diese Schärfe total verloren.
Dann wird das auf einmal viel Frequenz stumpfer.
Ganz genau.
Und das ist halt dann der Anlass gewesen, die Annahme zu machen,
dass die äußeren Haarzellen dadurch, dass sie selber Information kriegen,
dass sie selber mechanisch aktiv werden, dass die dazu beitragen durch entsprechende
Komplexe und ich glaube,
das ist bis heute nicht völlig aufgedröselt, was da im Detail wirklich abläuft,
dass man also einerseits nochmal sehr schwache Signale verstärkt in der Kochlehr dadurch,
dass man diese Zusatzschwingaktivität der äußeren Haarzellen hat und andererseits
zusätzlich diese spektrale Schärfung erreicht, dadurch dass man sagt,
oh hier, was hört ihr denn, so wie wir es vorhin hatten, Was hört ihr denn gerade?
Und ich feuer jetzt mal genau asynchron dagegen, damit wir da diese Störfrequenz,
die eigentlich nicht die ist, die wir haben wollen, an der Stelle sozusagen abdämpfen.
Ich würde das so als eine automatische Kalibration verstehen oder zumindest
auf so eine adaptive Wahrnehmung, die auch noch funktioniert, Marc.
Ja, da muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, weil in der realen Welt kommen
ja nicht nur Sinustöne vor.
Wenn man das mit einem Sinus-Ton, also mit einer monochromatischen,
können wir sagen, Frequenz, also nur eine einzige Frequenz untersucht,
dann kann man diese ganzen Eigenschaften haarklein rausholen.
Aber in der realen Welt hat man ja immer ein spektrales Gemisch aus vielen,
vielen Dingen, die gleichzeitig stattfinden. Und da geht es dann vielleicht eher darum, nicht...
Die eine Frequenz, die man jetzt gerade hat, möglichst genau festzustellen,
sondern sie möglichst von vielen anderen konkurrierenden Benachbarten gut unterscheiden zu können.
Solche Dinge sind dann vielleicht wichtiger. Also zum Beispiel die harmonische
Struktur von einem komplexen Signalgut aufdröseln zu können.
Das ist dann unter Umständen der eigentliche Grund, warum das sich so gebildet hat.
Ich lasse das mit der Kalibration mal raus, weil das immer irgendwie impliziert.
Man hätte jetzt irgendwie so ein Testsignal oder ein Referenzsignal,
auf das man sich dann einfuchst. Das meinte ich jetzt auch gar nicht sein.
Adaptiv vielleicht in dem Sinne, dass einfach dieses Ohr kann sich auf Basis
von was auch immer das ist,
auf die Situation einstellen und damit einfach die gesamte Messschärfe,
die sich aus der Wahrnehmung dieser inneren Haarzellen,
dieser primären Wahnnehmer einstellen, indem sich die korrelierenden äußeren
Haarzellen dann in Länge und was weiß ich,
welchen Eigenschaften noch entsprechend anpasst und am Ende,
da wo das zusammen läuft, dass also die Nervenzellen, wie hießen die jetzt nochmal,
die letztlich den Hörnerv dann ausmachen kann, hast du es glaube ich genannt.
Das sind die Ganglienzellen oder Spiralganglienzellen, weil die sitzen dann sozusagen nicht mehr.
Also die sammeln quasi diese Information und deren Ausgabe,
deren Axone, das ist das, was letzten Endes gebündelt zum Gehirn geleitet wird
und gesagt wird, Das ist das, was wir jetzt hier gerade sehen.
Mach was draus. So kann man das sagen.
Ja, ich glaube, ab dort kommen wir dann auch schon in ein anderes Thema, oder?
Also ich meine, sich jetzt hier über die Wahrnehmung und Auswertung des Hirns,
diese Information zu beschäftigen,
ich hatte ja auch schon mal eine Sendung zum Thema Hirn, ich muss sagen, das war wirklich,
glaube ich, der CAA, der mich am meisten zerpflückt hat, weil ich da einfach,
also da bin ich dann auch einfach nicht mehr, also da reicht einfach meine intellektuelle
Kapazität irgendwie nicht mehr aus oder vielleicht habe ich auch nur irgendwas
verstanden, aber das ist einfach nochmal anderer Komplexitätsgrad.
Ich würde es jetzt an der Stelle erstmal darauf beschränken,
du hast noch eine wichtige Anmerkung.
Ich hätte insofern noch eine wichtige Anmerkung als dass die landläufige Vorstellung
ist ja immer, das geht einfach nur von außen nach innen.
Da wird einfach nur von außen was angenommen, irgendwie vorverarbeitet,
vielleicht ein bisschen Spektral geschaffen, dann wird das so zack,
zack, zack, weitergeleitet.
Aber das geht schon über die, also es geht über die gesamte Hörbahn von der
Kochlehrer bis ganz rauf, sind immer wieder rauf-runter Kommunikation permanent.
Also im Verlauf des Hörnervs.
Im Verlauf, im Verlauf des, der Hörnerv, der endet ja jetzt erst mal an der
Eintrittsstelle im Hirnstamm. Da haben wir jetzt die erste Vorverschaltung,
da ist dann das nächste Neuron in der Kette.
Also das erste waren die Spiralganglehenzellen, deren Axone sind der Hörnerv,
die münden in den Hirnstamm ein. Da ist dann die nächste Schaltstelle,
die kriegen dann die Axone per synaptischer Verschaltung. Die machen dann was
drauf, die leiten das wiederum weiter, kommunizieren miteinander.
Die nächste Ebene tut das auch und zwar jetzt auch gegenseitig von einer auf die andere Seite.
Da finden dann so diese Auflösungsrichtungshörwahrnehmungsvorverarbeitungsschritte schon statt.
Aber das, was daran so interessant ist, ist, dass nicht nur draußen in der Peripherie,
die alle schon vorwärts, rückwärts miteinander sprechen und solche Dinge wie
diese spektrale Schärfung durch die äußeren Haarzellen machen und sozusagen
schon immer rückmelden,
was habt ihr denn von oben und ich mache deswegen aber ein bisschen was anderes,
sondern das zieht sich über mehrere Stufen hinweg, dass es immer wieder rauf
und runter geht und und zwar sogar bis hoch in, sagen wir mal so peripherere Hörerwartungen.
Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel solche Dinge hat wie ein repetitives Signal,
irgendwas was immer klick klick klick klick klick macht, ein relativ primitives
Signal und dann kommt auf einmal was anderes. Klack.
So was. Kann man auch beliebig komplex konstruieren. Dann ist es offensichtlich,
dass von oben herunter erkannt wird, das ist was repetitives.
Und dann wird sozusagen schon in die Peripherie weitergeleitet eine Voraussage, wie das jetzt kommt.
Und dadurch, dass auf einmal ein Widerspruch auftritt, reagiert das System auf einmal ganz anders.
Das kann man sogar messen, indem man mit EEG-Ableitungen entsprechende Experimente macht,
dass man sozusagen ganz vergleichsweise kleine Signale bekommt,
wenn das System erst mal ein paar Mal eine Repetition desselben gehört hat und
erst dann, wenn was anderes kommt, kriegt man auf einmal einen ganz großen Ausschlag,
eine ganz große Reaktion auf das jetzt rausfallende.
Das ist aber jetzt bestimmt nichts, was jetzt nur beim Hören der Fall ist,
sondern das wird sich wahrscheinlich auch in ähnlicher Form beim Sehen, Fühlen etc.
Auch feststellen lassen. Und um das jetzt vielleicht nicht allzu weit auszubreiten,
aber es ist unter Umständen auch an diesen Rückkopplungsschleifen,
die da existieren, dass von oben Informationen reingeschaltet wird,
weil von oben irgendeine Erwartung oder Vorberechnung erfolgt ist und von unten
dann immer sozusagen die reale Information nachkommt, die das wieder beeinflusst.
Es ist auch denkbar, dass solche Dinge wie Tinnitus zum Beispiel ein bisschen
außer Ruder laufen, diese Rückkopplungsschleifen sind.
Also falsche Erwartungshaltung sozusagen.
Solche Dinge oder dass auf einmal aus irgendwelchen Gründen von unten die Information
nicht mehr kommt, aber die Rückkopplungsschleife oben eigentlich noch gerne
was machen würde, aber nicht mehr zum Korrigieren oder zum Erwarten hat,
an dem sie arbeiten kann.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen sehr weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, aber diese,
damit können wir das an der Stelle aber abschließen, Diese vergleichsweise naive
Vorstellung, dass da einfach nur wie ein Kabel von unten nach oben wird,
das einfach weitergeleitet und am oben sitzt ein kleines Männchen mit dem Ohr
und das hört dann, das ist völliger Quatsch.
Also da sind ständig immer schon irgendwelche Vorverarbeitungsschritte auf allen
Ebenen, die ablaufen und die bis heute noch bei weitem nicht vollständig verstanden sind.
Puh, ganz schön was los für das bisschen Hören. Aber es ist spannend.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich hier die ganze Zeit von einem idealen Menschen gesprochen,
bei dem irgendwie immer alles super funktioniert, abgesehen jetzt von den den
unterschieden Einzelner.
Ja, es gibt halt Leute, die können besser hören, können schlechter hören, keine Ahnung.
Geht ja auch mal was schief, geht ja auch mal was kaputt. Was ist denn so überhaupt
der anfälligste Bereich?
Über Trommelfeldproblematiken haben wir ja schon gesprochen,
hast ja gesagt, das ist so täglich Brot in der HNO-Klinik.
Ist denn alles andere relativ stabil?
Ne, also das Empfindlichste ist das, worüber wir gerade gesprochen haben,
nämlich das kautische Organ mit den Haarzellen.
Die Schnecke.
Die Schnecke, genauer gesagt, also das sensorische System, was auf der Basilarmembran drauf sitzt.
Das hat ja grundsätzlich mal die Schwierigkeit, wenn man wenn man das schön
fein und empfindlich bauen will,
dann kann man da nicht so eine dicke Ader hin flanschen, die das alles immer
schön stabil mit Nährstoffen und allem möglichen versorgt und mit Sauerstoff und so weiter,
sondern das wird natürlich immer immer fein zisselierter, bis es am Ende eigentlich
praktisch nur noch über Diffusionen zu einer Nährstoffversorgung geht.
Und in der Kochlehr drin haben wir selber eigentlich nur noch ein paar wenige
Kapillaren, die das gotische Organ mit Blut und Nährstoffen versorgen.
Das ist der empfindlichste Teil.
Und das ist auch der Teil, wo es zum Beispiel durch Schalltrauma,
also zu hohe Lautstärke, zu Schädigungen kommen kann. Ganz primitiv,
mechanisch werden bei diesen Haarzellen einfach die Härchen abgeknickt.
Manchmal regeneriert sich das wieder und ist dann wieder so gut wie vorher.
Aber manchmal bleiben diese Schädigungen auch permanent, was dann wiederum dazu
führt, dass die Haarzellen abgebaut werden oder einfach ihre mechanische Rezeptorfunktion
nicht mehr wahrnehmen können.
Und die Gründe, die jetzt, wenn man mal pauschal sagt,
wer hat Hörverlust und auf welche Ursache ist der Hörverlust zurückzuführen,
dann wird einem mehr oder weniger jeder sagen, naja, so 80, 90 Prozent aller
Hörverluste ist im Innenort zu suchen, ist auf der Basilarmembran der Schnecke zu suchen.
Dass wir da Haarzellen haben, die einfach nicht mehr das tun,
was sie ursprünglich mal getan haben.
Natürlich genetische Defekte, das ist noch mal was anderes. Also Missbildungen gibt es natürlich auch.
Erbliche Taubheit gibt es auch. Und dann haben natürlich noch die Sachen, die...
Im Mittelohr ablaufen können, wenn wir also im Mittelohr dauerhaft irgendwelche
Entzündungen haben und sich das nicht so richtig in den Griff kriegen lässt,
dann kann das auch dazu führen, dass die
Gehörknöchelchen in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden oder dass der der Knochenbildungshaushalt
da so ein bisschen außer Kontrolle gerät und dass wir dort eine Verknöcherung
haben Und dass sich die Gehörknöchlichen zum Beispiel festwachsen und nicht mehr beweglich sind.
Also das kann schon mal sein, dass die Fußplatte vom Stapes einfach mit dem
umgebenden Knochenrand nach einer Infektion anfängt zu verwachsen.
Und einfach mechanisch die...
Stapes ist der Steigbügel.
Stapes ist der Steigbügel, Entschuldigung. Ja.
Damit einfach nur eine mechanische Problematik da ist.
Und das ist auch das, was an den Kliniken bei den Leuten, die sich damit medizinisch
beschäftigen, immer die große Trennlinie ist.
Ist das etwas, was mechanisch durch noch auf dem akustisch-mechanischen Wege
passiert ist? Also haben wir eine Mittelohrproblematik oder haben wir einen
Einriss des Trommelfells?
Ist das Trommelfell unter Umständen komplett zerstört und kann gar nicht mehr rekonstruiert werden?
Das ist eben die Sache, wo es um die Schallweiterleitung geht.
Das ist etwas, was man manchmal noch ganz gut in den Griff kriegt.
Also durch eine entsprechende Operation. Man kann zum Beispiel die Gehörknöchlichen
durch kleine Prothesen ersetzen.
Es gibt so kleine Titanengehörknöchlichen, um das mal so salopp zu formulieren.
Die dann den Hammer und Ambus ersetzen?
Ja, je nachdem was genau los ist, kann man zum Beispiel, es kann zum Beispiel
sein, dass nur der Steigbügel hinüber ist.
Und dass man also eine Art kleinen Ersatzsteigbügel aufsetzt,
wenn Hammer und Ambus noch da sind, oder dass man im extremen Gegenfall das
Trommelfell und alle Gehörknöchlichen weg sind, komplett alles kaputt ist und
das dann das natürlich chirurgisch entsprechend aufwendig. Da muss man natürlich Leute haben.
Ich staune gerade, dass das überhaupt geht. Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt auch
kein besonders gut zugänglicher Bereich da.
Da muss schon eine Operation, weiß nicht wie viel man da rum schnippeln muss.
Ja, man muss schon was tun. Man muss natürlich auch darauf aufpassen,
dass man nichts anderes kaputt macht.
Also es gibt gerade da in der Gegend gibt es zwei Nerven, die laufen da vorm Mittelohr entlang bzw.
Einer läuft sogar wirklich durchs Mittelohr durch, zwischen den Gehörknöchlichen
durch und das ist der Nerv,
der die Zungenspitze innerviert und ein Teil des Geschmacksinnens macht,
das die Corda tympani nennt sich der Nerv.
Darf man auch nicht gerade mal reintreten?
Darf man? Nee, sonst ist... Also das ist noch nicht ganz so schlimm,
weil die Zunge nicht nur von dem und man hat ja noch die andere Hälfte.
Ja, aber ich sehe schon, das ist so. Also nicht so schön.
Ja, was richtig doof ist, ist der faciales Nerv. Das ist der,
der die Gesichtsmuskulatur ansteuert.
Und wenn der mal so richtig betroffen ist, dann haben die Leute unter Umständen
auf einer Seite gar keine Mimik mehr oder kriegen ihr Auge nicht mehr zu oder
solche schrecklichen Mimik.
Wie man das auch so bei Lähmung durch, sag ich schon, hier durch Hirnschlag auch mal abkennen kann.
Ja. natürlich der Chirurg, der sowas macht, muss dann natürlich sich enorm auskennen.
Zum Glück haben wir hier in dem Land wirklich ein ziemlich hohes Niveau,
aber das ist natürlich richtige Fitzelarbeit.
Na aber schon erstaunlich. Das zeigt ja zumindest, dass es auch alles soweit schon verstanden ist,
wenn man solche Techniken umsetzen kann, dass das jetzt hier auch alles gar
kein Voodoo mehr ist, sondern dass man eigentlich genau weiß,
wie es eigentlich zu funktionieren hat und dann auch die Möglichkeiten hat, entgegenzuarbeiten.
Jetzt arbeitest du ja an Hörgeräten insbesondere.
Vielleicht kannst du nochmal deine eigentliche Aufgaben, Schwerpunkte nochmal
kurz zusammenfassen, weil wir hatten so am Anfang alles Mögliche angesprochen.
Also angefangen in dieses Fachgebiet reingekommen bin ich als Entwicklungsingenieur
und ich habe von einem damals neu entwickelten Cochlea Implantatsystem habe
ich die Signalverarbeitung programmiert.
Also das war noch mit einem richtigen DSP, einem richtigen Digital Signal Processor,
der hat dann eben das, was die Schnecke nicht mehr konnte, sozusagen digital berechnet.
Und den habe ich damals programmiert und ich bin dann aber,
also war Entwicklungsingenieur in dem Bereich, und bin dann so nach und nach
eher in die Forschungsrichtung rübergedriftet und habe dann parametrische Hörexperimente
mit vielen Patienten mit solchen Implantatsystemen gemacht und bin jetzt inzwischen
seit einigen Jahren an einer Klinik als,
wie man das so schön nennt, als Audiologe, also jemand,
der sich um einerseits natürlich die Forschung in diesem Bereich kümmert und
andererseits aber auch mit Patienten zu tun hat,
die solche Implantatsysteme erhalten und die natürlich eine hohe Notwendigkeit
haben, dass diese Implantatsysteme individuell auf die Patienten eingestellt
und angepasst werden müssen.
Und das ist jetzt mein heutiger oder derzeitiger Hauptarbeitsbereich.
Das heißt, du mit den klassischen Hörgeräten in dem Sinne hast du so nichts
zu tun und auch nichts zu tun gehabt.
Hatte ich bisher nichts zu tun. Aber vielleicht kommen wir da noch... Du kennst das ja,
das klassische Hörgerät, also wenn man jetzt schwer hört, das klassische Schwerhörige,
nimmt dann ein Hörgerät, da geht es dann erstmal um die reine Verstärkung.
Da geht es einfach erstmal nur um eine Schallwellenverstärkung.
Da liegt dann in der Regel eine Schwächung von was vor, also ist es dann das
Trommelfell, was sich nicht mehr so gut bewegt oder ist es so die Mechanik,
die ein bisschen eingerostet ist?
Ja, es ist eigentlich eine große Anzahl an Patienten, die ein Hörgerät brauchen,
sind natürlich ältere Leute und die hören von den hohen Frequenzen herkommen,
schlechter und schlechter.
Und da gehen dann so zwei Sachen Hand in Hand.
Einerseits so ein langsames Abbauen oder kaputt gehen, der...
Nerven der Haarzellen in dem hochfrequenten Bereich
und andererseits gibt es aber wohl auch eine
altersbedingte langsam Graduell zunehmende
Versteifung der Basilarmembran also die wird nach und
nach immer weniger gut schwingfähig und
beweglich Und das ist dann eben die Presbyakusis
die sogenannte Altersschwerhörigkeit und die kommt meistens von den hohen Frequenzen
her beginnend und Die Leute haben dann manchmal so eine ganz widersprüchliche
angabe die denken sie hören ja noch alles weil sie die tür noch Zufallen hören
genauso gut wie früher aber das ist halt ein tief frequent des plumpes oder
irgendwie den nachbarn hören sie auch noch weil der rumpelt Ein,
bisschen rum die tiefen frequenzen gehen dann noch aber sobald
es dann um sprache verstehen angeht wo man Die höheren
mittleren und höheren frequenzen zwingend braucht um das auflösen
zu können da verstehen die dann halt nichts mehr und denken erst Mal alle
nuscheln nur noch ja und projizieren das auch
nach außen so redet doch mal ordentlich ich
höre ich höre ich verstehe euch eigentlich das ist aber dann
oft eben ein von den hohen frequenzen her herkommender zunehmender
hörverlust und diese hörverluste die kann man natürlich bis zu einem gewissen
grad mit einer verstärkung der schallwellen ausgleichen indem man hörgeräte
baut die dann eben in den frequenzen wo weniger gutes hören noch vorliegt,
entsprechend mehr Schall abgeben.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich nicht beliebig steigern, weil das erzeugt ja dann
auch wiederum mehr Stress in der Schnecke, aber zumindest in einem bestimmten
Maße lässt sich das damit dann verbessern.
Also die Hörgeräte, die haben da eine Limitierung nach oben,
was einfach möglich ist und zwar auch eine Limitierung, die daher kommt,
weil die Hörgeräte natürlich ein Mikrofon brauchen. Mit dem Mikrofon können,
die Hörgeräte sich selber hören.
Das wird zwar in den Hörgang abgegeben, aber so ein bisschen was kommt ja doch
wieder draußen beim Mikrofon an und dann fangen die Dinge an,
Rückkopplungen zu kriegen, fangen an zu pfeifen.
Dann brauchen die Leute immer dichter und strenger abdichtende Ohrstöpsel,
damit das nicht passiert und dann ist das unangenehm zu tragen und dann ändert
sich es auch und die Leute wackeln dran rum.
Also Hörgeräte haben bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt eine sehr gut funktionierende
Lösung, aber irgendwann hört es auf.
Und dann gibt es als nächste Stufe, gibt es heute, das gibt es noch nicht so
wahnsinnig lange, Mittelohrimplantate, da wird also ein kleiner mechanischer Schwinger.
An die Gehörknöchelchen angeflanscht.
So wirklich so mikroskopisch kleines und schwingender Anker in der Spule,
der entsprechend angesteuert wird. Und der muss dann natürlich mikrochirurgisch
an die Gehörknöchelchen angedockt werden in irgendeiner Form.
Das ist dann quasi ein Trommelfellersatz?
Nee, das Trommelfell ist dann nach wie vor noch da. Das ist also auch im Prinzip
für eine Schwerhörigkeit des Innenohres gedacht.
Aber mit denen kommt man nochmal ein ganzes Stück weiter als mit Hörgeräten.
Aber was verstärken die denn dann?
Die haben selber ein Mikrofon. Die sitzen nicht nur alleine im Innenohr drin,
sondern außen auf dem Ohr sitzt ein Hörgerät drauf oder so eine Art von Hörgerät.
Es sitzt genauer gesagt etwas hinter dem Ohr. Da ist ein Mikrofon drin.
Eine digitale oder analoge Elektronik, die das Frequenz spezifisch verstärkt.
Und unter der Haut sitzt dann ein Gegenstück der Empfänger.
Der kriegt entweder digital oder analog, kriegt übertragen, was das System außen
hört und gemäß seiner patientenspezifischen Programmierung gesagt bekommen hat,
was es damit anfangen soll.
Das wird nach innen übertragen und das geht dann ans Mittelohr weiter und führt
da zu einer ausgeprägten Schwingung, die dann ans Innenohr übertragen wird.
Das geht aber auch nur für bestimmte...
Das heißt, es arbeitet dann quasi parallel zum Trommelfell.
Könnte man so sagen. Es dominiert aber das, was das Trommelfell tut.
Aber es ist schon richtig, ja. Das Trommelfell wird so mehr oder weniger...
Also es wird nicht entfernt, es wird auch nicht benutzt, es wird so mehr oder
weniger außer Betrieb genommen, weil die Hauptinformation sozusagen nur noch
vom Angriff. Also von daher ist es schon ein Trommelfellersatz.
Könnte man so sagen.
Es gibt natürlich das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, es gibt natürlich auch die
Patienten, bei denen die ganze Geschichte im Mittelohr jetzt schon nicht mehr intakt ist.
Also wo die Gehörknöchlichen vielleicht gar nicht mehr existieren,
weil irgendwelche schweren Entzündungen die zerstört haben oder sonst was nicht.
Da kann man diese Mittelohrimplantate aber trotzdem auch einsetzen.
Man muss nur mit anderen mechanischen Maßnahmen den Schall dann in die Kochlea reinbringen.
Da kommen dann diese kleinen Metallprothesen ins Spiel, die ich vorhin erwähnt hatte.
Da kann man also Kombinationen aus diesen Mittelohrschwingern und diesen Stapes,
also Steigbügelprothesen, nehmen und kann auf die Art und Weise das Schallsignal,
was man am Ende in der Schnecke wieder haben möchte, auf diesem Wege dort reinbringen.
Voraussetzung ist natürlich, dass die Schnecke per se noch halbwegs gut hört.
Man macht das jetzt normalerweise nicht, wenn die Schnecke noch normalhöhrend ist.
Das ist ja Quatsch. Die Schnecke hat schon ihren Hörverlust,
am Mittelohr stimmt aber auch irgendwas nicht mehr und dann geht man mit einem
Mittelohrimplantat ran.
Aber das ist natürlich nichts, was man beim Hörgerät der Akustiker um die Ecke
kriegt, sondern da muss man halt an die Klinik und das muss operativ eingesetzt
werden. Ein solches Implantat.
Und die nächste Stufe, das ist dann die Stufe, die die harte Sache ist,
wenn ich also in der Schnecke,
keine Möglichkeit mehr habe diese von außen kommenden mechanischen Anregungen
überhaupt wahrzunehmen,
weil die Haarzellen nicht mehr da sind, kaputt gegangen sind durch Ertaubung,
durch eine Infektion oder sonst eine Ursache, dann kann ich mit mechanischer
Anregung gar nichts mehr erreichen.
Ist ja auch völlig logisch. Ich habe keinen mechanischen Rezeptor mehr,
der das mir in Nervenimpulse umsetzt.
Und dafür gibt es dann das Kochleerimplantat.
Und das Kochleerimplantat, da wird jetzt üblicherweise in der Gegend vom runden
Fenster aufgemacht oder ein bisschen oberhalb davon.
Also diesem Ausdrucks, Ausgleichsmembran der Hörschnecke.
Die wird sozusagen aufgemacht und dort setzt man eine Elektrode ein.
Das ist aber jetzt nur das Ende eines Implantats.
Über den Rest haben wir noch nicht geredet. Wir reden jetzt mal nur über diesen
Innenurteil. Orteil. Das muss man
sich vorstellen wie so eine chinesische Glasnudel ungefähr aus Silikon.
Die ist drei Zentimeter lang. Es gibt auch Konstruktionen,
die machen aus diversen Gründen ein bisschen kürzer,
aber das ist ungefähr drei Zentimeter lang und auf der Oberfläche dieser Silikonglasnudel
sitzen Metallkontakte und in dem Elektrodenträger,
in diesem Silikonzylinder, sitzen dann Drädchen,
die diese Oberflächenkontakte sozusagen berühren und mit denen verschweißt sind
und das dann durch diese Glasnudel sozusagen nach hinten verbunden haben zu
einer gekapselten Elektronik.
Diese gekapselte Elektronik, die wird chirurgisch hier hinter dem Ohr eingesetzt.
Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz verstanden.
Ja, wir sind jetzt auch mal den umgekehrten Weg gegangen. Normalerweise sind
wir immer so schön von Peripher aus nach innen gekommen.
Und das haben wir jetzt mal nicht so schön gemacht. Genau, vielleicht drehen
wir es an der Stelle auch nochmal um.
Also grundsätzlich Kochlehrimplantat ist sozusagen, kommt in dem Moment ins Spiel,
wo man Hörfähigkeit wieder herstellen möchte,
wo aber das reine Nachbilden des mechanischen Luftdruckreizes über Trommelfell,
Hammer, Ambus, Steigbügel, egal an welcher Stelle man da jetzt ansetzt.
Also ein Hörgerät verstärkt ja sozusagen, ist ja quasi ein Lautsprecher in den Gehörgang.
So, das heißt der verstärkt einfach den Druck aufs Trommelfell,
aber ab da funktioniert so wie es sonst auch funktioniert.
Diese Mittelohrimplantate sagen, okay, Trommelfell ist jetzt schon raus aus dem Spiel,
darf gerne noch ein bisschen mitdrücken, aber im Wesentlichen übernehmen wir
diese mechanische Übertragung auf das System jetzt selber und jetzt zeigen wir
mal hier wo der Hammer hängt, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Oder wenn das eben aus irgendwelchen Gründen auch alles schon weggefault ist,
dann sagt man okay, dann sind wir jetzt einfach mal selber der Steigbügel und
trümmern da rein, aber dann würde die Schnecke ja immer noch ihr Ding tun, so gut sie es eben kann.
Und jetzt sind wir im Prinzip im dritten Schritt angekommen,
wo man sagt, Schnecke, also das einzige wozu jetzt diese Schnecke abgesehen
vom Gleichgewichtsorgan noch taugt, ist die Verbindung zu den Hörnerven herzustellen.
Das ist quasi, wir verwenden diese Schnecke eigentlich nur noch so als Docking
Station zum Rest des Gehirns und müssen jetzt eigentlich eine Systematik hervorbringen,
die eigentlich dasselbe tut wie eben die Herrchen dieser Haarnerven,
die in der Schnecke sind.
Dazu müsste man ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr genau nachbilden,
was sie eigentlich tun, was ich jetzt schon mal für eine irre Herausforderung halte.
Dieser letzte Schritt ist aber dann sozusagen eigentlich nur jetzt bei Leuten
zu machen, wo gar nichts mehr zu holen wäre. Das ist sozusagen Last Resort.
Ja, also da hat es natürlich wieder eine historische Entwicklung gegeben.
Inzwischen sind diese Kohleimplantatsysteme so gut, dass sie in den Grenzbereichen
schon mit Hörgeräten konkurrieren können.
Es gibt, also vor, sagen wir mal, gehen wir mal eine Zeit lang zurück,
springen wir mal 20 Jahre zurück. Vor 20 Jahren hat man diese Kochlerimplantate
nur bei Patienten eingesetzt, die wirklich stocktaub waren.
Wo gar nichts mehr ging. Die auch immer waren oder die stocktaub geworden sind?
In aller Regel solche, die taub geworden sind.
Weil erwachsene Patienten, die schon seit der Geburt taub waren,
die haben einen sehr großen Nachteil, nämlich dass sich die ganze Hörbahn und
das ganze Hörzentrum nicht vernünftig im Gehirn, sich nicht vernünftig ausgebildet hat.
Weil mangelse reiz mangelse reiz hat sich das nicht gebildet und solche zu lange wartet.
Wenn man, sagen wir mal, man hätte ein Kind, was,
Taub auf die Welt gekommen ist, nie auch nur irgendwas akustisch gehört hat
und man käme erst beispielsweise im Alter von zehn Jahren auf die Idee,
so jetzt setzen wir mal so einen Kochleimplantat ein, dann ist es zu spät.
Das heißt nicht, dass dann gar nichts mehr geht, also das Kind wird,
wenn es clever ist und trainiert, sicher lernen, Geräusche zu detektieren,
Umweltgeräusche wahrzunehmen, vielleicht Orientierungshilfen zu haben,
verschiedene Dinge unterschiedlich wahrzunehmen, aber wirklich einfach
so sprechen und und sprache verstehen
zu können ist da schon fast fast vorbei
man muss wann hätte man noch eine chance na
ja also ich mir ist es ein bisschen unangenehm eine genaue zeit zu nennen weil
das möglicherweise dazu führen könnte dass welche sagen ach der hat ja im podcast
gesagt so und so lange jetzt warten wir mal so und so lange grundsätzlich muss man sagen,
sobald nach der Geburt eine wasserdichte Diagnose da ist, dass das Gehör tatsächlich
nicht funktioniert. Und das kann man heutzutage.
Sollte man aktiv werden.
Der aller früheste Implantationszeitpunkt, der so gängige Praxis ist,
ist Alter von einem halben Jahr.
Da geht das los. Es gibt so einzelne heroische Chirurgen, die auch schon mal
versuchen, Rekorde zu brechen und sagen, wir haben schon vier Monate altes versorgt.
Aber der Standard ist so etwa nach einem halben Jahr und es zieht sich durch
alles, was wir inzwischen wissen, zieht sich als roter Faden durch je früher, desto besser. weil,
die Kinder sozusagen immer mehr damit aufwachsen. Wir sind jetzt wir haben ja
jetzt viele, viele Jahre schon richtig gute Implantatssysteme von der erreichbaren Höhereistung.
Und wir haben jetzt schon Kinder, die jetzt schon junge Erwachsene sind,
die vor 15 Jahren oder noch länger vor 20 Jahren versorgt worden sind.
Und da gibt es heutzutage dann junge Erwachsene, die als Kindertaube auf die
Welt gekommen sind und die heutzutage Funktional gesehen normal höhrig durch die Welt laufen.
Weil sie in welchem Alter?
Weil sie im Alter von zwei oder so eine Implantat bekommen haben.
Und jetzt muss man natürlich auch noch dazu sagen, macht man es gleich beidseitig
oder erst mal nur auf einer Seite.
Und da hat sich eigentlich auch die Meinung des Fachgebiets soweit entwickelt,
dass man sagt, wir sollten auch möglichst frühzeitig beide Seiten machen,
weil solche Sachen wie Schallquellenrichtung erkennen und auch in schwierigen
Situationen wie Störgeräusch kommt noch von irgendwo anders und den will ich aber verstehen.
Für solche Situationen ist es grundsätzlich besser zwei Ohren möglichst frühzeitig zu versorgen.
Ja, okay. Jetzt wollen wir aber doch nochmal zu dem eigentlichen System hin. Du hast schon recht.
Das, was wir vorhin gesagt haben, wir haben hier 3.000 bis 4.000 Haarzellen
im Innenohr sitzen. Wir haben 30.000 Nervenfasern, die von diesen Spiralganglehenzellen
im Zentrum der Kochlehre runter weggehen.
Und jetzt, wie wollen wir das elektronisch überhaupt machen?
Und das geht natürlich nicht. Das ist technisch heutzutage nicht möglich,
so viele spektral hochauflösende Informationen reinzubringen.
Technologisch ist es nicht möglich.
Und es ist auch deswegen nicht möglich, weil wir mit einer elektrischen Reizung,
die wir im Innenohr machen, wenn wir also jetzt mal einen einzelnen Kontakt
nehmen, den wir im Innenohr haben, dessen elektrisches Feld verbreitet sich einfach zu sehr.
Das reizt einfach zu viele Nachbarzellen mit. Das heißt, selbst wenn ich es
technologisch schaffen würde,
sehr, sehr viele Elektrodenkontakte in der Cochlea unterzubringen und auch zu
aktivieren, würden sich die elektrischen Felder so gegenseitig überlagern und
stören, dass diese hohe Frequenzauflösung höchstwahrscheinlich doch wieder nicht möglich wäre.
Also man besitzt einfach technisch überhaupt gar nicht diese Filigranität der
Einflussnahme auf Nervenzellen, weil die sich einfach in Stromstärken und Spannung
abspielen, die wir so gar nicht nachbilden können.
Vielleicht gibt es diese Technologie irgendwann nochmal, aber die ist jetzt
so nicht da. Aber wenn jetzt andererseits diese H-Nerven nicht funktionieren,
wo ist denn dann der Punkt, wo man ansetzen kann?
Ja, also...
Auch wenn wir jetzt wieder von innen nach außen gehen.
Ja, stimmt, wir sind wieder von innen nach außen. Vielleicht sollten wir es
doch mal andersrum aufziehen, oder? Ich weiß nicht. Na gut, also dann bleiben
wir mal bei dem, wo setzen wir denn an?
Erstens, wir wollen ja diese Spektralanalyse, die hydromechanische Spektralanalyse,
die das Innenohr macht, wollen wir ja in irgendeiner Form auch machen.
Die machen wir jetzt per Signalverarbeitung elektronisch.
Das heißt, wir haben irgendeinen Rechenchip da sitzen.
Früher waren das mal echte Signalprozessoren, heute sind das Chips,
die extra dafür hergestellt und entworfen.
Der kriegt das Ergebnis eines Mikrophones.
Der kriegt das Ergebnis eines Mikrophones. Also draußen auf dem Ohr oder hinter
dem Ohr haben wir ein Gerät sitzen,
das sieht aus wie ein futuristisches Hörgerät, das hat ein Mikrofon,
das hat diesen Spektralanalysechip, der noch tausend andere wirklich wichtige
Dinge auch noch tun muss.
Der analysiert aber das Mikrofon-Signal in eine spektrale Analyse und weiß jetzt...
Das muss dann auch noch patientenspezifisch eingestellt werden,
weil jeder Patient braucht auf jeder Frequenz oder jeder Tonhöhe unterschiedlich
stark und das muss individuell eingestellt werden, je nachdem wie der Zustand des Indos ist.
Das wird sozusagen schon alles schon draußen gemacht. Also man nimmt das Signal
auf und versucht es schon mal so gut aufzuteilen.
Das wird alles draußen schon gemacht.
Das ist ja auch sinnvoll, weil wenn man da technologische Fortschritte hat,
dann lassen die sich außen schnell tauschen.
Dann lassen die sich außen schnell tauschen. Neues Gerät, besseres Ergebnis, zack.
Das heißt, man leitet in das Innenohr schon eine digitale Spektralinformation
ein, die einfach dann den Weg nimmt mit Kabel dahin.
Das ist jetzt so, dass dieses Außengerät diese Spektralanalyse macht und die
Information digital an das Implantat überträgt.
Das geht durch die Haut durch per...
Das geht jetzt kein Kabel komplett rein, sondern man macht so eine induktive
Koppelung dann wahrscheinlich.
Das gab es aber auch mal. Das war State of the Art in den 80er Jahren.
Da gab es tatsächlich Implantate, die waren direkt vor einem Stecker,
den die Leute hinter dem Ohr sitzen hatten. War wirklich ein Stecker.
Von da gingen nur Drähte ins Innenohr. Und an den Stecker konnte man im Prinzip
alles andocken, was man wollte.
Und das System, was die Patienten an den, also es war ein kommerziell erhältliches
System, was die Patienten an den Kliniken bekommen haben, das waren weltweit
450 Patienten, die dieses System damals bekommen haben.
Und die hatten so einen Zigarettenschachtel großen, sogenannten Prozessor,
den mussten sie mit sich rumtragen, den mussten die oben anstecken.
Und der hat dann ein Mikrofon gehabt und hat das spektral analysiert und hat
das dann auf diese Elektroden, die per Kabel direkt Verbindung ins Innenurgen drauf gegeben.
Das war nicht toll, was dabei rauskommt, aber das war damals state of the art.
Und ohne diese Patienten mit dem Stecker, wäre man nie so weit gekommen, wie man heute ist.
Weil diese Patienten, die konnten in den Laboren sitzen und an die konnte man
alles anschließen, was man im Labor konstruieren konnte. Und...
Oh man, das ist ja wie bei Matrix.
Irgendwo muss man mal anfangen. Ja klar.
So ist das halt. Irgendwann guckst du zurück und denkst dir,
Gott, was haben wir damals alles gemacht.
Dann ist man aber an einem Zustand, wo dann heutzutage oder ist ja egal,
um was es jetzt geht, wo man dann halt sagt...
Mensch, sind wir froh, dass diese Zeiten vorbei sind. Aber ohne das früher hätten
wir das nicht geschafft.
Aber diese diese Patienten mit den Steckern, die haben wirklich von denen gab
es einige wenige, die findet man auch unter irgendwelchen anonymisierten Schlüsseln
in der publizierten Literatur.
Da gab es einige wenige, die haben wirklich wortwörtlich Monate,
Monate, wenn nicht Jahre ihres Lebens in Laboren verbracht und haben mit den Forschern,
die da saßen, das waren dann alles Ingenieure natürlich, alles Signalverarbeiter,
Physiker, Elektrotechniker und die haben mit diesen Patienten in den Laboren
alle möglichen Arten der Signalverarbeitung ausprobiert,
bis man nach und nach dahinter gekommen ist, wie man die Cochlea elektrisch
jetzt wirklich reizen muss, damit möglichst viel bei rumkommt.
Und der große Durchbruch, der war erst 1991.
Das war sogar eine Publikation in Nature damals.
Der ist ein amerikanisches Labor gewesen, wo ich selber auch mal zweieinhalb Jahre gearbeitet habe.
Und dieses Labor hat damals wirklich einen ganz fundamentalen Durchbruch in
der Signalverarbeitung hingekriegt und die Leute waren im Labor unglaublich gut,
diese Steckerpatienten und mit ihren komischen Prozessoren, mit denen sie durch
den Alltag liefen, hatten die viel, viel schlechtere Resultate.
Die waren dann immer ganz geknickt, dass sie das nie mitnehmen konnten,
was sie da im Labor alles gehört hatten.
Aber im Prinzip müssten sie doch dann einfach andere Zuspielungsgeräte bekommen?
Und ist auch so, dass auch passiert mit. Ach so, also die Früchte der Arbeit auch zum Glück.
Also die Patienten, die haben dann teilweise als die Systeme sich weiterentwickelt
hatten, konnten die dann anders konstruiert werden und und dann konnte man eben
die modernen Systeme andocken.
Das habe ich mit einem von diesen Patienten habe ich das selber mal mit unserem
damals entwickelten System gemacht.
Der war immer gewöhnt, im Labor zu sitzen und war wirklich absolut großartig.
Also auch von dem, was er erzählen konnte, was er jetzt für Wahrnehmungen hat.
Und dann hatten wir damals, das war eben in den 90ern, Dann hatten wir unser
System als Prototyp fertig.
Und dann bin ich halt mit einem Kollegen von mir in die USA rübergeflogen.
Dann haben wir das mit dem ausprobiert und der fand das großartig,
weil das war jetzt auf einmal genau das selbe, was er aus dem Labor kannte.
Nur intragbar, aber Prototyp. So so so Drähte stehen raus.
Hier ist noch ein Potty, der baumelt noch in der Luft. Er meinte,
ja, das, das möchte er jetzt unbedingt nach, ich glaube, nach Boston mitnehmen
oder so. Da war eine andere Arbeitsgruppe, die befreundet war mit der, in wo, wo das stattfand.
Da kommt er durch die Flugkontrolle nicht durch, er sieht aus wie eine Bombe,
kann er nicht mitnehmen.
Aber der hatte, also der und einige andere, die hatten dann auch tatsächlich
später tragbare Systeme gekriegt, die dann ihnen dasselbe an Hörleistung angeboten
haben, was sie aus dem Labor kannten.
So was hat man denn dann rausgefunden mit diesem bahnbrechenden Paper 91?
Also was war denn sozusagen der Durchbruch für, wie rede ich mit dem Innenohr,
was sich eigentlich nicht mehr ansprechen lassen wird.
Also das allererste, was man probiert hat,
und das geht zurück auf diese Franzosen 1957, war eine Elektrode direkt vor die Kochleersetzung,
gar nicht unbedingt drein, also
ein Analogsignal ohne jegliche spektrale Analyse. Das war's für heute.
Das hat man bis in die 70er-Jahre gemacht.
Wo hat man das dann angestockt?
Ich muss sagen, ich habe die Zeiten ja selber nicht erlebt, aber man hat das
direkt zum Beispiel ans runde Fenster drangelegt, wo man nur eine Membran hatte,
durch die man elektrisch sozusagen durch musste.
Aber viele Chirurgen oder das ganze Fachgebiet haben sich am Anfang gar nicht
unbedingt getraut, in die Schnecke reinzugehen.
Da macht man dann so viel kaputt, da passiert dann so viel an,
was weiß ich, Entzündungen.
Also so ein bisschen diese Ritter Methode. Man macht da jetzt mal ein Kabel
ran und schickt da mal was rein und dann gucken wir mal, ob es irgendwelche
Ergebnisse erzählt. Aber im Prinzip, man umgeht quasi das komplette System.
Also anstatt irgendwas mechanisch zu, in dieser Flüssigkeit zu induzieren,
was dann die Haarnerven dazu bringt, das richtige elektrische Signal zu erzeugen,
legt man einfach mal irgendwo ein elektrisches Signal an und hofft,
dass das dann so im Gesamtprozessing dieses Apparates ein bisschen was bringt.
Irgendwas Brauchbares erzeugt. Genau. Oh man, das ist schon brutal.
Aber ich meine, es ist schwer, sich jetzt die Situation eines tauben Menschen
so vorzustellen, aber ich denke, dass jeglicher Außenkontakt,
der da erstmal mehr als nichts ist, schon ein Gewinn darstellen kann.
Kann aber sicherlich auch sehr nervig sein, oder?
Ja, aber das ist dann vielleicht etwas, was für die Sprachkommunikation ausreichend ist,
um jemanden, der nur schlecht Lippen ablesen kann, so viel Zusatzinformation
zu geben, dass die Kombination aus Lippen ablesen und diesen seltsamen Hör-Eindrücken
ausreicht, um kommunizieren zu können.
Aber das ist jetzt Stand der 60er und bis, sagen wir mal, in die Mitte der 70er gewesen. Genau.
Dann hat eine österreichische Arbeitsgruppe das erste mehrkanalige System gebaut,
was mehrere Elektroden hatte, also der erste Ansatz dazu diese spektrale Aufdröselung zu machen,
Das war, wenn ich richtig informiert war, dass sogar acht einzelne Spektrale
unterschiedliche Bereiche, die da analysiert worden sind.
Und für damalige Verhältnisse war das wirklich heroisch. Also das war wirklich schon enorm gut.
Man hat das, war aber technologisch nicht ganz einfach für die damaligen Zeiten.
Man ist dann erstmal auch wieder bei analogen Systemen geblieben.
Spektral schon gefiltert, also verschiedene Frequenzbereiche elektronisch herausgegriffen
und hat die Signale dieser Frequenzbereiche,
diese unterschiedlichen Frequenzanteile, hat man dann aber auch als Analogsignale
ins Innenohr reingeschickt.
Im Prinzip wie so ein Equalizer.
Im Prinzip ja und das hat sich in der Kochlehre natürlich auch und das war das
wesentliche Problem Problem aus heutiger Sicht, glaubt man das so zu wissen,
das wesentliche Problem war, dass die alle kreuz und quer miteinander interagieren.
Wenn man sich also jetzt vorstellt, man setzt eine Elektrode tief rein für die
tiefen Frequenzen in die Kochlöhe, in die, sagen wir mal, man geht so eine,
eineinhalb Windungen rein und hat da einen Elektrodekontakt und der macht ein
schönes, vergleichsweise tieffrequentes, elektrisches Signal.
Und jetzt ein bisschen weiter aus und außerhalb hat man jetzt eine andere Elektrode,
die ist natürlich für einen anderen Frequenzbereich zuständig und macht jetzt
ein hochfrequentes analoges Signal,
dann hat man natürlich ein irrwitziges Übersprechen,
weil wenn das eine Signal, sagen wir mal, gerade in der positiven tieffrequenten
Phase ist und das andere arbeitet schnell hin und her,
dann fließen die Ströme, die reizen dann sozusagen nicht mehr lokal die Nervenzellen,
die man erreichen will, sondern fließt irgendwie kreuz und quer unvorhersehbar
diagonal von einem Ende zur Kochlehr ständig sich andauernd ändern,
fließen irgendwelche Querströme, irgendwelche Übersprecheffekte finden statt
und diese ganze schöne Intention der spektralen Zerlegung funktioniert nicht mehr,
weil sich alles gegenseitig kreuz und quer voneinander abhängig gegenseitig reizt.
Aber das war State of the Art in den 80ern. Diese Patienten mit mit diesem Steckerimplantat,
die hatten das, die hatten dieses Prinzip und kamen damit so halbwegs zurecht.
Es gab auch welche, die damit Sprache verstanden haben, die man im Labor testen
konnte mit Sprachmaterial und gucken, wie viel verstehen die denn jetzt und
die signifikante Anteile von Sprache tatsächlich verstanden haben.
Wo die einzelnen Patienten wahrscheinlich auch unterschiedlich gut disponiert
waren, je nachdem, wie gut sich eben ihr Sprachzentrum schon hat vorher aufbauen
können und wann diese Maßnahmen kamen.
Oder in welchem Zustand der Hörnerf oder das Innenkennenspiel war.
So und der große Durchbruch, der war jetzt das was...
Was bei den Osteoskopen diese früheren, diese Chopper-Technik, dieses Zerhacken ist.
Dass man also sehr schnell zwischen den verschiedenen Frequenzbändern hin und
her springt und eben nicht mehr gleichzeitig stattfindende Analogsignale anbietet,
sondern schnelle Pulse anbietet, die aber zeitlich nicht gleichzeitig stattfinden.
Man hat also, sagen wir mal, eine tiefe Frequenz und man weiß,
man möchte diese tiefe Frequenzbereich, möchte man jetzt gerne in der und der Intensität darbieten,
dann sendet man einen kurzen elektrischen Puls, an der richtigen Stelle setzt
man den ab, dann ist aber elektrisch gesehen gleich wieder Ruhe.
Und dann kann man an eine andere Stelle in die Kochlehr springen und da wieder
einen schnellen kurzen Puls.
Also so ein Zeit-Multiplex-Verfahren.
Genau, ein sehr schnelles, rei um arbeitendes Zeit-Multiplex-Verfahren.
Wie klein sind dann da so die Zeit-Slots, die dann da befüllt werden?
Wie lange existiert so ein Signal dann?
Ein Signal, das existiert so etwa vielleicht 50 Mikrosekunden,
um einen runden Schätzwert zu liefern. Also ein einzelner Puls dauert so Pi
mal Daumen, 50 Mikrosekunden.
Das ist aber jetzt auch ein Puls, der gleichstromfrei ist.
Ist also ein biphasischer Puls, der aus einem positiven und einem negativen
Phase besteht. Der schickt kurz Ladung rein ins Gewebe und zieht die Ladung
gleich wieder raus aus dem Gewebe, sodass kein Gleichstromanteil drin enthalten ist.
Also diese Pulse, die aus einer anodischen, aus einer kathodischen Phase bestehen,
die reizen kurz das Gewebe.
Einige Nervenzellen, die jetzt bereit sind dafür, also nicht noch in der Refraktärzeit
von einer vorherigen Aktivität sich am regenerieren sind von ein paar Millisekunden vorher.
Aber erzeugen da keine Ladung.
Genau, es bleibt keine Ladung im Gewebe stehen und und fängt an das zu elektrolysieren.
Das hat man schon immer nicht gemacht.
Der Wechselstrom.
Ja, also seit Volta hat man das nicht mehr gemacht.
Danke Ritter.
Ja und dann wird dann eben in ziemlich schneller Geschwindigkeit, also sagen wir mal,
1000, 2000, 3000 Mal in der Sekunde kriegt dann ein einzelner Ort in der Cochlea
immer wieder so einen Puls.
Und wie viele Orte wurden dann unterschieden? Also wie viel bändrig war das Ganze?
Das war damals, als der große Durchbruch war, hat man das ja mit diesen Steckerpatienten
gemacht und die hatten nur sechs.
Sechs. Okay. Also sechs Orte, sechs verschiedene Frequenzbänder,
die man unterschieden hat.
Das Mikrofon, das die Umgebungssounds aufnimmt,
teilt quasi in sechs Bänder auf und zeitlich verteilt werden dann jeweils die
einzelnen Bereiche mehr oder weniger stark stimuliert,
je nachdem wie stark das Klangensignal in dem Bereich dann war.
Und das dann gemultiplex auf 4000 Zeiteinheiten pro Sekunde.
Größenordnung.
Und das hat dann deutliche Verbesserungen.
Ja, das hat einen irrwitzigen Durchbruch in der Verstehbarkeit gebracht,
weil man diese spektrale Aufdröselbarkeit, sei sie noch so grob,
sei sie nur sechs Frequenzblender, die war aber jetzt auf einmal verfügbar.
Vorher hatte man zwar sechs analog angeboten oder die realen Patienten im realen
Betrieb hatten nur vier davon aktiviert von den sechs, die in der Kochlehr waren,
konnte man nur vier einschalten.
Die hat man sich dann ausgesucht, welche sind denn die unterschiedbarsten und
und hatten die genommen.
Aber die vier waren kaum unterscheidbar. Das hat sich alles überlagert.
Und dadurch, dass man jetzt auf einmal so schnell reihum hin und her gesprungen
ist, war auf einmal die...
Und auch gleich sechs nutzen konnte sozusagen, also auch die Auflösung noch mal vergrößert hat.
Und das ist dann... Wie gesagt, das war eine Publikation in Nature 1991.
Diese Vorgehensweise nennt man die CIS, C-I-S, Continuous Interleaved Sampling,
also permanente, verschachtelte Abtastung.
Die CIS-Stimulationsstrategie, und das hat eine Arbeitsgruppe in North Carolina
in USA gemacht, in Kooperation mit einer zweiten Arbeitsgruppe in Boston,
die haben das gemeinsam publiziert.
Und das war so ein Durchbruch, dass das relativ schnell daraufhin sich in der
klinischen Praxis in käuflich erwerbbaren Systemen wiedergefunden haben.
Das war auch der Zeitpunkt, wo ich damals dann den Einstieg hatte und das,
was die gemacht haben, dann in ein reales System gebaut habe.
Die Technik dann umgesetzt ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo man das Grundprinzip,
was auch heute noch genauso durchgeführt wird, umgesetzt hat.
So kann man das sagen.
Vermute jetzt mal, dass so aktuelle Systeme dann vielleicht auch in der Anzahl
der Elektronen dann noch feiner auflösen. Also du hast ja vorhin diese Glasnudel genannt.
Also, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, also durch das runde Fenster,
also eigentlich dieses Druckausgleich, Membran wird quasi als Einstiegspunkt genutzt.
Das ist ja dann das andere Ende der gesamten Schneckenbahn.
Also, wenn man einmal rein und dann wieder zurückgeht, dann landet man ja dort.
Man geht also quasi von hinten rein, führt jetzt da die Nudel in die Schnecke bis zum...
Bis zu dem einen Ende der Schnecke, also quasi die eine Hälfte,
die eine Schneckenhälfte wird gefüllt, die andere bleibt so wie sie ist,
weil braucht man nicht nochmal doppelt. Damit ist man an der Membran dran.
Und wie viele Kontaktpunkte, wie viele
Elektroden sind dann so in so einem State-of-the-Art-Kochlier-Implantat,
was man da heute reinschiebt?
Auch nicht viel mehr. Auch nur sechs? Nee, nee, sechs sind nicht.
Also es gibt eine Variation, zwölf, sechzehn und vierundzwanzig.
Das sind die derzeitig verfügbaren Systeme. Und man hat natürlich sich die Frage
gestellt, ja, das muss doch was bringen.
Die größere Anzahl an Elektronenkontakten muss doch in irgendeiner Form einen Vorteil bringen.
Und da haben sich viele Leute, ich könnte vielleicht sagen, die Zähne daran
ausgebissen und haben mit realen Patienten, die solche Implantatssysteme dann
hatten, im Labor experimentiert und hat unterschiedliche Bereiche deaktiviert.
Einfach durch umprogrammieren des Systems kann man das ja mal ausprobieren.
Er hat gesagt, also wir schalten jetzt mal gleichmäßig verteilt von den,
von mir aus 12 Elektroden, vier weg und dann noch mal zwei zusätzlich weg und
noch mal zwei zusätzlich weg oder hat mit einem System, was 22 Elektroden hatte,
hat man es in größeren Schritten gemacht und hat gesagt, wir nehmen mal 20, 10, 7,
4 und nur eine und hat ausprobiert, wie sich das übereinstimmend in mehreren
Arbeitsgruppen und über mehrere verschiedene technische Systeme hinweg zu der Erkenntnis gekommen,
dass man ungefähr jenseits von 10 keinen Zugewinn mehr hat.
Also 10 aktive Elektroden.
10 aktive unterscheidbare Elektroden kann man auf 12, 15, 20 hochschalten und
es tut sich nichts mehr fürs Sprache verstehen.
Wenn man dann in dieser Nudel eine Auswahl von 24 hätte, kann man dann immer
noch Optimierungen erzielen, dadurch dass man sagt, welche von denen man jetzt tatsächlich nutzt?
Kann man machen. In der Praxis passiert das normalerweise nicht.
Also der Ort ist sozusagen auch gar nicht so entscheidend. Es geht einfach nur
darum, eine gewisse Mindestauflösung.
Nein, doch der Ort ist schon entscheidend. Also, es ist jetzt so,
da fängt es jetzt an, Hersteller spezifisch zu werden und da kommen jetzt dann
irgendwelche Marketing-Sachen natürlich ins Spiel.
Wenn ich das jetzt aufdröselt, dann rede ich dem einen oder dem anderen Hersteller Plus oder Minus.
Okay.
Die...
Die grundsätzliche Idee ist, dass man eigentlich gerne die gesamte Cochlea abgedeckt
hätte, dass man sämtliche Frequenzbereiche gerne abdecken würde.
Das ist aber teilweise chirurgisch nicht so ohne Weiteres machbar,
weil der Durchmesser der Cochlea wird nach oben hin so ein bisschen kleiner
und die Elektrode da reinzubekommen wird schwieriger und schwieriger.
Richtig erfahrene, gute Chirurgen kriegen das ohne jedes Problem hin, außer in Sonderfällen.
Aber umso mehr Elektroden da drin sind, umso unflanzibler wird das.
Umso steifer wird das Ganze. Dann gibt es natürlich die Idee,
wir könnten die Elektrode spiralig vorformen, damit sie da sozusagen leichter
reinkleitet. Aber dazu muss man erst mal gestreckt anliefern.
Und dann ist das wieder per se in gewisser Schwierigkeit.
Da fängt es aber jetzt an wirklich herstellersteller spezifisch zu werden.
Die einen Chirurgen hätten das ganz gerne lieber so, die anderen lieber so.
Aber unterm Strich ist es so, dass man heute mit den Elektroden versucht,
möglichst von der Cochlear Bereiche abzudecken, an die man rankommt.
Und dass man dann in der Aktivierung, wenn die Patienten dann in der Klinik
sind und man das System zum ersten Mal einschaltet, dann schaut man sich natürlich
an, wie hören sich diese einzelnen Elektrodenkontakte für die Patienten an.
Perfekt ist es, wenn die, sagen wir mal, wir haben 12 Elektroden,
dass die eine schöne tonleiterartige Tonhöhenerhöhung hören,
wenn ich von den Elektroden 1 bis 12 durchgehe.
Ist aber leider nicht immer so. Manche haben dann zwei oder drei,
die sich genau gleich anhören oder es gibt einen größeren Sprung von der einen
zur nächsten und da kann man dann entsprechend drauf eingehen.
Das heißt, man kalibriert dann, indem man entweder die abgegebenen Signale anders betont?
Ja, indem man den Frequenzbereich, den man aus der Außenwelt herausgreift,
entsprechend am oberen oder unteren Ende ein bisschen hin und her schiebt.
Dass man also die Lage der Elektrode in der Kochlehr so nutzt in der Einstellung
von dem äußeren Gerät und von der spektralen Analyse des Systems,
dass es für den Patienten im Idealfall möglichst natürlich klingt.
Bei dieser Zuteilung dieser Zeitslots, weil ja nicht alle Elektronen gleichzeitig
feuern dürfen, sondern man macht das so quasi, ich denke mal die erste Methode
war einfach so round robin, jede Elektrode kriegt die gleiche Anzahl Zeitslots.
Jetzt würde ich mal so vermuten, dass es auch sein könnte, dass die hohen Frequenzen
vielleicht häufiger aktualisiert werden müssen als die niedrigen Frequenzen?
Ja, da kommen wir gleich an den Punkt der Abtastung.
Die Originalschwingung des analogen Signals, so wie es gefiltert ist,
sagen wir mal, wir haben einen Frequenzbereich jenseits von 5 Kilohertz.
Sagen wir mal, der Frequenzbereich zwischen 7 und 8 Kilohertz,
nur um willkürlich irgendwas rauszugreifen.
Den kann ich ja eigentlich gar nicht abtasten mit der Abtastrate,
mit der ich diese Pulse auf die, auf das Innenohr gebe. Das geht ja gar nicht.
Man macht das dann, weil wir jetzt selber nur bei 4000 Hertz sind sozusagen.
Genau. Also jetzt nach dem Abtasttheorem müsste man mindestens mit einem Faktor
2 von der Abtastrate drüber liegen, um das originale analog gefilterte Signal
überhaupt repräsentieren zu können.
Das macht man aber gar nicht. Man versucht das erst gar nicht,
sondern man nimmt sozusagen die Einhüllende, so eine Hüllkurve drüber.
Also man betrachtet die hohe Frequenz des eigentlichen, die eigentliche Frequenz,
die man hört, gewissermaßen als Trägersignal, was amplitudenmoduliert ist.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel in Zischlaut spreche wie hier so A-Scha,
dann habe ich beim A nur tiefe und mittlere Frequenzen,
beim Sch habe ich hauptsächlich den ganzen hohen Bereich aktiv und wenn ich
diesen Übergang habe A-Scha,
dann ist die Aktivität des höheren Frequenzbereichs im A ist praktisch nicht
da und dann beim Sch schießt das hoch und wenn das SCA, der Zischlaut vorbei
ist, dann geht das wieder runter.
Das heißt die werden sozusagen, die Slots werden auch nur so zugeteilt wie der
Anteil auch wirklich jetzt im Gesamtsignal.
Solche Konzepte gibt es auch, aber wesentlich ist erst mal, dass man mit der
Abtastrate, zumindest bei den hohen Frequenzen, eh keine Chance hat hinterher zu kommen.
Würde man vielleicht gerne machen. Es gibt auch ein paar clevere Ansätze,
die so ein bisschen in die Richtung was versuchen.
Was ist denn da das Problem?
Man kann doch einfach kleinere Zahlslots nehmen.
Eben nicht. Wenn ich diese Stimulationsimpulse, die ich brauche,
um den Nerv anzuregen, wenn ich die kürzer und kürzer und kürzer mache,
dann kriege ich den Nerv, der reagiert irgendwann.
Der ist dann zu träge dafür. Der ist dann einerseits zu träge und zweitens müsste
ich kompensierend die Stimulationsströme immer weiter rauf drehen.
Und das ist irgendwann technologisch nicht mehr möglich.
Weil wenn ich einen Strom fließen lassen will, muss ich ja durch den elektrischen
Widerstand des Gewebes muss ich den Strom ja sozusagen durchdrücken.
Dazu brauche ich eine gewisse Spannung, die ich aufbauen muss.
Und eine genügend hohe Spannung in einem Implantat aufzubauen ist nicht so trivial.
Da gibt es also technologische Limitierungen, wie viel Spannung man zur Verfügung
hat, damit man damit dann genügend hohe Ströme anbieten könnte.
Und selbst wenn man das macht, selbst wenn man in der Lage wäre,
jetzt mal simplifizieren gesagt, beliebig hohe Ströme anbieten zu können technologisch.
Und die dann immer kürzer und kürzer zeitlich werden zu lassen,
dann gehen die trotzdem irgendwann einfach wie der Wind durchs Gewebe.
Die sind irgendwann einfach nur hochfrequent und gehen einfach am Nerv vorbei
und das hat man natürlich in den ganz ganz frühen Zeiten,
ich spreche jetzt von 70er Jahren, haben wir das alles systematisch durchprobiert
an irgendwelchen Krebs, Neuronen und hat versucht da dahinter zu kommen,
in welchen Bereichen das aktiv ist.
Also aktivierbar ist. Das heißt, man kann das nicht beliebig schnell machen, beliebig kurz machen.
Man ist auf eine niedrige Rampling-Funk-Quanz angewiesen, aber ist auch nicht
so schlimm, weil so funktioniert es ja auch.
Worin besteht dann die eigentliche Verbesserung, die man jetzt noch erzielen
konnte über die letzten Jahre?
Also einmal hat sich auf der Ebene der Stimulationsmethodik durchaus noch was ergeben.
Also wie die Elektroden wirken?
Nee, die Art und Weise wie man die elektrische Stimulation stattfindet.
Ja, das meine ich ja. Also wie die sozusagen den Strom übergeben.
Also diese ursprüngliche CIS-Strategie, die dieser große Durchbruch Anfang der
90er war, die hatte gar nicht versucht die Phasenlage des Original-Signals zu repräsentieren.
Weil sie eh gesagt hat, spätestens bei den mittleren hohen Frequenzen geht das
mit der Abtastrate sowieso nicht mehr.
Also hat man gesagt, wir nehmen, wir filtern zwar in diese Frequenzbänder,
aber wir bilden da nur die einhüllende drum.
Wir betrachten also die eigentliche Frequenz als eine Trägerfrequenz,
die amplitude moduliert ist und was wir jetzt an Stimulation anbieten,
ist die gerade aktuelle Amplitude dieses Signals.
Das war der erste Schritt. Damit hatte man aber jegliche Phaseninformation des
Trägersignals, wenn ich es mal so nennen darf, verloren.
Das war aber dann der nächste Schritt. Das war dann Ende der 90er.
Da haben im Wesentlichen einige ganz wenige Leute, die sich das schon richtig
ausgedacht hatten, haben sich hingesetzt und gesagt, Moment mal,
wir vernachlässigen ja diese Phaseninformation.
Also die zeitliche Positionsinformation, wo die Wellenschwingung eigentlich sitzt.
Weil wir haben ja nur die Hüllkurve. Die geht halt nur lauter oder leiser,
aber nicht mehr, wo ist die eigentliche Schwingung gewesen. Dann haben die gesagt,
okay, dann, jetzt mal sehr salopp gesagt, dann spielen wir halt intelligent mit der Zeitachse.
Dann setzen wir die elektrischen Pulse, die wir abgeben, zeit synchron zu den,
sagen wir mal, Nulldurchgängen von den Wellen hin.
Das heißt, man hat nicht so gleichmäßige Zeitabstände, sondern man schiebt die
Zeitabstände selber noch in Abhängigkeit von dem eigentlichen Signal.
Auf der Zeitachse hin und her. Und das ist, man hat also das was beim, bei der,
Alten Stimulations Strategie bei dieser Zis Strategie das continuous war dieses
andauernd around Robin das hat man zumindest in den tieffrequenten Bereichen
wo man sozusagen wo es sinnvoll ist das hin hin hin zu codieren und wo unser
Hörsystem das auch mitspielt muss man auch dazu sagen das System.
Bei den hohen Frequenzen ist auch unserem Hörorgan das eigentlich egal.
Also auch bei den hohen Frequenzen arbeitet unser Hörorgan eigentlich auch im
Wesentlichen als Hüllkurvenextraktor und nicht als tieffrequenter Phasenwahrnehmer.
Das ist eher bei den tiefen Frequenzen. Da hat man gesagt, okay,
dann teilen wir das auf und dann machen wir eben den unteren Frequenzbereich
Phasensynchron und da oben ist es uns wurscht und dann...
Weil da könnte man es eh nicht nachbilden.
Genau und da, die bezahlen den Preis dafür, dass die Tiefen jetzt Phasensynchron sind.
Dann hat es noch einen weiteren Schritt gegeben, hat mal gesagt,
Moment mal, wenn wir jetzt diese Pulse doch wieder zeitgleich anbieten würden,
angenommen wir könnten das, dann könnten wir ja die Abtastrate massiv erhöhen.
Wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise 10 Elektroden haben, um die wir immer Reihe umdurchschalten müssen,
dann können wir nur, jeden Zehnten kommt einer dran, wenn wir es aber jetzt
irgendwie schaffen würden, doch wieder jeden anbieten zu lassen,
dann haben wir auf einmal eine viel höhere Abtastrate, dann kriegen wir die
Zeitinformation vielleicht auch besser hin.
Und da war man aber natürlich sofort wieder in dieser alten Bredouille der Kanal
gegenseitigen Beeinflussung, wenn ich mehrere gleichzeitig aktiv habe.
Und dann hat man gesagt, okay, vielleicht können wir das ja so machen,
dass wir das, was wir an Kanalinteraktion erwarten, vorher vorauseilend wegrechnen.
Dass man also diese Kanalinteraktionen voraus berechnet und sagt,
aha, wenn wir aber entsprechend weniger stimulieren auf eine bestimmte,
geschickte, genau ausgerechnete Art und Weise, dann ist in der Summe annähernd
das da, was wir eigentlich wollen.
Das heißt, man kann dann wieder mehrere Elektroden gleichzeitig aktivieren.
Man rechnet sozusagen das Gesamtsignal oder die Stärke der Einzelsignale so
weit runter, dass es in der Summe das ergibt, was man eigentlich will.
Fand ich auch extrem pfiffig. Das ist aber im Moment noch so in der Forschung drin.
Jetzt hast du ja gesagt...
Du arbeitest ja, also ich meine, ist ja zwangsläufig. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt
und sagt, ich bin ein potentieller Empfänger für so einen Implantat.
Ist ja sagen wir mal jetzt nicht so wie, ich hole mir einen Krückstock oder
einen Rollator oder ich fahre jetzt im Rollstuhl oder so, weil das hat man und
benutzt man und wenn man es wirklich nicht haben wollen würde, dann man es wieder los.
Aber so ein Eingriff, auch noch so mitten im Kopf, ist ja jetzt kein Pappenstil.
Also einerseits ein enormer chirurgischer Eingriff, aber es bedeutet ja im Prinzip
auch sozusagen einmal als Wunsch und Bereitschaft der Verabschiedung des bisher
wahrgenommenen Lebensstils.
Leute, die früher schon mal gesprochen haben, werden das sicherlich dann auch wollen.
Also kann ich mir auf jeden Fall gut vorstellen. Ich meine, wenn man mal gehört
hat und dann ist es weg, da denke ich mal, da fehlt einem was trotzdem.
Also was muss zusammenkommen und wie ist es mit solchen Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten?
Also wie viel muss man überhaupt mit den Patienten zusammenarbeiten,
bis das diesen ganzen Prozess dann auch bis wir so weit sind,
dass wir das aktivieren können. Dass das alles gehen kann.
Wie arbeitet man dann sozusagen auch mit den Leuten bei der Aktivierung dann dieses Implantats?
Also das ist natürlich so, dass man erstmal eine wirklich vernünftige Diagnose
braucht. Die Patienten kommen mit Hörbeschwerden oder werden von ihren Angehörigen
geschickt und dann muss man erstmal untersuchen, na ist das denn überhaupt in
dem Bereich eines Hörverlustes, der für das in Frage kommt.
Vielleicht ist das auch nur subjektiv, erstmal ein Hörverlust,
der gar nicht so schlimm ist und den Hörgeräte noch abdecken können oder auch
unter Umständen ein Mittelohr-Implantat abdecken kann.
Wenn wir dann, da gibt es eine entsprechende Höruntersuchungen,
die man an den Kliniken durchführt und dann stellt sich halt halt nach kurzer
Zeit heraus. Ja, das wäre prinzipiell in dem Bereich.
Wo alles andere nicht mehr vernünftig geht, kommt eigentlich dann nur noch ein
Cochle-Emplantat in Frage.
Dann müssen natürlich noch ein paar andere Dinge abgeklärt werden,
ob es denn zum Beispiel operierbar ist. Man muss also zum Beispiel mal klar
machen, dass die Schnecke noch flüssigkeitsgefüllt ist. Es gibt manche Erkrankungen
wie zum Beispiel eine Meningitis-Infektion.
Die haben gerne mal zur Folge, dass da
Verknöcherungen stattfinden und dass die Schnecke nach und nach mit fibrösem
Gewebe und dann bis zum Anschlag unter Umständen mit hartem verwachsenen Knochen
zuwächst und dann hat man keine Chance mehr das ordentlich reinzukriegen.
Dann ist alles schon wirklich sehr sehr viel schwieriger.
Mit manchen Tricks kann man in manchen Fällen durchaus noch was erreichen.
Aber eine Voraussetzung für den Standardfall des Cochlear Implantats ist,
dass die Schnecke überhaupt noch frei und offen und flüssigkeitsgefüllt ist.
Dann muss natürlich erreicht sein, muss natürlich sichergestellt sein,
dass der Grund nicht hinter der Schnecke liegt, auf dem Weg zum Gehirn hoch.
Es gibt auch manchmal Erkrankungen, bestimmte Tumore zum Beispiel,
die den Hörnerv angreifen,
ihn kaputt machen, platt drücken,
an die Wand drücken oder dass der Hörnerv,
der ist ja auch von so einem Netz an Versorgungsblutgefäßen umfasst,
wenn man also jetzt durch irgendwelche anderen operativen Eingriffe Schwierigkeiten
hat, dass diese Blutgefäße alle schon mal hinüber sind und deswegen der Hörnerv entsprechend...
Da hilft es dann auch nicht mehr, in der Strecke irgendwas zu induzieren,
weil da gibt es nicht groß weitergeleitet werden kann.
Und das sind alles Dinge, die klinisch abgeklärt werden müssen vorher.
Und wenn dann aber alles soweit in Ordnung ist, was in der Regel bei der Mehrzahl
der Patienten der Fall ist, dann müssen die Patienten natürlich operiert werden.
Dann braucht man einen erfahrenen, möglichst guten Chirurgen,
der das gut gelernt hat, gut kann, gute Erfahrungen hat und der implantiert das dann.
Und das geht eigentlich relativ schnell.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass diese Operationen so invasiv, so tiefgreifend sind,
wie wenn man zum Beispiel einen Hirntumor hat.
Also wenn man jetzt ans Gehirn ran muss, dann muss man wirklich die Schädelkalotte
aufmachen, dann muss man durch die Innenauskleidung der Schädelkalotte durch.
Und das ist alles schon sehr invasiv und ist auch natürlich in der Presse,
in den Medien immer alles ganz schwer gewichtet.
Das ist zum Glück bei diesen Ohr- und auch Cochlear-Implantaten alles nicht so wahnsinnig schlimm.
Man muss ja auch überlegen, dass diese ganze Region von dem...
Von dem Felsenbein sowieso schon so ein bisschen mit der Außenwelt in Kontakt ist.
Wir haben da die Ohrtrompete, die östere Röhre, das Mittelohr.
Das ist ja alles eigentlich dafür gebaut, sich ständig irgendwie mit Fremdkeimen
und Infektionen auseinanderzusetzen und hat auch entsprechende Selbsthilfemechanismen eingebaut.
Mit anderen Worten, das ist jetzt nicht so, ich wiederhole es nochmal,
nicht so inversiv, als wenn man ans Gehirn ran müsste.
Was ja sehr gut gekapselt ist und normalerweise keinerlei Besucher empfängt.
Genau, möglichst auch keine Öffnungen, Risse und sonstige Lücken nach außen haben sollte.
Und deswegen kann man diese Operation vergleichsweise schnell machen und ein
erfahrener Chirurg, der schafft das in unter zwei Stunden.
Und das gilt natürlich nur für das, also diese Zeitangabe gilt jetzt nur für
das, was der Chirurg sieht.
Also vom Einsenken des Skalpells in die Hautoberfläche bis zum Zunähen,
Das geht in unter zwei Stunden bei einem erfahrenen Chirurg,
der schon einiges gemacht hat und wenn keine irgendwie Absonderlichkeiten auftreten.
Und das, was natürlich der Patient und die Angehörigen sehen,
das ist natürlich ein bisschen länger, weil die müssen ja erstmal dann runter
in den OP gekarrt werden.
Das ist ja das, wo die Patienten dann dann ihre Narkose kriegen und ab dem Zeitpunkt,
bis sie dann wieder aufwachen, das können dann also schon mal vier,
fünf, sechs Stunden sein.
Von außen sieht das nach viel aus, aber der eigentliche Eingriff ist gar nicht
so lange. Auch die eigentliche Zeit, in der man in der Narkose ist,
ist gar nicht so wahnsinnig lange.
Also das ist eigentliche Öffnen, Einfüllen zu machen, ist nach einer Stunde vorbei?
Ist nach etwa eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden vorbei. Ist also nicht so wahnsinnig schlimm.
Ja, ne, so lange bin ich auch schon mal in der Hand operiert worden.
Ja, genau. Das ist also durchaus überschaubar und es ist auch heutzutage,
die Anästhesisten haben natürlich auch dazugelernt heutzutage sogar,
Der Standard, dass die Patienten am Nachmittag nach der OP schon wieder halbwegs
beieinander sind. Also bei kleinen Kindern, die da sowieso offensichtlich ein
bisschen robuster sind, die krabbeln dann schon wieder rum, haben zwar einen
Verband um den Kopf, aber die sind dann schon wieder halbwegs fit.
Ältere Patienten, denen es körperlich nicht besonders gut geht,
die sitzen dann vielleicht mal einen Tag lang da und denen ist schlecht und
sie sind am nächsten Tag oder am übernächsten Tag wieder halbwegs auf der Höhe.
Aber so der durchschnittliche Erwachsene, der kann am Abend schon wieder Fernseh
gucken und mit einem reden und was heißt, wenn er kommunizieren kann.
Was wird denn noch alles eingebaut? Also wir haben jetzt von dieser Glasnudel
gesprochen, die wird da reingeschoben und dann muss ja auch noch eine Verbindung
nach außen geben. Also da gibt es dann so ein Kontaktplättchen.
Das geht das geht alles elektromagnetisch sozusagen.
Also es ist so, dass unter der Haut jetzt machen wir es mal so.
Man hat ja hier hinter dem Ohr hat man ja so eine kahle Fläche Und der Knochen,
den man da fühlt, das ist das sogenannte Mastoid oder auf Deutsch der Warzenfortsatz.
Da dockt einer von unseren großen Halsmuskeln an, nämlich hier der Sternocleidomastid,
Mastoidäus, der ist für die Kopfwendung zuständig. Der dockt an diesem Knochen an.
Und dieser Knochen, von dem muss man sich jetzt vorstellen, geht man so ein
kleines Stückchen nach hinten, ein paar Zentimeter, das muss der Chirurg sich
aber dann in jedem in die Videofall angucken, wo genau.
Und an diese Stelle wird unter die Haut die gekapselte Elektronik des Implantates eingesetzt.
Da wird so ein kleines bisschen vom Knochen weggenommen und dann kann dort die
Elektronik hingesetzt werden und von dieser Elektronik ausgehend.
Gibt es dann die Elektrode, das ist dann eben diese Silikonglasnudel,
von der wir gesprochen haben.
Die geht dann von dort weg, erstmal zum Mittelohr.
Der Chirurg, der muss also praktisch von hinter dem Ohr sich zum Mittelohr durchbewegen
und wenn der erstmal in der Mittelohrhöhlung angekommen ist,
dann sieht er auch vor sich die Gehörknöchelchen und geht dann seitlich an den
Gehörknöchelchen dran vorbei zum runden Fenster oder knapp daneben und macht
dort auf und setzt dann die eigentliche Stimulationselektrode,
von denen eben nur die vorderen ungefähr 2,5-3 Zentimeter elektrisch aktiv sind,
setzt die dann in die Schneckenwindung ein, indem er diese Elektrode langsam
und vorsichtig vorschiebt und wenn er merkt, dass da Widerstand kommt,
dann zieht er noch ein bisschen zurück, verdreht vielleicht ein bisschen und
geht noch mal ran, bis er die Elektrode vollständig drin hat.
Dann macht er diese Eingangsöffnung in die Kochlehr,
in die Schnecke, macht er sauber zu, setzt also ein bisschen Bindegewebe drum rum,
dass das schön fest wächst und schön dicht ist, verankert dann die Elektrode
im Mittelohr, idealerweise noch auf eine Form, auf eine Art und Weise,
dass da nicht sich das wieder rausziehen kann.
Das muss nicht unbedingt gemacht werden, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit so extrem
niedrig ist, dass das passiert.
Aber manche Chirurgen machen das, dass sie diese Elektrode im Mittelohr noch
mal fixieren und dann wird an der Stelle, wo die gekapselte Elektronik sitzt,
wird dann halt wieder wieder zugemacht, zugenäht.
Und das war's dann eigentlich schon.
Und dann hat man so hinter dem Ohr so einen eingebauten Kontakt,
das bleibt dann aber unter der Haut.
Bleibt unter der Haut. Also von außen sieht man nach der OP erstmal natürlich die OP-Narbe.
Das ist klar, muss ja auf und wieder zugemacht werden. Aber das ist üblicherweise
unter den Haaren. Das sieht man dann also nicht mehr, wenn die Haare da sind.
Normalerweise muss man da so ein bisschen die Haare wegmachen.
Also eine Zeit lang hat man dann da so ein bisschen eine gerade Stelle.
Stelle, aber das ist ja nach kurzer Zeit wieder da.
Und dann sieht man von außen erstmal gar nichts.
Dann setzt man an diesen Kontakt, ist das dann irgendwie so magnetisch?
Ja, also das Implantat, was unter der Haut sitzt, das hat einen Magnet im Zentrum der Empfangsspule.
Also das Implantat hat eine Spulenwindung, die auch im Silikon drin sitzt und
im Zentrum dieser Spulenwindung sitzt ein Magnet. Das ist alles unter der Haut.
Und außen auf die Haut, wenn dann der Zeitpunkt der ersten Aktivierung gekommen
ist, setzt man eine gegenüberliegende Sendespule.
Das ist so eine Art Scheibe, die per Kabel mit dem hörgeräteartig aussehenden
eigentlichen Prozessor verbunden ist.
Und diese Sendespule hat auch wieder ein Magnet. Und wenn man die da hinsetzt,
dann zieht sich die automatisch an die
stelle hin natürlich nur aus ein paar millimeter abstand
weil so groß so stark können die magnete nicht sein dann zieht
sich die sendung spule in die gegenüber liegende position von der unter der
haut sitzenden empfängerspule und die beiden spulen die kommunizieren dann so
miteinander wie das zwei transformator spulen miteinander tun außer dass man
den elektrischen den eisen an kann jetzt irgendeine eine Elektronik,
also ist jetzt in dem was eingesetzt wird.
Da ist eine Elektronik drin. Wo befindet die sich konkret?
Die befindet sich in einem in einer Titanenkapsel.
Das ist also jetzt im Grunde genommen so ähnlich wie Herzschrittmacher-Technik.
Man hat also eine Titanenkapsel, eine hermetisch dichte Titanenkapsel.
Da drin befindet sich die Elektronik und aus der Titanenkapsel gibt aber einige
elektrische Durchführungen nach außen.
Zwei gehen raus und bilden eine Empfängerspule, eine Schlaufe sozusagen,
die von außen Energieversorgung bekommt und digital codierte Informationen bekommt.
In der Kapsel selber drin sitzt ein einigermaßen komplizierter Chip,
der die digitale Information dekodiert.
Und es gibt natürlich noch jede Menge andere Elektronik-Elemente,
die da drin sind. Also es gibt, was man vielleicht als wichtigstes mal dazu
sagen sollte, das Implantat selber hat keinerlei Energieversorgung.
Da ist also kein Akku drin, keine Batterie, nichts, was aufgeladen werden muss.
Das kommt alles von außen.
Und anders als bei Herzschrittmachern, die ja entweder aufgeladen werden müssen
oder durch eine neue OP ausgetauscht werden müssen, ist das da nicht notwendig.
Das kommt also alles ausschließlich von außen sowohl die Energieversorgung als auch die Information.
Das heißt, wenn man den Clip abmacht, ist das Ding komplett raus?
Schlagartig das Ding inaktiv. Das hat vielleicht noch ein bis fünf Millisekunden, je nach Hersteller.
Ja, aber im Prinzip ist es sofort Ende.
Okay, aber im Prinzip diese Elektronik in dieser Titan-Kapsel,
die setzt letztlich die digitale Eingangsinformation um in konkrete Impulse auf den Elektronen.
Aber der digitale Datenstrom selber ist zumindest schon mal so weit voroptimiert,
dass der Grad an Processing, der da jetzt gemacht werden muss, nicht mehr so enorm ist.
Also da wird jetzt keiner große akustische Berechnung mehr gemacht,
sondern es geht eigentlich nur noch darum, aus dem digitalen Eingangssignal
die richtige Information auf die richtige Elektrode umzusetzen.
Aber diese ganze Entscheidung, welche Elektrode sollte jetzt wann,
in welcher Intensität feuern, die liegt komplett außerhalb des Körpers.
Ganz genau. Wo sie auch gut aufgehoben
ist, weil da kann man sie immer verbessern, besser monitoren etc.
Das heißt, man legt sich jetzt sagen
wir mal auch mit dem Implementat sich technologisch noch nicht so fest.
Also man schafft eigentlich nur die Voraussetzung an die richtige Stelle zu
kommen und lagert das komplett nach draußen aus und die Box,
die dann da draußen damit verbunden ist, die definiert, wie gut das Ganze funktioniert.
Also man kann so richtig Firmware-Updates runterladen und kann besser hören.
Ja, ganz so einfach ist das nicht. Also in der Zeit früher,
als die Implantatelektronik noch völlig primitiv oder irgendwann mal gar nicht vorhanden war,
Stichwort Steckerimplantat, Da war man extrem limitiert durch das,
was das Implantat konnte, außer bei diesen Steckerimplantaten, weil die waren passiv.
Das waren also für den bastelnden Nerd waren die Steckerimplantate das Perfekte.
Da konnte man alles anflanschen, was man wollte.
Aber die Implantate sind natürlich in vielerlei Hinsicht spezialisiert auf das,
was man derzeit weiß, was das derzeit machbarste ist.
Und wenn so ein Implantat konstruiert ist, dass es zum Beispiel zeitgleich nur
einen einzigen Puls abgeben kann auf einer Elektrode und auf der anderen halt nicht.
Dann kann man nie auf so eine Konfiguration kommen. Dass man eben zum Beispiel
ausprobiert, wenn wir das schlau vorausbrechen, dann können wir ja doch wieder parallel stimulieren.
Wenn das Implantat das nicht kann, zum Beispiel, weil eine Stromquälerei oben
durchgeschaltet wird, dann kann das Implantat das nicht.
Also das sind nach wie vor bis heute sind das Limitierungen,
die jetzt einerseits natürlich deswegen existieren, weil man es noch nicht besser
weiß, weil man noch keine noch schlauere gefunden hat, wie man es machen muss.
Andererseits natürlich auch einfach auf Grund von Energieoptimierungen,
weil das sind jetzt nur wirklich Systeme, bei denen es extrem auf Leistungsverbrauch ankommt.
Das ist noch viel härter als das, was wir jetzt hier mit Mobilgeräten haben.
Die wollen wir natürlich, dass sie möglichst lange laufen. Ja,
schön, wenn man ganzen Tag mit dem Handy rund kommt und nicht schon unter dem
Tag aufladen muss, ist das alles wünschenswert.
Aber wenn so ein Patient alle zwei Stunden, theoretisch so ist es nicht,
aber alle zwei Stunden da immer wieder neue Akkus reinschieben muss oder immer
neue Batterien, dann ist das eine Kurbel noch hinter dem Ohr hat.
Dann ist das einfach von der Praktikabilität im Alltag, dann wäre das so schlecht,
dass das unheimlich an Wert verlieren würde.
Und deswegen sind diese Systeme in vielerlei Hinsicht extremer als das meist
andere, was es gibt, auf Leistungsverbrauch optimiert.
Das sind also im strengsten Sinne wirklich wearable devices,
wo dieses Schlagwort ja so immer wieder mal rumgeistert.
Und unter anderem deswegen sind die teilweise auch alles andere als universell,
sondern eben hochgradig spezialisiert auf das, was die jeweilige,
Entwicklergruppe in der Firma oder früher in den Labores sich ausgedacht haben,
was sie jetzt machen wollen.
Mit welcher Bitrate wird da reingetröpfelt? Was leistet dieses Interface?
Ja, also das Ganze wird natürlich über eine Hochfrequenzstrecke versorgt.
Diese ist eine HF-Kommunikation zwischen diesen beiden Spulen.
Und die Trägerfrequenz dieser HF liegt zwischen 5 und 50 MHz, je nach System.
Und da drauf kann man natürlich digital codiert auch immer nur durch ein- und
ausschalten dieser HF dann digitale Informationen drauf beraten.
Braucht natürlich eine gewisse Redundanz. Man kann ja nicht,
wenn man ein Bit auf eine Welle sozusagen drauflegt, dann ist das ziemlich wahrscheinlich,
dass da ständig Informationsfehler auftreten.
Das muss man also genügend Abstand
dazu haben und auch Korrekturbits oder solche Dinge mit reinrechnen.
Aber im Wesentlichen kann man sich aus dieser Trägerfrequenz dann schon ungefähr
ausrechnen, was man an Informationen hat.
Also wenn man jetzt mal von einem hypothetischen System von sagen wir mal 10
MHz Trägerfrequenz ausgeht,
was sagen wir mal 10 Halbwellen braucht,
um ein Bit zu kodieren, also 10 HF Wellen braucht, um ein Bit zu kodieren,
dann hat man da eine Bit Reihenübertragung von vielleicht einem Megabit oder so.
Das ist aber jetzt wirklich nur eine Hausnummer und die Zahlen,
die ich jetzt hier gesagt habe, die liegen irgendwo so im Mittelwert zwischen
dem was die Hersteller machen. Also das was ich jetzt genannt habe trifft auf
keinen von den Herstellern zu.
Ja gut, aber ich meine Megabit ist dann wirklich ausreichend um jetzt diese 6,
7, 8, 10 Elektroden damit Informationen
zu zu beliefern. Nur mal so eine Vorstellung zu bekommen davon.
Jetzt ist ja jedes Implantat eine sehr spezielle Anpassung an eine Person.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das eingebaut ist, wo der chirurgische Eingriff
vorgenommen wurde und das vielleicht auch schon, ich weiß nicht,
wie lange man nach so einer Operation dann wartet, bis so was in Betrieb genommen
wird, aber nicht gleich am nächsten Tag.
Nee, nee, man, ja, es gibt natürlich viele Leute, die hätten das ganz gerne
am nächsten Tag, aber wir warten normalerweise so zwischen vier und sechs Wochen.
Das hat auch wirklich handfeste Gründe. Erstens ist nach der Operation natürlich
noch die Haut eher mal geschwollen und man hat noch eine OP-Nabe.
Das dauert also, bis das sich einigermaßen wieder auf den Normalzustand reduziert.
Das kann also sein, dass die Haut noch zu dick ist, dass der Magnet gar nicht
hält, dass man das gar nicht wirklich mechanisch stabil hinbekommt.
Und dann gibt es aber noch einen anderen Grund und zwar den,
dass das wirklich sauber und
zuverlässig eingeheilt sein soll und fest drinsitzen soll ohne Wackler,
ohne Wackelmöglichkeit meine ich damit, weil man sich ja vorstellen muss,
dass die Patienten da täglich oder alle paar Stunden zumindest ihr externes
System aufsetzen und wieder abnehmen. Aufsetzen, abnehmen.
Mindestens einmal am Tag aufsetzen, abnehmen. Das heißt, man hat immer durch
diesen Magnet, den man draußen draufsetzt und der innen auch,
jetzt hat man immer so eine kleine mechanische Wackelkomponente.
Wenn die Sache mal schön eingewachsen ist und alles stabil ist,
ist das nicht auch nur ansatzweise ein Problem. Das ist einfach dann völlig okay.
Aber wenn man das in den ersten Tagen nach der OP anfangen würde,
frisch eingebracht, dann könnte es sein, dass man das Ding dann durch diese
permanente mechanische, dass man das sozusagen wieder locker wackelt.
Da können alle möglichen Sachen passieren, die unangenehm sind und deswegen
machen praktisch alle Kliniken,
die von denen ich weiß wie die das machen, warten zumindest ein paar Wochen
ab bis das dann aktiviert wird.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich auch für den Patienten insofern dann auch ganz sinnvoll,
dass das dann auch alles so die erste Aufregung nur auf diese Operation bezieht,
dass sich das schon mal gesetzt hat.
Man weiß, es ist jetzt in mir drin, aber kann immer noch geradeaus gehen und
so. Also es hat jetzt keine unmittelbaren negativen Auswirkungen.
Wenn es welche gegeben hätte, hätte man die jetzt schon bemerkt.
Und jetzt ist man auch bereit, da einen neuen Schritt zu gehen.
Ja, und das sieht dann die erste Aktivierung, die sieht dann so aus,
dass man eben nach diesen einigen Wochen die Patienten wieder in die Klinik bekommt.
Die meisten Kliniken hier in Deutschland nehmen die dann auf für ein,
zwei, drei Tage oder so, weil man ja viele Sachen erstmal ausprobieren muss.
Gibt allerdings natürlich auch gerade da, wo die Sparefrohs regieren,
Kliniken, die das versuchen, an einem Tag zu machen. Also in den USA wird das teilweise so gemacht.
Die kommen morgens rein, dann wird das eingeschaltet. Und teilweise sogar bei
der OP. Das ist also, finde ich, ganz fürchterlich.
So schlimm ist das zum Glück bei uns nicht.
Wir haben die Möglichkeit, die Patienten in die Klinik für ein oder zwei oder
drei Nächte aufzunehmen.
Und dann bei so einer Sitzung bekommen die dann in dem Moment bei der ersten
Aktivierung, bekommen die dann diesen externen Teil überhaupt erst mal.
Da ist natürlich alles Mögliche noch mit drin.
Betriebsanleitung und ein paar Zubehör- und Ersatzteile und ich weiß nicht,
ein Kofferchen, in dem das alles aufbewahrt wird und so.
Das erschlägt das die meisten Patienten so ein bisschen, dass sie da auf einmal
so einen Koffer kriegen. Aber der eigentliche Teil ist dann die Aktivierung des Implantats.
Da sitzt man dann also mit dem Patienten in einem normalen, etwas akustisch
geschützten Raum und fängt an, das Implantat zu aktivieren.
Wie viel Kommunikation mit dem Patienten gab es denn vorher schon?
Also inwiefern war vorher ein Informationsaustausch erforderlich?
Ja, eigentlich ist eine Menge Informationsaustausch erforderlich.
Es ist ein Informationsaustausch.
Da bin ich vorhin so ein bisschen salopp drüber hinweggegangen. Vor der OP notwendig.
Es reicht nicht aus, nur diese medizinische Machbarkeit zu diagnostizieren.
Ist das die Schnecke noch in Ordnung? Können wir es überhaupt machen und so
weiter? So man muss auch mit den Patienten sprechen. Man muss auch mal abtasten,
was die sich eigentlich erwarten davon.
Und es gibt dann natürlich auch völlig bizarre.
Unrealistische Erwartungen, so nach dem Motto dieses Implantat wird jetzt mein Leben zum Guten wenden.
Das ist zwar de facto bei vielen Patienten dann so, aber die Erwartungen können
auch viel zu hoch sein, dass die Patienten glauben, wenn das Ding dann eingeschaltet
wird, können sie wieder telefonieren.
Das ist erstmal nicht so und es ist auch nicht bei allen Patienten zwingend
so, dass das jemals geht. Also bei sehr vielen wird es so weit kommen,
dass sie telefonieren können.
Aber es bleibt auch immer ein gar nicht so kleiner Prozentsatz,
ob ich der das eben nie können wird.
Und wenn dann aber die Patienten beispielsweise schlechte Voraussetzungen haben,
zum Beispiel die waren schon 30 Jahre taub und das Ding hatte das ganze neuronale
System hatte, endlos Zeit schön zu degenerieren.
Und wenn dann die Erwartung ist, wenn ich das Ding jetzt kriege,
dann kann ich spätestens bis Weihnachten mit meiner Tochter telefonieren.
Dann muss man schon mal wirklich sagen, dass das noch nicht so ist.
Und das ist natürlich Aufgabe vieler Leute an der Klinik. Da bin ich in diesem
Vorfeld bin ich normalerweise noch nicht drin, aber das machen dann eben die
Mediziner, die dann sich darum auch...
Ich meine, mit Ihnen sprechen ist natürlich gut gesagt bei Leuten,
die eigentlich nicht mehr hören können. Das heißt, das ist ja auch alles so
eine schriftliche Kommunikation dann wahrscheinlich.
Und in dem Moment, wo man dann wirklich zu ihnen, also ich kann mir das sehr
schwierig ist, sich in so eine Situation reinzuversetzen, wo man wirklich denkt,
man ist jetzt akustisch komplett getrennt.
Man weiß zwar irgendwie, Leute haben einem etwas aufgeschrieben etc.
Dann wird das Ding aktiviert, was passiert dann? Also das heißt ja,
im Idealfall unmittelbar mit dem einschalten auf einmal,
das was wir als hören kennen einsetzt oder?
Nee, so muss man sich das vorstellen. Also es also was die Kommunikation angeht.
Hab ich mir mit Patienten, mit denen es nicht anders geht, angewöhnt,
dass ich einfach am Bildschirm tippe.
Ich habe da halt meinen meinen Rechner, der auch das Anpasssystem hat.
Muss er das irgendwie technisch kontrollieren? Ich habe da halt meinen Bildschirm.
Dann mache ich mir irgendwie ein Editor auf, klappt das, klappt im Bildschirm
zum Patienten drüber und tippt mit denen. Man schattet erst mal ein bisschen
und man schattet erst mal. Das entspannt die, dann fühlen die sich ernst genommen,
weil die haben jahrelang erlebt, dass Leute sich nicht die Mühe machen,
ihnen was aufzuschreiben.
Die rennen zwar vielleicht mit einem Blöckchen durch die Welt und fordern jeden
auf, schreib es mir doch auf bitte, aber das wird natürlich allen irgendwann mal viel zu mühsam.
Und in so einer Situation, wenn man dann so einen Rechner hat und einigermaßen
flott über den Bildschirm schriftlich kommunizieren kann, da kommen dann auch
manchmal so ein paar Sachen raus, die man dann erst mal so richtig transportiert.
Und mehrseits in das jetzt hört der Patient mal wirklich, worauf es jetzt dann
sofort ankommt, was jetzt wirklich passiert.
Und das ist dann eben das, womit man anfängt. Man schaltet also nicht das System schlagartig ein,
das geht natürlich nicht, sondern wir haben ja diese Elektrodenkontakte in der
Cochlea sitzen, wie viele immer das sind, und die testet man alle der Reihe nach durch.
Man gibt jetzt erstmal einfache...
Höhne und Rundtippen, eine Elektrode nach der anderen.
Das macht man auch gar nicht über das externe System, sondern das macht man
unter direkter unmittelbarer Ansteuerung vom Rechner aus. Man hat also den Rechner,
spezialisierte Hardware. Von dieser Hardware geht man dann sozusagen direkt zum Implantat.
Dass man gar kein Wandelproblem hat.
Den hat man noch gar nicht. Man geht also gar nicht erst auch nur ansatzweise
auf dem akustischen Weg, sondern alles digital direkt vom Rechner kontrolliert.
Und dann wählt man halt am Rechner,
wählt man entsprechende Elektrodenkontakte an und schaltet die ein,
schaltet die aus, stimuliert die, aktiviert die und versucht von den Patienten
Angaben darüber zu bekommen, wie sie das wahrnehmen.
Also wie ist die Lautstärke oder soll man noch ein bisschen lauter machen,
ist das jetzt gleich laut wie der andere, ist die Tonhöhe unterschiedlich etc.
Dann tastet man sich so nach und nach über die Elektrodenkontakte,
die die Patienten haben, der Reihe nach durch.
Versucht so alle ungefähr auf die gleiche Lautstärke zu bringen.
Und dann schaltet man das Gesamtsystem mal ein mit akustischem Eingang von außen,
dass also jetzt schon dann das Spektralanalyseprozedere losgeht,
dass das Mikrofon akustische Signale aufnimmt, das Spektral analysiert und das
dann auf die Elektroden in dem Maße drauf abbildet, wie man das unmittelbar
vorher eingestellt hat.
Und dann hat man,
bei Patienten, die sehr gute Voraussetzungen haben.
Das sind oft welche, die nur ganz kurz taub waren und bis dahin dann aber noch normalhöhrend waren.
Also der klassische Fall, Patient hatte einen Arbeitsunfall mit Schädelbasisfraktur,
die dann blöderweise auch noch durchs Felsenbein so durchging,
dass die schlagartig aus einem völlig normalhöhrenden Zustand in die Taubheit gefallen sind.
Und wenn man dann auch noch nicht allzu lange wartet, wenn man dann schon ein
halbes Jahr später das Implantateinsatz, Dann ist das manchmal so,
wie wenn man Radio einschaltet.
Und dann kann man kann man gleich mit denen reden. Das ist aber die Ausnahme.
Das ist vielleicht ich würde mal so aus dem Bauch heraus sagen,
vielleicht bei fünf Prozent der Patienten ist das der Fall.
Viele Patienten hören Geräusche. Dann fängt man natürlich erst mal an,
wenn das Ding dann läuft und aktiviert ist. Fängt man erst mal an mit irgendwelchen
Geräuschen. Man klopft mal auf den Tisch, pock pock pock, so ein dumpfes Signal.
Mal klatscht man in die Hände. Das ist schön laut. Da kommt schon was rüber und man sieht es auch.
Und dann ist das schon das Breitbandiges, so ein schlagartiges Signal.
Dann haben wir diverse Soundspielzeuge immer an diesen Anpassplätzen rumliegen.
Dann nimmt man sich hier mal so ein Glas und dängelt mal mit Metall dagegen.
Und dann hören die Sachen, die die vielleicht 30 Jahre nicht mehr gehört haben.
Hohe Zwilnen. Ist das nicht irgendwie super emotional auch?
Ja, ich habe da schon, da sind erwachsene Leute schon in Tränen ausgebrochen.
Also wirklich einer der schönsten Fall, das gibt es sogar als Video,
das ist schon ewig her, das war als wir damals dieses CIS-artige System mit
dieser CIS-Strategie erst mal gebaut hatten.
Dann bin ich bei einer der ersten Kliniken gewesen, die das eingesetzt haben,
das war in Wien und bin dann nach Wien gefahren, habe dann so eine Einstellungssitzung
gemacht und da saß so ein totaler Wiener Grantler vor mir. mir.
Der war Fleischhauer, wie das in Wien heißt. Also der war in so einer großen...
Wie nennt man das? So eine Industrie-Schlachterei. Er war Schlachter.
Ich weiß nicht, was er da genau gemacht hat. Schweinehälften zerteilt oder keine Ahnung.
Und er war auch dort verunfallt. Der hatte dort auch irgendwie war der mit dem
Kopf auf irgendeine keine Ahnung, so eine Kante aufgeschlagen, war taub.
Und der so ein richtiger Grantler, der saß da vor, hat man schon 1000 Sachen
mit mir probiert und nichts hat funktioniert. Und jetzt das auch noch.
Jetzt habe ich noch diese OP machen müssen, so ungefähr.
Und da habe ich gedacht, boah, das wird hart, ob da mal was bei rauskommt.
Und dann habe ich das halt da aktiviert.
Und als ich das Ding eingeschaltet habe, dann blühte der auf einmal auf.
Ich verstehe, was Sie sagen. Sagen Sie doch noch mal was.
Also ich weiß, es ist jetzt nur diese emotionale Situation. Und dann war in
dem Moment einer von den jungen Assistenzärzten,
die sich für diese Sache interessierten, inzwischen Professor und weltweit bekannt,
der war da mit dabei und dem fielen die Augen raus.
Der ist zum Telefon gestürzt, hat seinen Chef, was der Klinikdirektor war,
hat der angerufen, sie müssen sofort runterkommen, ein Wunder ist geschehen, ein Wunder.
Und dann habe ich den Patienten mitsamt dem Gerät, habe ich erst mal rausgeschickt,
dann ist der eine rauchen gegangen oder was und stand dann im Eingangsbereich von dem Klinikum,
da wo diese die ganzen Autos durchkommen und auch mal eine Ambulanz hilft und
es regnete und es regnete und da stand er da unter dem Dach,
rauchte eine und dann kam er wieder zurück und erzählte er Er hat die Scheibenwischer
von dem Taxi quietschen hören.
Unglaublich, und dann sind uns alle die Tränen geflossen und so und das war
alles ganz toll und schön und das war alles wunderbar und aus diesem ur-Krantlerischen
schlechtgelaunten Menschen war ein glücklicher Mensch geworden für zumindest diese Zeit,
aber ich habe den dann immer wieder mal so in den wenigen Jahren danach noch
gesehen und der hatte sich da also wirklich in vielerlei Hinsicht wieder gefangen.
Das sind diese emotionalen Sachen.
Ja, Mensch, hier Sendung wird auch schon ganz emotional. Wir brechen hier alle Längenrekorde.
Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt auch langsam mal auf die Zielgerade bringen.
Stellt sich eigentlich noch die Frage, gibt es noch irgendeinen Aspekt,
den du gerne noch hinterher werfen möchtest? Wir haben jetzt hier einen langen
Ritt gemacht, einmal durchs ganze Ohr.
Diese Implantate spielen schon eine besondere Rolle. Guck mich so den Eindruck,
also das ist im Prinzip so die Kür, kann man sagen. Also näher ans Hirn kann
man fast schon gar nicht kommen, zumindest nicht mit so perfekten Ergebnissen.
Ja, also vielleicht, das sollten wir vielleicht noch ganz kurz anreißen.
Es kann ja auch mal sein, dass der Hörnerpfund nicht mehr da ist,
zum Beispiel durch ein Tumor zerstört ist und dann kann man in der Kochlehrer
nicht mehr elektrisch reizen, das wird einfach nicht weitergeleitet.
Das Kabel ist nicht mehr da. Da gibt es dann noch so eine, sagen wir mal,
eine Notlösung, indem man nämlich jetzt die Elektrodenspitze,
diese was bisher die Glasnudel war, jetzt ein bisschen anders konstruiert.
Alles andere bleibt gleich, aber die Glasnudel wird jetzt nicht eine Glasnudel,
sondern ein kleines Paddel, an dessen Unterseite die Elektrodenkontakte sitzen.
Dieses Paddel legt man an die Stelle am Hirnstamm auf, Das war's für heute.
Hinter der der Hörnerv gerade eingemündet ist. Das ist der Nucleus cochlearis
heißt das. Das muss natürlich jetzt von einem Neurochirurgen gemacht werden
und da haben wir die Sache jetzt ist das auf einmal eine invasive Hirn-OP.
Also in dem Moment wird dann quasi die Hörstücke komplett abgetrennt.
Die ist völlig außer außen vor. Es gibt sogar Fälle, muss man auch dazu sagen,
es gibt sogar Fälle wo nur der Hörnerv zum Beispiel durch ein Tumor zerstört
wurde oder der Tumor muss raus weil sonst lebensgefährlich und so weiter.
Der Tumor muss raus und der Hörnerv klebt so verwachsen dran an dem Tumor.
Also der Tumor hat den Hörnerv so durchdrungen oder so verwachsen,
dass der Hörnerv mit bei drauf geht, mit rauskommt automatisch.
Und dann kann die Kochlehrer das Innenohr sogar noch normalhöhrend sein.
Es gibt solche Fälle, wo das Innenohr eigentlich noch normalhöhrend ist.
Alle Hörzeilen, alle H-Zeilen sind kaputt.
Nur die Verbindung ist kaputt.
Das Kabel, die Verbindung, also jetzt Kabel, etwas salopp gesprochen,
ist gekappt und dann hat man trotzdem keine Chance mit einem Kochleimplantat,
logischerweise. Dann gibt es eben noch das sogenannte Hirnstammimplantat oder
auf Englisch Auditory Brain Stem Implant, ABI.
Und das ist eine viel schwieriger Prozedur, wird viel seltener gemacht und hat
im Durchschnitt auch viel schlechtere Ergebnisse. Aber es ist sozusagen der
letzte Notnagel, den man dann noch hat.
Und ganz neue Entwicklungen versuchen sogar,
selbst wenn da schon nichts mehr gehen sollte, was zum Beispiel manchmal bei
starken Bestrahlungen der Fall ist,
dass das Nervengewebe dort so geschehig ist durch die Bestrahlung,
dass auch das nicht mehr geht, noch eine Ebene höher zu gehen und da sind die
Resultate noch schlechter.
Je näher man sich nach oben bewegt mit der ersten Einspeisung des Signals, desto im Durchschnitt,
Schlechter kann man zumindest nach derzeitigen Wissenstand sagen.
Schlechter sind die Ergebnisse,
weil unter anderem diese ganze vorsortierende Vorverarbeitung in diesen ganzen
Zwischenprozessen, die aus diesem doch sehr grobschlechtigen Signal,
was wir elektrisch in die Kochlehr einspeisen, doch noch irgendwas weiter oben Vernünftiges macht.
Wir umgehen sozusagen mehr und mehr und mehr von diesen Zwischenschritten und
hoffen dann, dass trotzdem noch ansatzweise was funktioniert.
Man müsste eigentlich an der Stelle viel abstrakter mit dem Hirn kommunizieren.
Man muss nur wissen, was es an der Stelle denn überhaupt für eine Sprache spricht.
Ja, und das ist eine wesentliche Sache.
Die Cochlea ist ein eindimensionales Organ. Da ist also jetzt vereinfacht gesagt,
da sind also die Zellen sitzen in einer Linie, es ist spiralisch angeordnet
zwar, aber es sitzt im Prinzip in einer Linie alles nebeneinander.
Man weiß auch in etwa, was für was zuständig ist.
Genau. Und wir haben noch dazu die schöne Situation, dass das in einer festen
Knochenkapsel drin liegt. Und die Lage ist uns durch diese Knochenhöhlung einfach
vorgegeben. Also vergleichsweise leicht das richtig zu positionieren.
Aber so ein Hörnervblundel, das ist so wie wenn man hier auf dem Boden so ein
Telekomkabel ausgräbt.
Ja, genau. Oder wenn man ans Hirn rangeht, man operiert ja eigentlich Pudding.
Da was wo wohin jetzt? Wo ist das genau? Und vor allen Dingen sind diese Strukturen
dort auf einmal schon dreidimensional.
Das geht also sowohl in der Fläche als auch in die Tiefe. Und es ist alles fürchterlich
kompliziert und kreuz und quer miteinander verschaltet.
Und das macht die Sache unglaublich viel schwieriger, da überhaupt sinnvoll
was anzudocken. Natürlich gibt es schöne Fantasien, dass man das irgendwann
mal wird hinbekommen können.
Aber derzeit ist das nicht der Fall.
Und auch schon bei unserem anderen großen Sinnesorgan, dem Auge,
ist es schon viel schwieriger, weil das ist schon zweidimensional.
Also das Ohr ist ja sozusagen nur eindimensional und hat sozusagen nur eine
Frequenzachse, an der wir uns andocken müssen.
Das Auge ist schon zweidimensional und da müssten wir schon eine Fläche andocken
und wissen schon gar nicht mehr, was da alles passiert. Abgesehen davon,
dass es mechanisch auch nochmal schwieriger ist als im Ohr.
Jetzt dreidimensional irgendwo im Gehirn anzudocken, das ist dann noch mal eine Stufe schwieriger.
Das ist auf jeden Fall noch Raum für Erweiterung und Potenzial für weitere Forschung.
Trotzdem schon relativ bemerkenswert, was man jetzt in der kurzen Zeit auch
schon geschafft hat. Ich meine, so der Durchbruch 91 ist jetzt alles gar nicht so lange her.
Ja, naja, das sind ja...
Nennenswerte medizinische Durchbrüche hier durch totalen Elektronik-Hightech erzeugt.
Das leitet dann auch so ein bisschen das Cyborg-Zeitalter ein,
den kulturellen Aspekt, den denke ich auch noch mal aufzugreifen.
Sind da hier schon um einer groß belohnt worden für diesen technischen Durchbruch?
Ist schon eine ziemlich alleinstehende...
Ja, also es hat jetzt gerade letztes Jahr eine sehr große Belohnung gegeben.
Das ist der sogenannte Laske Award, der ist jetzt im Oktober,
glaube ich, 2013 vergeben worden.
Und den haben drei Pionierforscher auf dem Gebiet bekommen und zwar Ingeborg Hochmeier,
mit ihrem Mann zusammen Mitte der 70er das erste mehrkanalige mit mehreren verschiedenen,
also diese spektrale Repräsentation als erstes versucht haben.
Dann Graham Clark, das ist ein Australier, der Ende der 70er Jahre,
Anfang der 80er dann eine gute Arbeitsgruppe zusammengestellt hat und im Prinzip
als Leiter dieser Arbeitsgruppe es im Wesentlichen geschafft hat,
so ein erstes klinisch brauchbares und über das Labor hinaus,
dem Labor entwachsene klinisch verwendbare System auf die Beine zu stellen.
Und dann Blake Wilson, der diese CIS-Strategie zusammen mit seiner Arbeitsgruppe
und in Kooperation mit einer befreundeten Arbeitsgruppe im Labor entwickelt
haben. ist diese schnelle Zerhacker-Strategie.
Also diese drei Leute haben den.
Laska preis gekriegt übrigens zusammen mit Bill Gates der
hat den auch Ich weiß nicht für diese Melinda
Bill Gates Stiftung mit Melinda Gates Und
dieser laska preis ist schon richtig hoch
aufgehängt das ist der wichtigste preis
für medizin für medizinische forschung den die usa zu vergeben haben Und der
ist eigentlich nur noch eine stufe unterm Nobelpreis und damit sind wir jetzt
natürlich auch beim Nobelpreis von dem im Moment noch keiner weiß ob das Cochlea
Implantat oder irgendwelche Forscher auf dem Gebiet den vielleicht mal kriegen werden.
Aber es ist so, dass es ich glaube 83 Nobelpreisträger gibt,
die vorher diesen Laska-Preis gekriegt haben.
So ein bisschen wie Golden Globe und Oscar.
Also der der Laska wird jetzt auch nicht häufiger vergeben, so dass das dann eh...
Automatisch der Fall ist, sondern der wird auch nur einmal im Jahr vergeben
und auch nur an begrenzte Anzahl an Leuten und die Korrelation zwischen den
Laska-Preiskriegen und den Nobelpreiskriegen,
die ist außerordentlich hoch und gerüchteweise ist auch tatsächlich die schwedische
Akademie auf der Suche nach guten Themen.
Ja, nee, nicht, da glaube ich nicht genug. Aber es gehen wirklich Gerüchte rum,
dass das Kochlerimplantat auch mit dem Nobelpreis belohnt werden soll.
Und weil der alte Nobel, der hat ja eigentlich den, ist ja eigentlich gar nicht
der Medizin-Nobelpreis, sondern der Physiologie-Nobelpreis, so hieß der,
glaube ich, ursprünglich und hieß dann irgendwann Physiologie und Medizin.
Und in der allgemeinen Wahrnehmung ist es dann auf einmal nur noch der Medizin-Nobelpreis.
Aber der hat als Vergabebedingungen ja auch positive Auswirkungen auf die Menschheit.
Also dass es wirklich nicht nur Erkenntnisgewinn ist, sondern tatsächlich auch...
Für den Entwicklungsstand oder die Lebensrealität der Menschen eine Rolle spielen
soll, diese Erkenntnisse.
Da hat ja der alte Nobel auch drauf Wert gelegt und deswegen würde das eigentlich
so richtig in Kram passen, dass das Nobelkomitee da sagen würde, das ist was.
Aber wer den kriegt und ob das wirklich passiert, wissen wir noch nicht.
Aber schön wäre das schon.
Wollen wir mal sehen. Wollen wir mal gucken. CAA wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren
gehört, da gibt es dann genug Möglichkeiten, das dann irgendwann nochmal so
mit der uns noch vorstehenden Zukunft abzugleichen.
Bis dahin sage ich erstmal Danke, Stefan, für den mal wieder hier einen längeren
Rekord einstellenden, brechenden CAA.
Sehr interessant, ich habe eine Menge verstanden und weiß jetzt deutlich besser Bescheid als vorher.
Vielen Dank für die Ausführung und an euch hier. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
CIE geht weiter und ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.